AGAIN WE TO THE ASSEMBLY BUT
SUBCOMMITTEE SIX HEARING ON
COVERT NINETEEN RESPONSE THIS
IS THE ASSEMBLY SO FIRST
HEARING IN THE ERA OF SOCIAL
DISTANCING WE'RE USING NEW
TECHNOLOGY VIDEO CONFERENCING A
NEW PUBLIC- PHONE SYSTEM TO
TAKE PUBLIC COMMENT AS WELL AS
REMOTE PANELISTS. LET ME JUST
START OFF BY THANKING THE
SPEAKER STUFF OUR ASSEMBLY RULE
STAFF THE ASSEMBLY SERGEANTS
THE LEGISLATIVE DATA CENTER OUR
BUDGET COMMITTEE STAFF AND MY
PERSONAL STAFF FOR THEIR HARD
WORK IN GETTING THIS COMMITTEE
UP AND RUNNING WE HAD A PRO
CURE- TECHNOLOGY AND TEST
TECHNOLOGY AND SO WE'RE USING
ALL OF THIS FOR THE VERY VERY
FIRST TIME SO- THE LONG WINDED
OPENING IS TO JUST ASK FOR
EVERYBODY'S PATIENCE DURING
THIS FIRST TRIAL RUN AND WE
STAND THEIR ME SOME HICK UPS.
OUR PREFERENCE WOULD OBVIOUSLY
HAVE TO BE TO GO BACK TO RETURN
TO HOW WE'VE ALWAYS DONE
BUSINESS BUT IF THE- COLD TEEN
WORLD WE LIVE IN WITH THE IT IS
VERY. TO BE SAY. TO ENSURE THAT
WE HAVE AN OPEN AND TRAIN AND
TRANSPARENT HEARING TO FULLY
ALLOW PUBLIC PARTICIPATION AND
SINCE THIS BEING CALIFORNIA WE
THINK WE'RE TRYING TO LEVERAGE
ALL THE AVAILABLE TECHNOLOGY.
TO US TO ENSURE THAT WE CAN
HAVE A PUBLIC PROCESS AGAIN
PLEASE GIVE US FEEDBACK- WE
KNOW THAT THIS HEARING WE'RE
GONNA HAVE A FEW BUMPS AND-
ALONG THE WAY BUT DEFINITELY.
LET US KNOW YOUR FEEDBACK
DURING THIS PROCESS SO. TODAY
IN FORTY TWO OH TWO WE ARE ALL
AS YOU NOTICE SOCIALLY DISTANCE
THIS IS A COMMITTEE ROOM THAT
YOU ACTUALLY HOLD. OVER TWENTY
MEMBERS WE HAVE IT ALL WE ARE
ALL OF ELEVEN MEMBERS HERE AND
AS YOU CAN SEE- WE ARE SPACED-
PROPERLY APART WE'VE ALSO A
LIMITED THE AMOUNT OF STAFF IN
THE ROOM. WE DEFINITELY HAVE-
SIGNIFICANTLY YOU WERE STAFF
THERE. NOT. THANK YOU THE LAST
MAN OF THE THEN WE NOR WHAT FOR
HEARING ARE WE OFF HI EVERYBODY
THE OP TO PARTICIPATE FROM HOME
OR FROM THEY'RE ALL REMOTELY WE
HAVE GOTTEN OF TWO. ALREADY
OVER. NINETY FIVE EMAILS THAT
WERE SENT PRIOR TO THE HEARING
SO AGAIN- WE WANT TO MAKE SURE
THAT THERE WAS ADEQUATE PUBLIC
COMMENT ON. IN TERMS OF THE
PUBLIC WHO IS EITHER HERE OR ON
THE PHONE YOU WILL HAVE ONE
MINUTE FOR PUBLIC COMMENT AND
THEN AFTER YOU MAKE YOUR PUBLIC
COMMENT WE ARE ASKING PEOPLE TO
EXIT THE HEARING ROOM. IN TERMS
OF PENELAS ALL OF OUR PANELISTS
ARE APPEARING TODAY REMOTELY
WITH STAFF- THE STAFF AT THE
USUAL USUALLY THE WITNESS TABLE
ARE MODERATING- THE HEARING- OF
THE TEAM AGAIN HAS DONE
EXTENSIVE TESTING WE'VE BEEN
DOING TEST ALL WEEK I WAS ON A-
DRY RUN TEST ON FRIDAY WE'VE
BEEN TESTING IT ALL THROUGH THE
WEEKEND. AGAIN WE HOPE OF FOR A
SMOOTH HEARING BUT JUST
UNDERSTAND THAT THERE MAY BE-
TIME DELAYS THERE COULD BE A
LAG JUST IN TERMS OF TECHNOLOGY
TRANSMISSION- BUT JUST WANT TO
MAKE SURE. THAT WE ARE- YOU
KNOW ASK YOU FOR YOUR PATIENCE
DURING DURING THIS TIME. AGAIN
IN TERMS OF REMOTE PUBLIC
TESTIMONY WE ARE TAKEN OUR
TESTIMONY VIA THE PHONE. THAT
CALL IN NUMBER WHICH WILL BE
HOPEFULLY POSTED RIGHT THERE
IT'S. 877-692-8957 THE ACCESS
CODE IS FOUR EIGHT FIVE THREE.
WHEN YOU GET ON THE PHONE THE
MODERATOR SHOULD ASK YOU TO
HEAR ONE IN ZERO TO GET IN
LINE. SO THAT IS EXTREMELY
IMPORTANT FOR YOU TO GET IN
LINE DON'T HIT ONE ZERO AGAIN
BECAUSE I DON'T TAKE YOU OUT OF
LINE SO JUST TO ONCE. IN YOUR-
WELL TELL YOU WE ALSO HEARD
FEEDBACK AT THE SENATE HEARING
THAT SOMETIMES PEOPLE GOT ON
THE QUEUE BUT WEREN'T CALLED IF
THAT IS THE CASE FEEL FREE TO
CALL THE OFFICE OUR OFFICE AT
NINE ONE SIX. THREE ONE NINE
TWO ZERO NINE NINE DOES THE
ASSEMBLY BUDGET COMMITTEE
OFFICE SO FEEL FREE TO CALL
THAT NUMBER IF FOR SOME REASON.
YOU'RE IN LINE THE NOT GETTING
CALLED OR YOU HAVEN'T YOU HAVE
AN ISSUE. ALSO IF YOU DON'T OR
CAN'T CALL THE AND FEEL FREE TO
EMAIL US WHICH IS AN EMAIL THAT
WE'VE ALREADY SENT. HE WAS A
POSTED. ALREADY ON THE WEBSITE
ITS BUDGET SUB SIX AT A S. M.
DOT C. A. DOT GOV. AGAIN
TODAY'S HEARING IS LIMITED ON
THE DISASTER RESPONSE EFFORTS
THAT HAVE OCCURRED. AND ARE
UNDER WAY AND BASED ON WHAT WE
KNOW TODAY. WE ANTICIPATE MAY
BE COMING. NEXT MONTH THIS
HEARING WILL BE DISCUSSING
ECONOMICAL CAUGHT IDEAS. THE
STATE. CAN LIGHT OF WHAT THE
FOR RESPONSE HAS BEEN SO FAR.
SO I. AGAIN WE'RE GONNA HAVE
OPENING COMMENTS THE TO GO TO A
PANEL. AND WHAT I'D LIKE IS
AFTER THE- WE'D LIKE TO ANY CAN
QUESTION. AND THEN GO TO PUBLIC
COMMENT AFTER THAT. SO I'M JUST
GONNA START MY OPENING WITH MY
OPENING STATEMENT AND ALLOW OUR
OUR- VICE CHAIR TO SEE IF HE
HAS ANY OPENING STATEMENTS A
SEAT AND IF ANY OTHER COMMITTEE
MEMBERS HAVE OPENING STATEMENTS
BUT- AS WE ALL KNOW THE- COVERT
NINETEEN. PANDEMIC WITH SOME
THAT WE FOR C. THIS MERGES SEE
WHICH IS USUALLY YOU USUALLY
WITH MOST DISASTROUS THERE ARE
DISCRETE. AND THEY IMPACT A
CERTAIN NUMBER OF PEOPLE THIS
IS A DISASTER THAT IS IMPACTED
ALL FORTY MILLION CALIFORNIANS.
WORLD BOOK BEFORE WE DO MY
OPENING COMMENTS WE GOT GOT A
SIGNAL TO TAKE BRAWL SO LET'S
LET'S ROLE IN ESTABLISH FORMS
SO. TANG HERE OBERNOLTE I.
BLOOM HERE BRO YOUR FONG HERE
KERR. SMITH GREAT IT'S AGAIN IT
BECAUSE THIS PANDEMIC WAS
UNFORESEEN IN BECAUSE IT'S
AFFECTING EVERY SINGLE
CALIFORNIAN IN OUR STATE- WE
BEFORE WE LEFT APPROPRIATED ONE
POINT ONE BILLION DOLLARS IN
EMERGENCY FUNDS TO THE GOVERNOR
AND WE ALSO AUTHORIZED THE
DISASTER RESPONSE EMERGENCY
OPERATIONS ACCOUNT TO ACCEPT.
OTHER RESERVE FUNDS SO WHEN WE
DID THIS- FIVE WEEKS AGO I
THINK THIS SENSE WAS THIS IS
GOING TO BE A DISCRETE DISASTER
FOR STERN AMOUNT OF TIME- THAT
AT SOME POINT THAT THIS WOULD
BE OVER. NOW THAT WE'VE BEEN IT
IS FOR ABOUT FIVE WEEKSTHIS OF
PANDEMIC COULD LAST
SIGNIFICANTLY LONGER LIFE MAY
NOT COMPLETELY RETURN TO NORMAL
AND TELL WE HAVE A VACCINE
INTEL WE HAVE ACTUALLY HAVE-
TESTING EVERYWHERE THAT'S YOU
READILY ACCESSIBLE IN SO GIVEN
THAT I THINK WE WANT TO GET A
BETTER SENSE OF- BASED ON WHAT
WE- KNOW TODAY- HOW HOW LONG
IT'S- GONNA GO FOR. AND THE
WHAT THE BUDGET EXPECTATIONS
ARE GOING TO BE UP I FIRST I
JUST WANT TO REALLY COMMEND THE
GOVERNOR FOR HIS EXTRAORDINARY
ACTION. LEADING THE STATE AND
REALLY- WORK WITH ALL OUR
COUNTY OUR CITY LEADERS IN
DOING EVERYTHING POSSIBLE TO
THE CURVE ARMS PROUD OF THE
EVERY CALIFORNIA. AND THE
RESPONSE ACROSS OR WE'VE SEEN
OUR IN THE STATE ALL OF US
POINT OTHER WORKING WITH OUR
FIRST AND THE INDUSTRY BUT THEN
ALSO. WERE I EVERYBODY WHO YEAH
I GET YOUR EVERYONE WHO OPENING
SINGLE PHARMACY. EVERY SINGLE
DAY WE SO MANY WHO ARE. TO GO
TO WORK EVERY DAY TO KEEP US
SAFE KEEP US HEALTHY KEEP AS
FAT AND WE'VE ALL DONE AN
AMAZING JOB OF WORKING.
TOGETHER BUT WITH THE
GOVERNOR'S LEADERSHIP WORKING
WITH THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT
ALSO WORKING WITH OUR HEALTH
CARE WORKERS AND REALLY MAKING
SURE THAT. WE HAVE BEEN AHEAD
OF THIS CURVE NOT BEHIND IT-
ONE THING THAT I'VE ALWAYS
RESPECTED THE MOST ABOUT THE
GOVERNOR IS HE'S ONE OF THE
MOST TRANSPARENT PUBLIC
OFFICIALS I'VE EVER KNOWN GOING
BACK TO HIS TIME. WHEN HE WAS
MY MAYOR IN SAN FRANCISCO- IN
TODAY'S COMMITTEE IS ALL ABOUT
TRANSPARENCY WHERE WE'RE GOING
TO BE ASKING QUESTIONS TO GET A
BETTER IDEA OF WHAT THE SCOPE.
ENDEMIC YOU KNOW WHEN HOW LONG
LAST FOR. WHAT WE THINK WILL BE
THE EXPENDITURES ARE WE KNOW
THAT BEFORE WE LEFT IT WAS A
BILLION DOLLARS THAT WAS
APPROPRIATED BUT NOW THE
UNDERSTANDING IS THERE COULD BE
SEVEN BILLION DOLLARS THAT WILL
BE SPENT TO RESPOND TO THIS
PANDEMIC IN CALIFORNIA THAT WE
KNOW OF- OBVIOUSLY. THE
ASSUMPTION IS THAT THE BULK OF
THAT MONEY WILL BE- WILL BE
REIMBURSED BY FEMA BUT ALSO ON
WE WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT WE
UNDERSTAND. WHAT WON'T BE WELL
WILL BE AND WHAT ARE SOME OF
THE SPECIFIC ISSUES REALLY ARE
COMMITTEE TODAY IS TO PROVIDE
THE PROPER OVERSIGHT OVER THAT
SPENDING BUT ALSO TO BE A
PARTNER. IN THAT PROCESS. WE
KNOW THAT THERE IS A MODEL THAT
HAS BEEN DRIVING THE THINKING
OF THE STATE OF THE GOVERNOR-
WE THINK THAT'S I PERSONALLY
THINK THAT'S GREAT THAT PUBLIC
HEALTH OFFICIALS ARE DRIVING
THE THINKING. ARE REALLY
DRIVING THE RESPONSE HOWEVER
THE MODEL THE STATE HAS PUT
FORWARD- SAYS IT'S OUR PEAK IS
AROUND MID MAY. WHEN THE OTHER
PUBLIC MODELS HAVE THE PEAK AS
A WEEK AGO SO WE JUST ONE
UNDERSTAND WHAT THE DIFFERENCES
WERE SOME OF THE DIFFERENCES IN
THE ASSUMPTIONS. AND REALLY- OR
STAND WITH THE DIFFERENCE OF A
PEAK IN MID MAY WHAT DOES THAT
MEAN IN TERMS OF THE STATE'S
RESPONSE IN TERMS OF
EXPENDITURES. BUT ALSO. WHAT
THAT MEANS ABOUT WHEN WE MAY
EVEN BE ABLE TO ANTICIPATE.
GETTING BACK TO. WORK AND-
OPENING BACK UP THE STATE AGAIN
WHILE WE ALSO WANT TRANSPARENCY
REGARDING WHAT THE FUTURE LOOKS
LIKE WE ALSO NEED TO KNOW I GET
A BETTER SENSE OF. WHAT HAS
BEEN SPENT AND WHERE THE
RESOURCES HAVE BEEN DEPLOYED-
SENSE ALL EIGHTY OF US HAVE
BEEN HOME IN OUR DISTRICTS
WORKING IN VERY CLOSE CONTACT
WITH OUR CITIES ARE COUNTIES
OUR OUR HOSPITALS ARE HEALTH
CARE PROFESSIONALS. WE ARE
CONSTANTLY HEARING AND BEING
ASKED ABOUT- WHERE THE PP IS-
HOW HOSPITALS GOT CHOSEN TO
OPEN. WHERE RESOURCES ARE BEING
DEPLOYED. HOW DECISIONS ARE
BEING MADE IN TERMS OF WHO'S
MAKING DECISIONS AROUND THE
HOTELS AND MOTELS FOR OUR
HOMELESS POPULATION- INCENSE.
INFORMATION HASN'T ALWAYS
READILY- BEEN FLOWING BETWEEN
THE ADMINISTRATION'S
LEGISLATURE TODAY WE'RE TRYING
TO REALLY GET A BETTER
UNDERSTANDING OF WHAT-
INFORMATION AVAILABLE.
INFORMATION WE CAN CONTINUE TO
SHARE WITH OUR CONSTITUENTS
WILL BE CAN SHARE WE ALL ARE
VERY SLOW. GOVERNMENT OUR
PARTNER AND THE HEALTH CARE AND
WE WERE TO BE ABLE TO. GET THAT
RISK TO THE IN BILL TIME SO
WERE ASKING- WHAT WHAT IS
AVAILABLE IN TERMS OF
INFORMATION AS WELL AS WHAT CAN
BE- SHARED AND HOPEFULLY WE CAN
THE SYSTEM. COMPRISED THAT
INFORMATION SO THAT THAT PUBLIC
CAN REALLY SEE IT IN IN REAL
TIME SO AGAIN MUCH EASIER IF WE
CAN JUST DIRECT PEOPLE TO A
WEBSITE THAT'S BEING UPDATED
REGULARLY RATHER THAN. GETTING
ON PHONE CALLS AND GETTING
INFORMATION THAN HAVE TO
DISTRIBUTE THAT INDIVIDUALLY-
IN IN A MUCH LESS EFFICIENT
WAY. SO AGAIN VERY- VERY
THANKFUL THAT WE HAVE NUMBER OF
PANELISTS FROM THE
ADMINISTRATION TODAY I WILL BE
GETTING THEM TO A SECOND I JUST
WANTED TO FIRST TURN OVER TO AB
OTHERS MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
TO SEE IF ANY OPENING COMMENTS-
MISERABLE. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN AT AN HONOR TO BE BACK
WITH YOU AND AN HONOR TO SEE
EVERYONE IN PERSON AGAIN. THE
pPOIGNANT. NOT JUST FOR US BOARD
FOR ALL CALIFORNIANS. AND I
THINK WE'RE ALL AWARE THE
DEGREE TO WHICH CALIFORNIANS
ARE HURTING WE HAVE PEOPLE THAT
ARE OUT OF WORK WHERE PEOPLE
HAVE PEOPLE WHO ARE STRUGGLING
TO PAY THE RENT. PEOPLE WHO ARE
ILL PEOPLE WHO ARE DYING- IT'S
HUMBLING THOUGH TO THINK THAT
THE DECISIONS THAT WE MAKE HERE
IN THIS ROOM. AFFECTS THE
ABILITY OF THE STATE TO RESPOND
TO THAT CRISIS AND OUR ABILITY
TO HELP PEOPLE WHETHER IT AND
GET THROUGH IT. SO AS THE CHAIR
SAID THE PURPOSE OF THIS
HEARING IS TO CONDUCT OVERSIGHT
OVER THE BILLIONS OF DOLLARS
THAT THE STATE IS SPENDING IN
RESPONSE TO THIS CRISIS. IN THE
COURSE OF THIS HEARING. WE'RE
GOING TO ASK SOME POINTED
QUESTIONS WE'RE GONNA ASK SOME
DIFFICULT QUESTIONS WE'RE GONNA
HAVE SOME UNCOMFORTABLE
QUESTIONS BUT I WANT TO MAKE IT
VERY CLEAR. THAT OUR INTENT
HERE IS TO MAKE SURE THAT THIS
MONEY IS WISELY APPROPRIATELY
SPENT. WE ARE STILL ALL ON THE
SAME TEAM HERE. WE ALL HAVE THE
SAME GOAL WHICH IS TO PARTNER
WITH THE GOVERNOR AND OUR
COLLEAGUES IN THE SENATE TO
MAKE SURE THAT THIS MONEY GETS
TO WHERE IT NEEDS TO GO ON THAT
CALIFORNIA GETS THROUGH THIS.
AS QUICKLY AND AS PAINLESSLY AS
WE OSSIBLY CAN SO- MISTER
CHAIR IT'S AN HONOR TO BE
WORKING WITH YOU TODAY AND I
YOU BACK. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR FOR CALLING THESE
HEARINGS ON THE SUBJECTS AT.
THIS IMPORTANT TIME. I LOOK
FORWARD TO THIS HEARING ON THE
DETAILS ABOUT THE MODELING. ON
WHICH THE GOVERNOR'S ROAD MAP
FOR MODIFYING AND ARE STAY AT.
HOME ORDER IS BASED. IT IS ALSO
IMPORTANT FOR US TO UNDERSTAND
THE RATIONALE FOR. THE DETAILS
OF. AND THE REPORTING BACK
EXPECTATIONS. FOR THE EMERGENCY
EXPENDITURES THAT HAVE BEEN
PROVIDED TODAY. WHILE I
APPRECIATEWHAT WE ARE FOCUSING
ON TOGETHER IN THE PUBLIC EYE.
RIGHT NOW I'M ALSO LOOKING
FORWARD TO WHAT WE WILL DISCUSS
ON APRIL TWENTY SEVENTH
REGARDING RECOVERY MISTER CHAIR.
I'D LIKE TO TAKE THIS
OPPORTUNITY IF I MAY TO BRIEFLY
OUTLINE THE TOP ISSUES THAT ARE
ON MY MIND AS WE MOVE FORWARD.
THE CRISIS AND OUR RESPONSE IS
A MARATHON AND NOT A SPRINT AND
I'M MINDFUL AS THE CHAIR OF THE
SUBCOMMITTEE THAT DEALS WITH
HEALTH AND HUMAN SERVICES. OF
THE LONG TERM PRESSURES IMPACTS
DEMANDS AND PROTECTIONS THAT WE
NEED TO KEEP IN MIND OF FOR THE
HEALTH ACCESS AND SOCIAL SAFETY
NET. I'VE BEEN VOCAL MY SUPPORT
FOR THE GOVERNOR FOR THE
DISASTER RELIEF AND EMERGENCY
ASSISTANCE FOR THE UNDOCUMENTED
COMMUNITY. WHILE THE FEDERAL
RESPONSE DOESN'T RECOGNIZE THE
SUPPORT THAT THIS WORKING
COMMUNITY NEEDS. DURING THIS
UNEMPLOYMENT CRISIS AND
PANDEMIC CALIFORNIA HAS SHOWN
LEADERSHIP ON THIS BASE. MORE
NEEDS TO BE DONE FOR SURE AND
THIS POPULATION WHICH WILL
REQUIRE OUR SUPPORT SO THAT
THEY CAN WEATHER THIS
DEVASTATING TIME. EMERGENCY
FOOD SUPPORT IS ANOTHER ISSUE
OF GRAVE CONCERN. DEMANDS ON
OUR FOOD BANKS ARE ESCALATING
WITH EVERY PASSING DAY
PRIORITIZING EMERGENCY FOOD
SUPPORTS AND CAL FRESH NEEDS
NEED TO BE AT THE HEART OF OUR
HEALTH AND SAFETY RESPONSE.
SENIORS AND PEOPLE WITH
DISABILITIES ARE BY
DEFINITIONS. AT RISK IN THIS
PANDEMIC AND MARSHALL
MARSHALLING RESOURCES FOR THEM.
AND THE PROGRAMS ON WHICH THEY
RELY IS AN ABSOLUTE MUST RIGHT
NOW. THIS INCLUDES OF COURSE
OUR IN HOME SUPPORTIVE SERVICES
AND ADULT PROTECTIVE SERVICES.
SECONDLY WHILE ONLY EVER
SUGGESTS THAT CALIFORNIA MAY
ESCAPE THE EMERGENCY ROOM
CRISES THAT WE ARE SEEING IN
NEW YORK ITALY AND ELSEWHERE.
THE EPICENTER OF CALIFORNIA'S
CRISES SEEMS TO BE UNFOLDING
WITHIN OUR NURSING HOMES. THE
LIVES OF OUR MOST VULNERABLE
RESIDENTS HAVE BEEN LEFT IN THE
HANDS OF A WORK FORCE THAT IS
INSUFFICIENT AT SIZE IN SIZE
EVEN IN THE BEST OF TIMES.
BEYOND TO NURSING HOMES ARE
HEALTH CARE WORK FORCE OVERALL
WAS RECOGNIZED TO BE WOEFULLY
INADEQUATE PRIOR TO THIS
PANDEMIC. NOW WE ARE WATCHING
THAT THIS WORK FORCE IN KING
COMPONENTS OF OUR HEALTH CARE
SYSTEM SLIP AWAY AS THE WORLD
STAYS HOME. FOR GOING EVEN NON
EMERGENCY MEDICAL CARE. WE ARE
SEEING MASSIVE FURLOUGHS
LAYOFFS AND OORS CLOSING AND
COMMUNITY CLINICS HOSPITALS
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH CARE SETTINGS
DENTAL CARE AND MORE. WE WILL
NEED THIS WORKFORCE NOW MORE
THAN EVER ONCE WE ENTER THE
RECOVERY AND REBUILDING PHASES.
AMONG OTHER STRATEGIES
TELEHEALTH IS NOT A TEMPORARY
SOLUTION IT IS OUR NEW NORMAL
AND THEREFORE IT MUST BE
SUPPORTED AND EXPANDED WELL
BEYOND THIS PANDEMIC. FINALLY
NONE OF US CAN IGNORE THE
SECONDARY CRISIS THAT IS
UNFOLDING BEFORE OUR EYES IN
THE FORM OF INCREASES IN ALL
FORMS OF FAMILY VIOLENCE AND IN
BOTH FAMILY BASED AND COMMUNITY
TRAUMA. UNEMPLOYMENT COMBINED
WITH ISOLATION AND GRIEF IS A
PERFECT RECIPE FOR NEW
EPIDEMICS OF MENTAL ILLNESS
SUICIDALITY SUBSTANCE ABUSE AND
ADDICTION. ARGUABLY CALIFORNIA
WAS NOT MEETING ITS NEEDS IN
THIS AREA BEFORE THE PANDEMIC
AND NOW WE ARE AN UNPRECEDENTED
CRISIS HEADED OUR WAY. MY WORK
WHICH IS WITHIN SOMEONE CALLS
ON BOTH A HUMAN AND A HUMANE
INSTINCT IN EVERY SENSE TO SHOW
COMPASSION TO VULNERABLE
COMMUNITIES AND TO FIGHT FOR
THE RESOURCES THEY NEED TO
SURVIVE. I PLAN TO PLAY THIS
ROLE FULLY AS WE GO THROUGH
THIS CRISIS AND EVENTUALLY COME
OUT OF IT THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR FOR ALLOWING ME TO
PROVIDE TIME FOR THIS THANK YOU
DOCTOR ABOUT. EIGHT MISTER.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR I
APPRECIATE THE OPPORTUNITY TO
BE HERE AND FILL IN FOR MY
ESTEEMED COLLEAGUE DR WEBER I
THINK TWO VERY IMPORTANT THINGS
TO NOTE AS WE GO THROUGH THIS
PROCESS TODAY IS THAT WE WANT
TO ENSURE THE CALIFORNIANS ARE
REASSURED THAT THE DECISIONS
THAT ARE BEING MADE IN
SACRAMENTO AND OUR SUPPORT FOR
THE WORK OF THE GOVERNOR AND
HIS TEAM CONTINUED BE BASED ON
THE HIGHEST ORDER SCIENTIFIC
EVIDENCE THE BASS MODELING AND
ENSURING THAT WE HAVE THE
HIGHEST AND BEST USE OF THE
STATE'S RESOURCES. IN DEPLOYING
ADDITIONAL INFRASTRUCTURE TO
GET US THROUGH THIS CRISIS-
SECONDARILY BECAUSE THIS IS
BEING LIVE STREAMED- TO THE
ENTIRE STATE I THINK IT'S VERY
IMPORTANT TO NOTE THAT A NUMBER
OF MEMBERS PRESENT ON THE PANEL
TODAY COME FROM COUNTIES WHERE
FACE COVERINGS ARE RECOMMENDED
AND SO YOU SEE THAT REFLECTED
IN THE PANEL HERE HERE IN
SACRAMENTO COUNTY THEY ARE NOT
RECOMMENDED AT PRESENT BUT
THAT'S WHY YOU SEE A DIFFERENCE
BETWEEN SOME MEMBERS ARE
WEARING FACE COVERINGS AND SOME
MEMBERS NOT TO THINK IT'S
IMPORTANT FOR THE PUBLIC TO
UNDERSTAND THAT. THANK YOU
MISTER. MISTER BROOKS THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIRMAN THE FIRST I'D
LIKE TO SAY HAPPY SIXTEENTH
BIRTHDAY TO MY SON CONNOR WILL
BE WITH THEM- LATER ON AFTER
AFTER WE CONCLUDE THE HEARING I
ALSO WANT TO A PAST MY
CONDOLENCES ON OF THOSE
CALIFORNIA'S AFFECTED BY THIS
VIRUS. I WANT TO THANK THE
FRONTLINE WORKERS THE DOCTORS
THE NURSES THE MEDICAL
PROFESSIONALS. WHO ARE DOING
THE LORD'S WORK AND PROTECTING
OUR STATE I ALSO WANT TO. SPEND
TIME TALKING ABOUT SMALL
BUSINESSES OF MY DISTRICT ARE
HIT VERY VERY HARD THESE HOURLY
WORKERS THE BARTENDERS THE
WAITRESSES WHO ARE FILING FOR
UNEMPLOYMENT IT'S BEEN THE
NUMBER ONE CALL IN OUR IN OUR
DISTRICT OFFICE- SOME OF THESE
BUSINESSES MAY NOT REOPEN- THE
NEXT COUPLE HEARINGS I WANT TO
FIND OUT WE GET. TESTING DONE
MORE QUICKLY- SPECIFICALLY THE
IMMUNITY TESTING THERE'S THE
STANFORD STUDY THAT CAME OUT
THIS WEEK SAYING TAT THIS MAY
HAVE GONE THROUGH- MANY PEOPLE
IN THE WINTER AND THEREFORE
THEY MAY BE A MEDIA. I ALSO
WANT TO TALK ABOUT. LOCAL
CONTROL BECAUSE NOT ALL AREAS
OF THE SAME IN MY COUNTY OF
ORANGE. NOW WE'VE GOT FOURTEEN
HUNDRED TWENTY FIVE CASES OUT
OF THREE POINT THREE MILLION
PEOPLE YOU KNOW DO WE NEED TO
LOCK DOWN. TO THE EXTENT THAT
WE ARE NOW. AND IF WE IF WE DO
OPEN HOW DO WE- NAVIGATE OUR
NEIGHBORING COUNTY LOS ANGELES
THAT'S THAT'S BEEN MORE
IMPACTED LIKE TO HEAR SOME.
SOME ANSWERS TO THAT YOU KNOW
QUARANTINE IS SUPPOSED TO BE
FOR SICK. NOT HEALTHY. THE P.
PLEASE I MEAN THERE'S A STORY
OUT IN TWO THOUSAND ELEVEN THAT
WE ABANDON OUR STOCKPILE AS
OTHER STATES IN THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT DID. LIKE TO GET
QUESTIONS TO WHY THAT HAPPENED-
THESE CALLS WE'VE BEEN ON
SINCE. MARCH HAVE GIVEN US THE
THIRTY THOUSAND FOOT VIEW OF
NUMBERS AND STATS AND- I DON'T
WANNA GET DEEPER INTO WHERE
THESE MASTER GOING IN. AND
ISSUES LIKE THAT. THE CONTRACT
WITH THE MASKS IS SOMETHING I'D
LIKE TO DISCUSS. I KNOW FOR A
FACT THAT THEIR SALE COMPANIES
LEOTARD COMPANIES LOCAL
ALTERATIONS IN MY DISTRICT.
THAT ARE MAKING MASS RIGHT NOW
IN THESE DAYS THIS IS COULD
HAVE USED TO BOOST- MAYBE WE
SHOULD DIVERSIFIED INTO A
COUPLE OF DIFFERENT COMPANIES-
NOT JUST ONE CONTRACT I'D LIKE
TO HEAR SOME ANSWERS TO THAT-
BUT AGAIN. PROUD TO BE PART OF
THIS MISTER CHAIRMAN AND I LOOK
FORWARD TO HEARING FROM OUR
PANELISTS. THANK YOU MISTER
BROWN. ANY FROM THE COMMITTEE.
POUGHKEEPSIE SEEING NONE WE ARE
GOING TO GO TO OUR FIRST PANEL
TO DISCUSS CALIFORNIA'S CODED
NINETEEN INFECTION
HOSPITALIZATION AND MORTALITY
PROJECTIONS I BELIEVE WE HAVE
MISTER GULAR DO CHIEF FROM- YES
AS WELL AS MISTER- MY CHECK
FROM- HEALTH AND HUMAN SERVICES
AGENCY. AVAILABLE REMOTELY.
GOOD AFTERNOON OR GOOD MORNING
MISTER CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE FALL DIRECTOR
COLOR DO CHEN AYE ARE HERE AT
THE STATE OPERATIONS CENTER
JOINING YOU FOR THIS HEARING- I
WILL START BY- GIVING YOU AN
OVERVIEW OF OUR MODELING WORK
TODAY- AND THEN WE CAN- JUMPING
TO YOUR QUESTIONS. WE DO HAVE A
SHORT POWER POINT PRESENTATION-
THAT WE ARE READY TO PUT UP ON
THE SCREEN SO I'LL JUST GIVE
THAT  SECOND AND THEN I'LL
BEGIN MY REMARKS. AND THANK YOU
FOR. TAKING THE TIME AND WE
ARE. GRATEFUL TO YOU FOR GIVING
US THIS OPPORTUNITY TO BE PART
OF THIS HEARING TODAY. I BEFORE
I WALK YOU THROUGH. OUR
MODELING EFFORTS I WANT TO
PRACTICE AND MIGHT REMARKS WITH
THREE DISTINCT. PIECES OF
INFORMATION THAT I THINK WILL
PROVIDE YOU WITH A LITTLE BIT
OF CONTEXT AS TO HOW WE ARE
USING. OF MODELING AND DATA TO
INFORM OUR DECISION MAKING HERE
AT THE STATE OPERATIONS CENTER.
FIRST I THINK IT'S REALLY
IMPORTANT AND UNDER I
UNDERSTAND THAT ALL MODELS
INCLUDING THE MODEL THAT WE ARE
USING. HAVE A HIGH. HIGH SENSE
OF UNCERTAINTY. AND PART OF
THAT IS BECAUSE THE SIGNS THE
EVIDENCE BASE. FOR THE BASIC
ASSUMPTIONS THAT WE'RE USING IN
THESE MODELS. IS NOT ONLY THE
FACT THAT THE EVIDENCE BASE AND
THE SCIENCE IS BEING BUILT
EVERYTHING HEY. SO IT'S
IMPORTANT UNDERSTAND THAT THERE
IS A LOT OF UNCERTAINTY THIS
BOTTLE AND ALL MODELS BECAUSE
OF THE BASIC ASSUMPTIONS. BEING
MADE AT. THIS POINT THAT I. IS
THAT. THERE ARE BOTH OF BOTTLES.
AVAILABLE AND THERE IS A OF NO
WITH REGARDS THE MILE. AND I
THINK MODELING. HELP SAID LOOK
AT RATIONALITY BUT I THINK DOES
NOT GIVE A- CERTAIN FACTS OF
WHAT. HAPPENED ON THE GROUND
AND SO IT'S- IMPORTANT AS YOU
LOOK AT BOTH THE BOTTLE AND ALL
AUTO CENTER. PRESENT ACROSS
STATE THAT YOU'RE LOOKING AT
OUT. OPENLY IN THE SENSE THAT
IT REALLY DOESN'T. ALL OF OUR
BUT IT HELP UNDER THE JACK
CORRECT NOT. THE THIRD POINT
THAT I MAKE IT. DATA IS MOST
AND- DATA IN THIS CAR. OR WE
AGO WHEN WE- WITHIN THE OPERATE
OR AT LEAST A TERMS OF. AROUND
THE- WE DID NOT HAVE AN DAY. WE
ONLY HAVE SOME PRETTY OF WERE
WORKING ON THAT DATE WE HAVE
ACT DATA AND NOT AND- THE
ACTUAL DATA IS ON. IMPORTANT IN
HELPING US UNDERSTAND THE
DIFFERENCES THAT ARE HAPPENING
WITH IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
AND ACROSS THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA SO THE ACTUAL DATA
IS ACTUALLY WHAT'S GUIDING OUR
WORK NOT THE MODELING WORK AND
I THINK THAT IS A REALLY
IMPORTANT THING HEY. I'LL CLOSE
ON THIS SLIDE BY SAYING THAT
DIRECTOR GO WOULD YOU CHIEF AND
SENATE WE PLAN FOR THE WORST
SCENARIO BUT WE ARE HARDEST TO
COME UP THE BEST CASE SCENARIO
AND THAT'S REALLY THE EFFORTS.
WE'VE GOT DONE AT THE STATE
OPERATIONS CENTER AND I THINK
THAT'S THE CRIME BEYOND
MODELING. SO THEY REALLY ARE
LOOKING AT SOME OF THE WORST
CASE SCENARIOS BUT WE WORK.
REALLY RESCUE. SO WE CAN GO.
WHAT YOU WILL SEE IS A SCENARIO
WITHOUT IN ANY INTERVENTION.
THIS IS IF WE IF THE GOVERNOR
HAD NOT PUT A STAY AT HOME
ORDER IN PLACE AND WE NOT DONE
PHYSICAL DISTANCING THE
HORIZONTAL LINE THAT YOU SEE
ABOVE THE X. AXIS IS OUR SEARCH
CAPACITY AND SEARCH CAPACITY
WHETHER AN OVERWHELMING TO VERY
VERY QUICKLY HAD WE NOT PUT THE
STATE HOME ORDER IN FACT WE
WOULD HAVE PRINT. MODEL PRINT
CLOSE TO HUNDRED HOSPITALS. AS
A RESULT OF THE VIRUS AND NO
INTERVENTIONS BEING PUT IN
PLACE THESE INTERVENTIONS ARE
OFTEN CALLED NON PHARMACEUTICAL
INTERVENTIONS ARE EMPTY EYES
AND THEY INCLUDE THINGS SUCH
AS- CLOSING DOWN MASS
GATHERINGS I AM PUTTING IN THE
STATE OR MORE. AND IMPLEMENTING
PHYSICAL THIS. SO IT JUST SENSE
OF THE MAC HAD WE DONE ANY.
NEXT SLIDE PLEASE. THERE WE ARE
I LOOK AT THE SONORA. WITH THE
IN THAT WE PUT IN PLACE AND
WHAT YOU WILL SEE HERE IS A
BLUE LINE THAT IS THE MEDIAN.
THE SCENARIOS THAT ARE RAN IN
THE BOTTLE AND THAT THE CODE
THAT YOU SEE HERE. IS FROM THE
TWENTY FIFTH PERCENTILE TO THE
SEVEN FIFTH PERCENTILE THE RED
DOTS THAT YOU SEE HERE- OR THE
RED LINE AT THE BOTTOM IS OUR
ACTUAL HOSPITALIZATIONS AND
WHAT I WANT FOLKS TO TAKE AWAY
FROM THE SCREEN IS THAT OUR
INTERVENTIONS ARE WORKING
EXTREMELY WELL. AND WHAT WE
NEED TO YOU CAN THIS ARE WE TO
THANK THE GENERAL. REALLY I BY
GOVERNOR STATE OR- BECAUSE THE
IMPACT IS EVIDENT IN THE DAY
THAT WE'RE- SO MOST OF THE
SPRAY IF. THE ACTUAL IS THE
RIGHT DOT OR THE RED LINE THAT
YOU SEE ON THIS PARTICULAR
GRAPH. NEXT SLIDE PLEASE. HERE
WHAT WE'VE MODEL IS IF WE WERE
TO LIFT THE INTERVENTIONS AND
GO BACK TO NORMAL WHAT WE WOULD
SEE IN TERMS OF THE SPY SO THE
INITIAL DOTTED LINE WHICH IS
LIGHTLY GREAT IS WHAT WE WOULD
HAVE SEEN HAD WE NOT DONE
ANYTHING THAT I HAD THE BLUE
AYE SOLID LINE IS THE MEDIAN
WITH REGARDS TO THE MODEL THE
RED LINE IS THE ACTUAL
HOSPITALIZATIONS. IF I WERE TO
LEFT THAT THAT IN NON
PHARMACEUTICAL ENGINES YOU
WOULD SEE A SPIKE SO WHEN YOU
LOOK AT OTHER COUNTRIES LIKE
SOUTH KOREA INJURED AND THEY
LIFTED THEIR EMPTY EYES AND NOW
WE'RE HAVING TO PUT THEM BACK
IN PLACE. EIGHTEEN EIGHTEEN FLU
PANDEMIC GIVE US SOME GOOD
INSIGHTS INTO TERMS OF HOW TO
PREPARE FOR LIFTING EMPTY EYES
AND IN FACT A NUMBER OF CITIES
IN THE UNITED STATES LIFTED
THEIR EMPTY ICE TOO QUICKLY AND
SAW SIGNIFICANT BY EARLY THIS
WEEK THE GOVERNOR LAID OUT SIX
DIFFERENT INDICATORS THAT WE
WILL BE USING TO GUIDE OUR
DECISION MAKING AROUND HOW WE
LEFT OR MODIFIED. GUYS MOVING
FORWARD THAT VOID THE
SIGNIFICANT SPIKE OUT WITHIN
OUR CASES IN CALIFORNIA. NEXT
LINE I WANT TO CLOSE MY
PRESENTATION AND LOOK FORWARD
TO ENGAGING WITH YOU IN IN A IN
A CONVERSATION BUT I WANT TO
SAY THANK YOU FIRST AND
FOREMOST FOR HEALTHCARE
PROVIDERS AND HOSPITALS WHO
REALLY HAVE DONE A TREMENDOUS
AMOUNT OF WORK OVER THE LAST
COUPLE OF WEEKS. AND PUTTING
THE EMPTY EYES ARE. SOME PLACE
WAS TO PREPARE OUR HEALTHCARE
DELIVERY SYSTEM SO THAT IT HAD
THE ABILITY TO TAKE CARE OF
PEOPLE AND SAVE LIVES. FIRST
AND FOREMOST I ALSO WANT TO SAY
THANK YOU TO THE GENERAL PUBLIC
BECAUSE THEY HAVE BEEN A BITING
BUYERS IN ORDER AND IT'S REALLY
IMPORTANT FOR US. TO CONTINUE
TO DO THAT IN ORDER FOR US TO
BE ABLE TO SAVE AS MANY LIVES
AS POSSIBLE MISTER CHAIR I WAS.
THERE AND WOULD LOVE TO IN ANY
QUESTIONS THAT YOU MAY. THEY
THEY I'D LIKE TO DO IS WE COULD
JUST GO TO. ALL THE PANELISTS
NAY WILL TAKE QUESTIONS FOR ALL
OF THEM WHEN WE- FINISH OF
THAT'S OKAY. SO BUT WOULD LIKE
TO GO TO THE NEXT PANEL. ALL
WHICH IS THE OVERVIEW OF TOTAL
AND HEARD IN ANTICIPATED KOBE
DISASTER- IN PUBLIC HEALTH
RESPONSE STATE EXPENDITURES IN
FEDERAL REIMBURSEMENTS. SO
FIRST WE'RE GOING TO HAVE-
MISTER VETO ANYTHINGFROM THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR. HI MY NAME IS
THE LATEST ONE OFTEN AND I'M
JUST HAPPY DIRECTOR AT THAT FOR
BUDGET AT THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE AND I HAVE SEVERAL MY
COLLEAGUES WERE LEADERS HERE AT
THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE ON
THE LINE AS WELL TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS I'LL KEEP OPENING
REMARKS. NOW WE KNOW THAT WE
ARE IN AN UNPRECEDENTED
SITUATION BOTH IN TERMS OF
PUBLIC HEALTH AND ALSO THE
ECONOMIC SITUATION. THAT WE'RE
FACING IN ADDITION WE ARE
ADDRESSING THESE ISSUES IN THE
CONTEXT OF WORKING TOWARD THE
GOVERNOR'S. NAME REVISION
BUDGET PROPOSAL- WHICH WILL BE
SUBMITTED TO THE LEGISLATURE
JUST A COUPLE WEEKS FROM NOW.
FIND EIGHT FOURTEEN STATUTORY
DEADLINE SO PEOPLE MORE TO SAY
ABOUT THAT IN THE WEEKS TO
COME. BUT I THOUGHT I WOULD
MAKE THREE POINTS RIGHT NOW
WITH REGARD TO THE SUBJECT OF
THIS HEARING. IS THAT
MINISTRATION VERY MUCH
APPRECIATES THE ESTEY EIGHTY
NINE APPLICATION THAT THE
LEGISLATURE MADE A MONTH AGO
AND WE UNDERSTAND THAT THE
LEGISLATURE GAVE A GREATER
DEGREE. WHAT DO YOU TRUST
MINISTRATION. THAN MIGHT BE
DIFFICULT FOR THE STORE OF
BILLS GIVEN THE- SO WE ARE. TO
PROVIDE AS MUCH INFORMATION
ACTUALLY. REGARDING HOW THOSE
MY COLLEAGUES AS MY HEALTH.
THREE QUESTIONS TODAY. AND WE
CAN'T. MAKE TAX YOU AFTER THE
HEARING IS IN THIS CALL. THIS
POINT IN TO MAKE THAT THERE.
CONSIDERABLE I ASKED MR MAKE
FROM A- MENTIONED WE ARE DOING
PROJECT IN MY- WITH REGARD HOW
WE EXPECT THIS PANDEMIC TO GO.
BUT THE TRUTH IS NOBODY REALLY
KNOWS FOR SURE OUR BEST
ESTIMATE RIGHT NOW IS THAT KOBE
RELATED EXPENDITURES TO
DIRECTLY RESPOND. TO THIS
EMERGENCY WILL TOTAL
APPROXIMATELY SEVEN BILLION
DOLLARS FOR THIS YEAR AND WE
EXPECT THE MAJORITY OF THAT TO
BE REIMBURSED BY FEMA. FEDERAL.
THAT IS. FAST AND WHILE WE TALK
ABOUT SOME OF THE- A CATEGORY
WHERE WE- THAT FUNDING BE. ARE
WE WILL HAVE MUCH MORE TO SAY
ABOUT OUR UPDATED ESTIMATES IN
TERMS OF OUR SPENDING AND WE
ARE PROPOSED ALLOCATED IN THE
WEEKS AND MONTHS TO COME. AND
THEN THE FINAL POINT THAT I DO
WANT TO MAKE A CASE IS THAT
SEVERAL SUPPORT IS. ABSOLUTELY
KEY OVER HERE CARE ACT INCLUDED
ONE HUNDRED FIFTY BILLION
DOLLARS IN STATE AND LOCAL
EIGHT. WHICH APPROXIMATELY.
FIFTEEN MILLION DOLLARS IS
GOING TO CALIFORNIA'S SPLIT
BETWEEN STATE AND CERTAIN LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS AND THAT'S
CERTAINLY A GOOD START BUT IT'S
NOT A NOT SEEN EVEN MUCH
GREATER LEVELS SEVERAL. WELL IN
A- TWICE THAT LATER IN THE
MINISTRY WILL HAVE. MAKING SO
WE ARE TO WORK WITH OUR FEDERAL
PARTNERS TO TRY TO GET AS MUCH
FEDERAL AID FOR BOTH THE STATE
GOVERNMENT IS FALSE LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS. ALL AND WE HOPE TO
WORK WITH YOU ON THAT SUBJECT
AS WELL AND WITH THAT I'LL TURN
IT OVER TO MY COLLEAGUE TREES A
CALVERT. BUT SOME ADDITIONAL
DETAIL IN TERMS OF THE
EXPENDITURES MAKES DAY. THE
MORNING TO RESET COLOR A
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE- ALL
QUICKLY NOTE THAT OVERALL
ALLOCATIONS THAT STARTED IN
MARCH THE AGENDA PROVIDES
DETAILS ON THESE ON PAGE THREE
AND WE ALSO WE ARE VERY IS
REPRESENTATIVES FROM FINANCE
AVAILABLE TO ADDRESS QUESTIONS
ON THESE ALLEGATIONS- FIRST SB.
ONE SEVENTEEN THE SITE ON MARCH
SEVENTEENTH AND PROVIDED A
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS FOR
LOCAL EDUCATIONAL AGENCIES FOR
PERSONAL PROTECTIVE EQUIPMENT
CLEANING AND SANITIZING
NUTRITION SERVICES AND DISTANCE
LEARNING. I'M SB EIGHTY NINE
WHICH INCLUDES SECTION THIRTY
SIX WHICH PROVIDES UP TO ONE
MILLION DOLLARS IN GENERAL FUND
APPROPRIATIONS RELATED TO THE
KOBE NINETEEN EMERGENCY. ON
THIS FARM SB EIGHTY NINE ON
ALLEGATIONS OF TOTAL SEVEN
HUNDRED AND SIXTY EIGHT POINT
NINE MILLION. AND YOUR
PREPARATION IS SUBJECT TO
SPECIFIED LEGISLATIVE
NOTIFICATION REQUIREMENTS AND
WE HAVE BEEN SENDING THOSE. I
AM ALSO ON MARCH TWENTY FIFTH
THE ADMINISTRATION PROVIDED
NOTICE ABOUT ONE POINT THREE
BILLION DOLLAR TRANSFER I'M TO
THE DISASTER RESPONSE EMERGENCY
OPTIONS ACCOUNTS. AND AS HAS
BEEN NOTED PREVIOUSLY I AM
CALIFORNIA HAS SECURED A
RESIDENTIAL MAJOR DISASTER
DECLARATION WHICH MAKES FEDERAL
FUNDING AVAILABLE AND- OR- TO
THE STATE AND REIMBURSEMENT OF
MANY OF THE STATE COSTS IN YOUR
THAT FEDERAL EMERGENCY
MANAGEMENT AGENCY IS EXPECTED.
AND WITH THAT I WILL TURN IT
OVER TO THE NEXT PANEL. THANK
YOU ARE WE'RE GONNA HEAR FROM
MISS. CURRY WITH OUR WE US
RUNNING OF MISTER GIVE A DUTY
WAS SPEAKING ON HER BEHALF.
OKAY GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIR
AND MEMBERS COMMITTEE MARK RTG
DIRECTOR OF THAT. OFFICE
MURDERS YOU SERVICE IS GOING TO
BE WITH OU THIS MORNING. LET
ME START BY SAYING- THAT THE
STATE OPERATIONS CENTER HAS
BEEN ACTIVATED. SINCE EARLY
MARCH AT THE HIGHEST LEVEL THE
SUPPORT STATEWIDE PANDEMIC
RESPONSE. ARE ACTUALLY- WE'VE
ACTUALLY BEEN COLLECTIVELY BEEN
ENGAGE WITH THIS- RESPONDED SO
THAT ACTUALLY SINCE ABOUT MID
JANUARY WHEN THE FIRST.
REPATRIATIONFLIGHTS CAME IN
THE CALIFORNIA ROUGHLY ABOUT
THREE MONTHS. ALL WE ASK AND
THE HEALTH OF HUMANS AGENCIES
ARE WORKING- IN A UNIFIED
EFFORT RESPOND TO THIS EVENT.
WE HAVE OVER THREE HUNDRED
PERSONNEL THAT ARE ACTIVATED AT
THE STATE OPERATIONS CENTER
EITHER REMOTELY OR IN PERSON.
YOU'RE OUT MULTIPLE FACILITIES
TO ENSURE APPROPRIATE SOCIAL-DISTANCING AND SAFETY. MULTIPLE
TEAMS ARE ON THE GROUND IN THE
FIELD PROVIDING MEDICAL CARE
STAFF TO FOOD BANKS BUILDING
FEEL HOSPITALS AND OTHER
SUPPORT NEEDS TO OUR
COMMUNITIES ARE HEALTHCARE
SYSTEM. GIVEN THE IMMENSE SCOPE
AND SCALE AND COMPLEXITY IS A
BAD THIS IS BETTER ALL HANDS ON
DECK ALBERT INVOLVING ALL
LEADERSHIP. AT EVERY AGENCY IN
STATE GOVERNMENT TO SUPPORT
LOCAL GOVERNMENT COMMUNITIES.
AND THE PUBLIC. WE HAVE
MULTIPLE TASK FORCES IN PLACE
WORKING TIRELESSLY TO ADDRESS
ISSUES SUCH AS HOSPITAL AND
MEDICAL BRIDGE. HOUSING IS THAT.
I'M ALREADY MOVE. BY. OUR
SCHOOL. AS WELL ARE FEDERAL BAR
IF. HELP THAT HE SERVICE. AND
THE US ARMY CORPS OF ENGINEERS
AND DEPARTMENT OF FATS ARE
FULLY ENGAGED STATE OPERATIONS
CENTER OR IN THE FIELD
SUPPORTING CALIFORNIA'S NEEDS.
CALIFORNIA HAS AND WILL
CONTINUE TO FOCUS ON PROTECTING
OF PROVIDING FOR HEALTH AND
MEDICAL SERVICES AND PUBLIC
SAFETY PROTECTING THOSE MOST
VULNERABLE THE IMPACTS OF
COVERT NINETEEN AND PROVIDING
ECONOMIC AND OTHER RELIEF YOUR
DRASTIC CASCADING IMPACTS. OF
THIS UNPRECEDENTED EVENT. I
WANT TO CLOSE MY AGAIN THINKING
ALL OF THE CALIFORNIANS AND ALL
OF OUR HEALTHCARE PROVIDERS
WHERE THEY'RE FANTASTIC WORKER
COOPERATION AND THE GREAT
EFFORT THE FLAT OCCUR. AND HELP
SAVE LIVES THIS IS A MARATHON
AND WE'RE GONNA BE KEEPING OUT
THIS UNTIL- WE ARE HOUSE THIS
CHALLENGE AND GETTING BACK TO A
NORMAL STATE. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. I IN OUR LAST POLLICIS IS
MISTER PETTIT ARE LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST. OKAY BUT THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR MISTER VICE CHAIR
AND MEMBERS OR INVITING ME TO
PARTICIPATE HERE TODAY. I JUST
HAVE A COUPLE OF. MINUTES HERE
ABOUT COM COMMENTS. I WOULD SAY
THE LEGISLATURE CLEARLY HAS
RECOGNIZED THAT THE CODED
NINETEEN PANDEMIC IS A PUBLIC
HEALTH EMERGENCY. AND HAS BEEN
ACCOMMODATED TO THE BUDGET
AUGMENTATIONS UNDERTAKEN BY THE
ADMINISTRATION. AND GENERALLY
SPEAKING THE LEGISLATURE'S TECH
KNOWLEDGE THE ADMINISTRATION'S
NEED FOR OPERATIONAL
FLEXIBILITY AND HAS PROVIDED
THE CAPACITY FOR IT TO RESPOND
SWIFTLY TO THE PANDEMIC. BUT
NOW WE'VE MOVED ON FROM THE
INITIAL. PHASE OF THIS EPISODE
AND IN THE COMING WEEKS THE
LEGISLATURE WILL BE TASKED WITH
PASSING A FINAL BUDGET PACKAGE.
THIS WILL BE TAKING PLACE
DESPITE THE CHALLENGING
CIRCUMSTANCES. THEREFORE THIS
PRESENTS AN OPPORTUNITY FOR THE
STATE TO SHIFT ITS ORIENTATION
FROM ONE OF REACTION TO THE
PUBLIC HEALTH CRISIS TO A MORE
PROACTIVE STANCE. IN WHICH
MORTGAGE ACTIVITIES ARE PLANNED
IN ADVANCE AND INCORPORATE MORE
OF A STRATEGIC APPROACH. BUT IN
ORDER FOR THE LEGISLATURE TO
EFFECTIVELY PARTNER WITH THE
ADMINISTRATION. WE BELIEVE THAT
THE LEGISLATURE WILL REQUIRE
MORE DETAILED INFORMATION. IN
BROAD TERMS THE TYPES OF USEFUL
INFORMATION THAT THE THAT THE
LEGISLATURE WOULD BENEFIT FROM
WOULD INCLUDE HOW THE
ADMINISTRATION HAS ALREADY
RESPONDED. WHAT ARE THE
ADMINISTRATION'S PLANS FOR THE
COMING MONTHS PERHAPS UNDER
MORE THAN ONE SCENARIO. WHETHER
IT AND THEN FINALLY WHAT ARE
THE COSTS OF THESE PLANS
HOWEVER THE COST ESTIMATED AND
HOW DOES THE ADMINISTRATION WAS
A- FUNDED. THE DATE A LOT OF
THE THIS KIND OF INFORMATION AT
LEAST IN ANY DETAIL FORM IS NOT
BEEN AVAILABLE TO THE
LEGISLATURE. AND I MENTION ALL
OF THIS JUST AS A REMINDER.
THAT IT IS IMPORTANT TO RECALL
THAT THE LEGISLATURE. HAS A
CONSTITUTIONAL RESPONSIBILITY
OF OVERSIGHT AND AUTHORITY OVER
APPROPRIATIONS. IN THE MAY
REVISION IS THE TRADITIONAL
TIME WHEN THE ADMINISTRATION
WILL PROVIDE UPDATED
INFORMATION ON CASELOADS AND
INCORPORATE THEIR EFFECT ON
WORKLOAD AND THE ADMINISTRATIVE
COSTS. OF PROVIDING WHAT WILL
BE CRUCIAL HUMAN SERVICES AND
HEALTH CARE SERVICES TO
AFFECTED POPULATIONS THIS WILL
BE ESPECIALLY IMPORTANT THIS
YEAR. LIKEWISE IF NOT SOONER
THAN A REVISION WILL BE AN
IDEAL TIME FOR THE LEGISLATURE
TO HOPEFULLY RECEIVE BACK UP
INFORMATION ON THE- SEVEN
BILLION AN ESTIMATED INCREASE
COSTS RELATED TO RESPONDING TO
KOBE NINETEEN. FINALLY I JUST
LIKE TO NOTE THAT THE
LEGISLATURE ACTING THROUGH THE
JOINT LEGISLATIVE BUDGET
COMMITTEE. AS CAN KERR HAS- CAN
CONDUCTED AN EXPEDITED REVIEW
AND CONCURRED WITH THE VARIOUS
BUDGET DOCUMENTATIONS
UNDERTAKEN BY THE
ADMINISTRATION. HOWEVER HOWEVER
IN THE COURSE OF PROVIDING
THOSE REVIEWS THE JAIL BC HAS
SENT TENURE REVIEW LETTERS TO
THE ADMINISTRATION. THESE
LETTERS HAVE MADE CERTAIN
REQUEST OF THE ADMINISTRATION
IN CONJUNCTION WITH THE REVIEW.
SOME OF THE DATA THAT THE THAT
THAT JAIL BC HAS AS INDICATED
WOULD BE HELPFUL IS IN INCLUDES
ADDITIONAL INFORMATION AND
DATA. ON HOW THE FUNDING
AUGMENTATIONS HAVE BEEN PUT TO
USE EXPLANATIONS OF THE VARIOUS
METHODOLOGIES FOR HOW THE
NEEDED FUNDING AUGMENTATIONS
ARRIVED A. AND HOW CERTAIN
FUNDING INCREASES IN PURCHASES
OF THE PP WILL BE ALLOCATED
ACROSS THE STATE AND EVEN
POTENTIALLY OUTSIDE OF THE
STATE. THERE'S ALSO BEEN A
REQUEST FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
VIEW CERTAIN OPERATING
CONTRACTS SUCH AS IN THE CASE
OF THE SAINT VINCENT'S HOSPITAL
IN THE SEATING MEDICAL CENTER.
I THINK IT IS REASONABLE FOR
THE LEGISLATURE TO ANTICIPATE
RECEIVING AN UPDATE ON THE
STATUS OF THESE REQUESTED
SOMETIME IN THE NEAR FUTURE.
ALL RIGHT THIS WILL CONTINUE TO
ASSIST THE LEGISLATURE IN
EVALUATING ANY BUDGET
AUGMENTATIONS. THEY COME
THROUGH AND OF COURSE WE WILL
BE WORKING WITH YOU IN THE
COURSE OF- REVIEWING THE COMING
BUDGET PROCESS. THANK YOU MISS
BENNET. OUT WITH THAT WE SHOULD
THE PANELISTS FOR THEIR- FOR
THEIR CMMENTS WANTED TO TURN
IT BACK TO THE COMMITTEE TO
OPEN UP FOR QUESTIONS. MR
OBERNOLTE. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR OF MY FIRST QUESTIONS FOR
THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. WHEN
WE ADJOURNED SIX WEEKS AGO WE
PRINT PLACED EXTRAORDINARY
TRUST IN THE GOVERNOR WHEN WE
PASSED IS BEING EIGHTY NINE AND
DELEGATED TO HIM- BILLION
DOLLARS OF SPENDING AUTHORITY
TO RESPOND TO THE CORONAVIRUS
CRISIS SO- IN THE ENSUING
WEEKS. THE JOINT LEGISLATIVE
BUDGET COMMITTEE HAS BEEN
EXERCISING OVERSIGHT OVER THAT
SPENDING AUTHORITY IN THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE ISSUES US
LETTERS ASKING FOR OUR
CONCURRENCE IN THE SPENDING
ITEMS THAT THEY PROPOSED
UNDERTAKE. MOST OF THOSE
REQUESTS I HAVE CONCURRED WITH
SOME OF THEM I HAVE NOT AND TO
ASK ABOUT THAT- THE GOVERNOR
HAS SPENT MONEY ON THINGS
DIRECTLY RELATED TO THE CORONA
VIRUS WERE TALKING ABOUT- FIELD
HOSPITALS PER MINUTE PP
VENTILATORS MEDICAL PERSONNEL-
HE SPENT SOME MONEY ON THINGS
THAT WERE PERSONALLY RELATED
LIKE OF HOMELESSNESS- THAT'S
COULD BE A SUBSTANTIAL VECTOR.
SPREAD OF THE DISEASE SO I
UNDERSTAND THAT CHILD CARE WE
MAKE SURE THAT OUR EMERGENCY
MEDICAL PERSONNEL ARE ABLE TO
GO TO WORK AND SO CHILD CARE IS
IMPORTANT FOR THAT BUT ALSO HE
SPENT MONEY. I'M SHORING UP OR
SAFETY AND THE IT MIGHT BE.
THROUGH THE MIGHT EVEN BE WHY
IS A BY BE SOMETHING AGREE WITH
WHEN RATING IT. SETTING
GOVERNOR. BUT THAT'S NOT
SOMETHING THAT I FEEL WAS GIVE
HIM THE AUTHOR TO ALLOCATE
MONEY FOR UNDER SB EIGHTY NINE
I SB EIGHTY NINE THAT SECTION
THIRTY SIX THE SECTION WE'RE
DISCUSSING SAYS HALF A BILLION
DOLLARS IS HEREBY APPROPRIATED
FROM THE GENERAL FUND FOR ANY
ITEM FOR ANY PURPOSE RELATED TO
THE MARCH FIRST FOURTH. SEE
UNDER ORDER THE- FINANCE SO
THAT'S WHAT IT SAYS IT HAS TO
BE REALLY TO THAT PROCLAMATION
SO MY QUESTION FOR THE PARMA
FINANCES HOW IS SPENDING ON
SOCIAL SAFETY NET PROGRAMS
RELATED TO THAT PROCLAMATION OF
EMERGENCY. THANK YOU MISTER
OBERNOLTE FOR THAT QUESTION
I'LL SPEAK BRIEFLY AND THEN I
MAY TURN IT OVER AS WELL MY
COLLEAGUE AND SHE REACHED HHS
UNIT HERE AT FINANCE I THINK
THE MAIN THING IS. THAT REVIEW
ALL THESE EXPENDITURES ASKED
WAITED TO THE KOBE NINETEEN
EMERGENCY RESPONSE AND SOME OF
THEM AS YOU MENTIONED ARE
DIRECTLY RELATED TO SCALING.
HOSPITALS ARE PASSING THE
PERSONAL PROTECTIVE EQUIPMENT.
BUT FOR SOME OF THESE OTHER
CATEGORIES IT'S ALSO ABOUT
MINIMIZING IN THE SHORT TERM
THE IMPACT ON THE MOST
VULNERABLE POPULATIONS WE KNOW
THAT. THEY WERE GOING A COUPLE
WEEKS THROUGH THE VISION
PROCESS REGION BUDGET ACT MAN
IT JUST SO HAPPENSTHAT THOSE
DEADLINES WILL BE PRETTY SOON
WHEN IT COMES TO SOME OF THE
LONGER TURNS ACTIONS THAT WE
WILL PROPOSE TO UNDERTAKE. BUT
WE ALSO KNOW THAT EVEN THOUGH
FEDERAL SYSTEMS HAS BEEN THE
OVERALL PACKAGE WAS VERY
SIGNIFICANT OVER TWO TRILLION
DOLLARS THERE WERE A LOT OF
GAPS IN THERE SOMEPLACE IS
WORKING OR NOT ME TOO WELL SOME
PLACES WERE IMPACTED AND
CHANGED. DIDN'T NECESSARILY
PROVIDE LIMITATION ALL UP
THROUGH THAT WE NEED AND SOME
PLACES WHERE THERE ARE STILL
VULNERABLE. HEALTH THAT ARE
GETTING THE MORE THAN EIGHTY
EIGHT IN STOCK. AND COURSE
EIGHTY NINE. PROVIDED ONE
BILLION DOLLARS OVER. THAT'S
LESS THAN ONE TENTH OF 1% OF
THE WORLD'S DRAWING. NUMBERS
ARE PACKED. THE GOVERNOR
DIRECTION AND SAID BOTH FOCUS
ON UP TO. CAPACITY ALSO ON
THOSE MOST. POPULATIONS SO DO
VIEW THAT AS TO. RELEVANT ON
THE ARE POPULATION THAT NEED
RIGHT NOW- AND AS YOU KNOW WITH
ASKING LOCAL GOVERNMENT VERY
CLOSE PARTNERSHIPS WITH THE
COUNTIES IN TERMS OF THE- WORK.
REGARDING THE SOCIAL SERVICE
PROGRAMS AND FOR THE DETAILS OF
THAT SPECIFIC PER DAY YOU ASKED
ABOUT ALTERNATE OFFERED. SHE.
HELLO THAT- THIS IS ADAM TO
RECEIVE THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE- SO YES I THINK IF
THERE WERE- THERE WERE A FEW
THINGS IN THIS AREA THAT WERE-
WHERE WE NOTICED AN IMMEDIATE
YOU CRITICAL NEED AND ONE EXAM.
ALL ALL TAKE IS SORT OF MONEY
FOR THE FOOD BANKS. SO FOR
EXAMPLE AS THE BIG CRUNCH AND
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT MADE A
SIGNIFICANT. HERE IN-
EMERGENCY. THAT'S BUT WHAT WE
LEARNED IS THAT WE WERE SEEING
AN IMMEDIATE. IS IN DEMAND FOR
FOOD ASSISTANCE. AND THE
FEDERAL MONEY THAT WAS
APPROPRIATED IT I'M WAS NOT
GOING TO BE AVAILABLE TILL JULY
AND SO THIS WAS AN AREA WHERE.
WE SAW AN IMMEDIATE NEED THAT
NEEDED TO BE ADDRESSED AND THE
FEDERAL INVESTMENT WAS NOT
GOING TO IT TO COME FOR A
COUPLE OF MONTHS AND SO THE
STATE- YOU KNOW WE STEPPED IN
AND BEAT INVESTMENT THERE ARE
TWO TO FILL THOSE IMMEDIATE
NEEDS IS. RESULT OF THE CRISIS.
AND SO I DID TO THE TEXAS AND
SO WE'VE BEEN TRYING TO
ADDRESS- THROUGH THE SB EIGHT
AND I PROCESS. RIGHT THANK YOU
FOR THE RESPONSE BUT- MY
QUESTION WAS NOT WHETHER OR NOT
THIS WAS NEEDED. WHETHER OR NOT
IT WAS WISE MY QUESTION IS
WHETHER OR NOT THE GOVERNOR HAD
THE STATUTORY AUTHORITY.TO
SPEND THE MONEY ON SOCIAL
SAFETY NET PROGRAMS. AND IT'S
CLEAR TO ME THAT HE DID NOT.
THE DECLARATION OF EMERGENCY
WAS VERY DETAIL TO TALK ABOUT
FAIR GROUNDS A TALKED ABOUT
STATE OWNED PROPERTIES. RESPOND
HERS HOSPITALS- MEDICAL
PERSONNEL PRICE GOUGING. IT DID
NOT TALK ABOUT THE SOCIAL
SAFETY NET AND THERE'S A REASON
FOR THAT BECAUSE- IN SB EIGHTY
NINE THERE'S ANOTHER SECTION WE
WOULD TALK ABOUT SECTION THIRTY
SIX. AND THIRTY SEVEN SAYS.
IT'S THE INTENT OF THE
LEGISLATURE THE ADMINISTRATOR
CAN WORK WITH STAKEHOLDERS
INCLUDING MEMBERS OF THE
LEGISLATURE LEGISLATOR AFTER.
HELPING SHREDDED TO BE
CONSIDERED FOR AN- ON THE BALL.
ASSIST VISUAL NONPROFIT WORK
SMALL BUSINESS EXPECTING EIGHT.
SHIP TO THE IMPACT OF IT. OKAY
SO THAT'S BY THE WASTE I JUST
READ YOUR- BILL THAT ALWAYS YOU
NINE DOES OTHER THAN. DOES A-
MARBLE. OF BILLS. HI IT'S SAFE
SECTION SIX WE'RE THE GOVERNOR
THE A FULL. IN THIS MONEY IN.
TO THE FIGHT FIRST ANSWER.
SEVEN WE'VE ALLEGE. WOULD LIKE
TO PARTNER WITH THE GOV. IN
ADDRESSING THE SOCIAL IMPACTS
OF CODED THROUGH THE BUDGET
PROCESS SO I FEEL LIKE THE
LEGISLATURE'S BEEN BY PASSED ON
THIS ISSUE. AND I'D LIKE TO ASK
THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE TO
PLEASE DO WHAT THE LEGISLATION
HAS SAID AND PARTNER WITH US.
IN SHORING UP OUR SOCIAL SAFETY
NET AS WE MOVE FORWARD- I ALSO
QUESTION FOR. OH YEAH. NOW WE
UNDERSTAND THAT. IF YOU EFFORT.
EXPENDED IN OF THESE PROGRAMS
FOR THE PROCUREMENT OF PP
CREATING A DISTRIBUTION
WAREHOUSE IN A SYSTEM FOR
GETTING THOSE OUT TO THE-
ORGANIZATIONS AND COMMUNITIES
THAT NEED THEM- AND WERE I
THINK YOU DIED OF A NEW UNITED
IN OUR DESIRE TO SEE THAT BE AS
EFFICIENT AND X. BUT IT. IS
POSSIBLE. AB I'M THOUGHT THINK
EVERYONE IS DíAS HAS HEARD
STORIES FROM OUR LOCAL
COMMUNITIES ABOUT. HOSPITALS
AND COUNTIES AND CITIES THAT.
SUBMITTED REQUESTS FOR PP TO
THE STATE AND THEN JUST DIDN'T
HEAR BACK SO I'LL TELL YOU SOME
STORIES FROM MY OWN DISTRICT-
I'VE HAD HOSPITALS THAT
SUBMITTED REQUESTS. THAT THEY
THEY NEVER HEARD WORD ONE. AND
THEN A COUPLE WEEKS LATER. 10%
OF THE- TOP. SHOWED UP AND
NOTHING WAS SAID AND SO MY
QUESTION IS THIS I MEAN WE
UNDERSTANDING THAT THIS THIS
THIS IS A CRISIS THERE'S A HUGE
NEED BUT CAN'T WE BE A LITTLE
BIT BETTER AT PROVIDING GOOD
CUSTOMER SERVICE. OR IS IT IS A
QUICK BUT AT LEAST I THINK
RESPONDING TO REQUEST EVEN IF
IT'S TO STAY WE GOT YOUR
REQUEST FOR PROCESSING AT WORK
ON FIRST HEALTH OR- CAN'T FEEL
RIGHT NOW WE'RE SORRY WE THINK
WE'RE GOING TO BE ABLE TO. AT
THIS A CERTAIN DATE IN ORDER
YOU KNOW. AT ALL THE BIG 10% I
MEAN I. SHOULD BE DOING A
BETTER JOB. TO CONVICTING THEIR
IN. LIKE TO KNOW IF FOR MAKE
OUT AT RISK. SO THIS IS
REGARDED YOU THANKS FOR THE
QUESTION- I GUESS LET ME START
OFF BY SAYING THAT. OF THE
SCOPE AND SCALE OF THIS ADVANCE
HAS REALLY DICTATED THE NEED
FOR US DEVELOPING AND
IMPLEMENTING THE MOST EXTENSIVE
LARGEST MOST COMPLICATED
LOGISTICS DELIVERY AND
COMMODITY PROCUREMENT. EFFORT
WE'VE EVER DONE IN THE STATE'S
HISTORY. IN DOING SO OUR EFFORT
HAS BEEN WORKING VERY VERY
CLOSE THEY ALL WITH THE
EMERGENCY MEDICAL SERVICES
AUTHORITY HELP. BUT HELL
SUPPORT THEM IN THEIR ACTING
COORDINATING HOSPITALS AND- AND
COUNTIES THROUGHOUT THE STATE
BEING ABLE TO- PROVIDE HE AND
OTHER COMMODITIES AS NECESSARY.
THAT WAS ALL DONE IN REAL TIME
UP WE'VE WE OF COURSE BUILT ON
THE EXIST THE WAY WE DO- THIS
KIND OF ABANDONED DISASTERS BUT
AGAIN THE IT'S NOT- IT'S NOT A
COMMON PLACE TO HAVE AN
ADVANTAGE ALL FIFTY EIGHT
COUNTIES. EVERY HOSPITAL IN THE
STATE EVERY FIRST RESPONDING
AGENCY IN THE STATE IS THE
INTERMEDIATE NEEDS OF THESE
KIND OF COMMODITIES- SO- THE
EFFORT WAS TO FORCE MULTIPLY
HERE AND BUILD A VERY
EXTENSIVE- CAPABILITY- THAT NOT
ONLY INCLUDED- THE OF THE
LEVERAGING ALL OF THE STATE
ASSETS ARE DEPARTMENT WILL
SERVICES AND OTHER. BUT ALSO
PARTNERING WITH OUR FEDERAL
PARTNERS A FEW OTHER OF FEDERAL
AID HHS WORK. TO AS MAY. I'M
ALWAYS REPOSSESSED POP LIKE
THAT U. S. AT U. S. SAID MAYBE
MERCY TO BE ABLE TO LOG WHAT
CAPER. BECAUSE THE TIME ON ON.
THAT'S JUST. BETTER MORE
EFFICIENT AND MORE EFFECTIVE
ALSO REAL TIME A WHY WOULD WITH
A- WE WERE CARRYING COMMODITIES
AND IN A VERY COMPETITIVE
MARKET AND BEING ABLE TO GET
THOSE THOSE RESOURCES IN. AS
FAST WE POSSIBLY COULD AND GET
THEM OUT TO THE STATE OUT
THROUGHOUT THE STATE LASTLY IN
WORKING WITH THE HOSPITAL CARE
SYSTEM. THEY ALSO WERE DOING
THEIR BEST TO ASSESS WHAT
COMMODITIES WERE AVAILABLE IN
THEIR HOSPITALS AND THEIR
EXISTING PIPELINE AND WE
COMPARE THE TWO TO BE ABLE TO.
UP A SORT OF A- THE ONE WEBSITE
I. OF MOVING THIS FORWARD ALL
ABOUT IS YOU. YOU'RE QUITE AN
AD UP THIS. HERCULES EFFORT. IN
A VERY BROAD SCALE AND THAT- I
THINK THAT IT IS SELF OPERATING
RELATIVELY OFFICIALLY NOW- AND
WILL HOPEFULLY WE'LL GET
CONTINUE TO GET BETTER AS THE
DAYS AND WEEKS A MOVE ON. ALL
RIGHT THANK YOU AND I JUST TO
BE CLEAR I MEAN WE WE'RE TRYING
TO HELPTHE SITUATION WE'RE ON
THE SAME TEAM HERE WE ALL OF US
IN GOAL- BUT I'D LIKE TO ASK
THAT. WHICH LOOK AT THIS SYSTEM
FROM THE STANDPOINT OF THE
PEOPLE IN OUR COMMUNITY ASKING
SO QUITMAN AND PUT OURSELVES IN
THEIR SHOES ABOUT WHEN THEY
MAKE A REQUEST AT LEAST WE
OUGHT TO RESPOND. AND THEM THAT
WE GET THEIR REQUEST WERE
PROCESSING AND EVEN. UNDER THEM.
I PEOPLE IN OUR COMMUNITY KNOW
THE STATUS OF THE EQUIPMENT
THAT THEY'RE ORDERING AND THEN
I HAVE A LAST QUESTION FOR THE
LA- MISTER PETTIT. THE
UNEMPLOYMENT INSURANCE SYSTEM
AND- I WONDER IF YOU IT WE
WE'VE CERTAINLY SEEN IN RECENT
WEEKS THE SURGE IN UNEMPLOYMENT
INSURANCE CLAIMS VERY HAPPY TO
SEE THE EDT OPEN UP THAT NEW
CALL CENTER THIS WEEK I THINK
THAT THAT'S AT LEAST GOING TO
GIVE PEOPLE. THE ABILITY TO GET
THEIR CLAIMS AND THEN THERE IS
THE PROCESSING- STARTED ON
THEM- COULD YOU GIVE US AN
UPDATE ON THE FINANCES OF THE
BE ON MANAGER TRUST FUND AND
WHETHER OR NOT- THAT FUND IS
NOW- INSTALLED DID WITHOUT YOU
KNOW WE'RE HAPPY TAKE TWELVE
TITLED. SITUATION WITH A LITTLE
OVER TWO TWO BILLION IN IN THE
TRUST FUND RESERVE ALTHOUGH I
DON'T KNOW AT THIS POINT- HAVE
IT. EIGHT YEAH I DON'T KNOW AT
THIS POINT IF I HAVE A THAT
CURRENT FIGURE ON THAT THE
BALANCE AS IT STANDS TODAY THE
ADMINISTRATION MIGHT HAVE SOME
INSIGHT ON THAT PERHAPS. IT IS
ADDED TO MAKE THIS ONE OFTEN
AGAIN WOULD DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE AS THE ONLY MENTIONED
WE DID HAVE- LAWS BALANCE IN
THE LOW SINGLE DIGIT GOING TO
DOLLARS COMING INTO. EMERGENCY
HAS ALSO SEEN WITH THAT DATA IN
TERMS OF THE NUMBER AT
UNEMPLOYMENT PLATE. YOUR IN
CALIFORNIA KNOWING. LAST
PASSAGE OF IT'S ON I IN TURN OF
THIS OF THE OF CLAY THAT YOU
COMPARE WITH A GREAT TEN YEARS
AGO OR SO WHAT THE STATE HAS
DONE A TAKEN TO TAKE SOME GOING
DOLLARS STAND ALONE FROM GOT
JUST AS WE DID DURING THE GREAT.
ALTER OVER MY COLLEAGUE WHO MAY
HAVE SOME ADDITIONAL TO. THANK
YOU CHRIS COOKED OF FOR AS A-
APRIL. SEVENTEEN THE YOU ARE BY
WAS A PROXY ONE SAID BILLION
DOLLARS BUT I'LL JUST KNOW THAT.
NO GIVEN THE SIR IN THE U. I.
R. NUMBER OF YOU I CLICK. THE
PART EDT HAS BEEN INCOME
CONTACT WITH THE GOVERNMENT TO
IT TO. THE MONITOR THE INCOME
PLAYING. ON A OUT. ARRANGEMENTS
TO DRIVE THIS FEDERAL ON I BE
ALONE. IN THE PALE THE ON THE
CLAIMS. THAT THEY RECEIVE. ALL
RIGHT THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
THE RICH FOLLOW UP QUESTION
MISTER THIS ONE. SINCE WE ARE
TAKING OUT TITLED FOR THE
GOVERNMENT ARE FROM THE FEDERAL
WHEN WE THAT A TWO EIGHT. THE
STATE DID PAY THOSE LAW BACK
AND AS A RESULT THEIR RESEARCH
ARE ON EVERY EMPLOYEE IN THIS
OF FOR AND YEARS ALL THE WAY
TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN WHEN
LOANS WERE FINALLY BACK SO THE
WORD THIS TOOK OUT. BUT
EMPLOYERS AND ENDED UP HAPPEN
TO PICK ONE I'M ONE INTENTIONS
ARE FOR THE STATE WITH RISK TO
THE TITLE TWELVE LOANS TIME
OTHER WORDS IT TAKE GOING TO
THE- WORD. INTO NOT BACK.
CHARGES BUT THE NOT EVERY
EMPLOYER IN. DO I THINK ON THE
WILL HAVE MORE TO SAY WITHIN A
I CAN TELL YOU BRIEFLY WHERE WE
ARE. AT RIGHT NOW WHICH IS THAT
THE FEDERAL IN THE BILL THAT IT.
I SAID THAT THEY WERE BE NO
CHARGES THE STATE ON THOSE AT
LEAST FOR THE END OF THIS CAN
YEAR TWENTY SO ARE A TEN TO
DISCUSS NOT ONLY A ANY OF
BURDEN AND- MENTION. SO.
QUESTION AROUND. THAT BROADER
POINT ABOUT FEDERAL SUPPORT I
THINK WILL BE ESPECIALLY
IMPORTANT HERE BECAUSE I THINK
WHAT YOU'LL SEE IS CALIFORNIA
OF COURSE IS THE BIG STATE WILL
BE TAKING THE LARGEST. LIKELY
THAT TAKING AMONG THE LARGEST
NUMBER OF LOAN AMOUNT OF LOANS
FROM THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT
THERE WILL BE A NUMBER OF
STATES. ACROSS THE COUNTRY I
CAN DISTORT. DESCRIBE WILL BE
TAKING THOSE LOANS SO WHAT WE
ARE HOPING FOR IS FOR THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT JUST. US
THIS PAST APRIL WILL TURN AS
POSS. UNDER HIS THE REQUESTED.
A RISK WHEN IT COMES TO. CHARGE
PHONES. THE END OF TWENTY
TWENTY. THAT THEY CAN SEEM ON.
THE ON THIS. AND ALL JUST TURN
IT ON. MICHAEL I JUST LOOK AT
THE GENERAL. HE IS HELPED.
STARTING PRIOR TO FUND LOAN AND
FROM GENERAL THERE WERE KIND OF
TWO THINGS THAT HAPPEN TO AND
THE STATE AS AS AD ARCH DEPUTY
MENTION THE- GEN FUND PAGE A
LITTLE OVER DOLLARS IN INTEREST
PAYMENTS THAT DID NOT GET. ON
TO MY LAWYER. EMPLOYERS THOSE.
I'M SOME IMPACT BASED ON THE
OUTSTANDING BALANCE IN TOTAL
LOAN WAS PAID IN FULL BECAUSE
THERE ARE FOOD AT THE FEDERAL
UNEMPLOYMENT INSURANCE TAX AND
ACT AT CREDIT WAS. UP AND MAKE
EACH YEAR AND THAT CREDIT
REDUCTION KIND OF HAPPEN AND
POINT THREE TEN INCREMENTS
COMPARED TO WHAT IT WOULD
TYPICALLY PAY AND THE FOOD TAX.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
RESPONSE IF I COULD ASK THAT
FOR OUR HEARING NEXT WEEKTHAT
WE BE PREPARED- TO IT WAS NOT
ON. EXACTLY WHAT THE STATUSIS
WITH THE NUMBER OF FEDERAL
LOANS HAVE BEEN TAKEN IN THE
BALANCE THE U. I TRUST OKAY. I
AM SO WHAT OUR PLANS ARE FOR
EVENTUALLY PAYING THAT MONEY
BACK I THINK THERE'S IN THE
REVENUE TAKE THESE LOANS THAT'S
THE PURPOSE OF ASSISTING OR UP
THE PIZZA. BUT IT SHAME. IF THE
STATE. HE WHAT IF WANT TO FOR
ARE SMALL BUSINESSES AND CAL AS
WE DID LAST TIME SMALL
BUSINESSES HAVE NOT TO PLAY IN
THE CURRENT CRISIS WAS NOT
THEIR FAULT A TWO EXPECTED TO
PAY THAT BACK WOULD BE SHAMEFUL
LIKE TO ASK HI IT IN HER NEXT
WEEK THAT WE BE ABLE TO. I WHAT
ARE. WHAT THE INSTANCE OF THE
STATE'S ALL. BACK TO PRINCE. SO
THANK YOU MUCH OF FOR THE FOR
THE ANSWERS ARE I WANT TO
REITERATE WE'RE ON THIS TEAM
BUT WE CERTAINLY WANT TO MAKE
SURE THAT WE DO WELL OUR
RESPONSIBILITY IN TERMS OF SIDE
OF THIS SO YOU. MISTER THANK
YOU. TO MISTER PROGRAM MISTER
JACK HE'D BE WILLING TO SHARE
THE SLIDES THAT HE PRESENTED
EARLIER WITH THE COMMITTEE
WOULD LIKE TO COME ONLINE WE'VE
BEEN GETTING QUITE A FEW
QUESTIONS REGARDING GUY GETTING
OUT. TO THE- THIS IS MY-
HELPING HIM IN SERVICE IN WE
WILL SEND THAT YOUR STAFF AND
YOUR MORE THAN WELCOME TO PRESS
THAT ON YOUR WEBSITE THANK YOU
MISTER COOPER. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR I'M NOT. FOR FIVE.
BESIDES ROOM KEY. WATER LOCALS
IN YOU'LL SEE SPENDING A
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS ON.
THANK YOU MISTER COOPER I WILL
I TURN THIS OVER TO YOU. STOCK.
MORNING THANK YOU FOR THE
QUESTION ASSEMBLY MEMBER SO.
TODAY WE'RE WITH YOU KNOW
AGENCIES AIRED LOCALS ARE JUST
NOW RECEIVING A LOT OF THAT
MONEY- THROUGH THE HUNDRED
MILLION- SOME OF THE PRIMARY.
THINGS THAT THEY'RE SPENDING I
ON IS THERE SUPPORTING PROP
ROOM KEY EFFORTS THEIR PURCHASE
SEEN OUR EQUIPMENT AND SUPPLIES
TO PREVENT THE SPREAD OF
INFECTION FOR EXAMPLE- CLEANING
SUPPLY. P. E. N. SENATE-
TELEVISION STATIONS- THEY'RE
ALSO USING THE FUNDS TO EXPAND
CHAU CAPACITY TO HELP WITH
SOCIAL GIPSON SEEN. OUR PAIN-
OUTREACH. ADDITIONAL FOR THEIR
ON AND SHOULDER AND THAT
HOMELESS COORDINATING HOW
FINANCING COUNCIL. STRONGLY
ENCOURAGING THOSE COMMUNITIES-
ARTIST SPENDING THESE FUNDS- ON
ROOM KEY AT IN PARTICULAR- SO
THEY COULD- LEVERAGE THAT BEING
A REIMBURSABLE DOLLARS AND
MAXIMIZE THEIR AND THAT THESE
FUNDS. THANK YOU NOW THAT WE'VE
WORKED TO SHELTER MANY HOMELESS
DURING THIS CRISIS HAS
ADMINISTRATION THOUGHT ABOUT
WHAT HAPPENS NEXT. HOW WE KEEP
THESE PEOPLE IDENTIFIED
SHELTERED AND MOVED TO THE MORE
PERMANENT HOUSING MOVING
FORWARD. EIGHT SO- THE LONG
TERM GOALS OF YOU KNOW TO
STAINING THESE INDIVIDUALS ANY
IS SOMETHING THAT WHAT THE
ADMINISTRATION IS CURRENTLY-
CONTINUING TO LOOK AT AND
DEFINITELY- ONE O'CLOCK SB I
LEGISLATURE TO. LOOK FOR
SOLUTIONS BUT THAT'S SOMETHING
THAT WE'RE STILL OUT LOOKING AT
MORE OF A LONG TERM. IN THIS
ONE MORE QUESTION IF. THIS
DIAGNOSED WITH COPD NINETEEN
REFUSES TO ISOLATE AND SIGNED
HOUSING WHAT IS YOUR PLAN. I'M
IF THEY'RE REFUSING TREATMENT I
THINK YOU KNOW THAT IN THERE
LOCALS ARE ENCOURAGING THEM AS
MUCH AS THEY CAN TO I TAKE
OPPORTUNITY FOR THESE. THE
PROJECT ROOM KEY SITES OUR
SHELTER AND TO THE EXTENT THAT
THEY'RE NOT DOING THAT YOU KNOW
THEY'RE OFFERING SERVICES IN
MAKING SURE THAT INDIVIDUALS
ARE AWARE OF THE SERVICES THEY
ARE AVAILABLE TO THEM-
UNFORTUNATELY WE CAN'T FORCE
THEM TO. YOU KNOW. THE ROOM IN
THESE PLACES- BUT- YOU KNOW
DEFINITELY ENCOURAGING THEM AND
ENSURING THAT THEY ARE AWARE OF
THE SERVICES AND SUPPORTS. AND
PROVIDING- YOU KNOW BILL
SERVICES WHEN NEEDED. SO THAT
REALLY DOESN'T HAS AND SO IT
WITH THEY DIDN'T REFUSE ALL
THOSE THINGS. AND HELP AND
ASSISTANCE WHERE THE NEXT STEPS
THE ADMINISTRATION PLAN ON
DOING. THAT'S IT DOESN'T REALLY
GET TO THE REAL PROBLEM. RIGHT
YEAH I. I DON'T I DON'T. YOU
KNOW AGAIN WE'RE JUST PROVIDING
AS MUCH SUPPORT AS IS NEEDED
AND YOU KNOW- TO THE EXTENT WE
CAN GET THEM YEAH IN THE
SERVICES. THAT'S THE OLD KOHLER
THE HEALTH AND SAFETY AND THE
OTHERS AROUND SO JUST IN.
PERSON THE SERVICES. AND YEAH
IF MY MIKE MARK ME CHECK ANY
COMMENTS. LIKE TO TURN OVER FOR
HIM WELL AND THE REASON I BRING
THIS UP THIS IS A HIGH RISK
GROUP WE KNOW- BUT A LOT OF.
WILL HELP TO USE SUCH AS THE
BIGGEST ISSUES. SO WE WRAP
AROUND THIS BIG FOLKS- RICK.
AND WE DO WANT TO SPREAD SO GOT
A HOW WE DEAL WITH THIS. IT IS
A PROBLEM ARE LOCALS ARE DOING
WITH IT WE'VE GOT TO GIVE
DIRECTION FROM UP FROM DOWN UP
TOP. FROM DOWN. ASSEMBLY MEMBER
THIS IS MARK A MAJOR AT THE
HEALTH AND HUMAN SERVICES
AGENCY THANK YOU FOR THAT
QUESTION AND I APPRECIATE- THE
RESPONSE FROM MY COLLEAGUE AT
THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. I
THINK THE APPROACH THAT WE ARE
TAKING HERE IS REALLY LOOKING
TO WORK WITH OUR LOCAL. WHICH
THESE ASSETS. INTO I REALLY.
STAND HOW WE CAN BETTER HELP AT
THE INDIVIDUALS FROM MOST
VULNERABLE IN THIS INSTANCE.
IT'S THE INDIVIDUAL WHO IS
HOMELESS AND COVERT POSITIVE.
AND MAKE SURE THAT THEY ARE
GETTING THE SUPPORT OF CARE
UNFORTUNATELY THERE IS NO
TREATMENT. FOR COVERED NINETEEN
YET BUT THERE ARE. THAT WE CAN.
ACCESS THEM. IT'S NOT GOING TO
BE THE STATE TELL. INDIVIDUAL
AFTER GO IN TO OUR INTO OUR-
BUT IT'S A IT'S THE PEOPLE WHO
DIED IN THE- TRUST BE. SIR IS
FROM THEM AT A LOT LEVEL THAT
CAN AND NOT. THAT HE OR SHE IS
WORKING WITH ON A BASIS AND
THOSE ARE THE- THAT WE ARE.
TRUSTED MESSENGERS IN THE CAN
BE DURING WITH THESE POPULAR.
TAYLOR RIGHT TO THEM THAT ARE
YOU ARE BEING- PUT IN A HOTEL
AND WHAT WRAPAROUND SERVICES WE
CAN OFFER THEM. THANK YOU
MISTER COOPER GONE MUST FOLLOW.
I THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR. I
THINK FIRST MY FIRST QUESTION
GHOST- DEMARCO JUST UNDERSTAND-
THE MODELING ME NOW MORE THAN
EVER THE PUBLIC- BY THE ROUGHLY
WANTS TO KNOW AS MUCH AS
POSSIBLE. TO UNDERSTAND YOU
KNOW WHY THESE DECISIONS ARE
BEING MADE BY THE GOVERNOR CAN
YOU AND YOU AND I DO AGREE THAT
THE MODEL IS ONLY AS GOOD AS
THE ASSUMPTIONS THAT ARE PUT
INTO IT SO CAN YOU. SHARE SOME
OF THE SOME. MODELING THAT.
SURE I AM HAPPY TO DO THAT
ASSEMBLY MEMBER SO- WE'VE
LOOKED AT AT THIS PARTICULAR
MODEL IS THE JOHNS HOPKINS
MODEL I AND WE ARE LOOKING AT A
NUMBER OF DIFFERENT MODELS SO
THAT YOU PAY MY ONE THAT WE'RE
LOOKING AT LEAVE THE UNIVERSITY
OF WASHINGTON ANOTHER MODEL THE
REASON WHY- THE U. PANAMA I
THANK YOU JOHNS HOPKINS WASN'T.
TO READ. IT RUN. RIGHT THERE
RUNS PROBABLY AT. BILL
BALLISTIC. ON A THOUSAND
DIFFERENT SCENARIOS- AND SO IT
GIVES YOU A RANGE IN TERMS OF
WHERE YOU MIGHT BE THE OTHER
REASON WE LIKE THAT JOHN TOP
MODEL. THAT IT GAVE ELEVEN DATA
SAID THAT WE HAD. THE RK ALI.
WHAT HAPPENED. THERE ARE TWO AT
AREA SO IN OF THE OF THE BASS
LINE OF SOME JUST RUN THEM AT
THE MEDICARE ARE NOT VALUE FOR
THOSE OF YOU I'M WITH ARE NOT
ARE NOT IS A VALUE THAT IS.
GIVEN IN A PRETTY NEAT. AT HOW
MANY THE END OF IT IT IS AND
HOW MANY INDIVIDUALS MIGHT B
IN FACT. GIVE YOU SOME CONTEXT
AND ARE NOT VALUE OF ONE
ANYTHING BELOW ONE MEANS THAT
THE VIRUS WHAT KIND OF FADE
OUT. ANYTHING WITHIN ONE. OVER
ONE MEANS THAT AT THEIR COULD
POTENTIALLY BE A PANDEMIC ARE
EPIDEMIC OR AN OUTBREAK PRETEND
TO MAKE IN THIS INSTANCE YOU
KNOW WE'RE LOOKING AT A TWO TO
THREE THIS IS IN A LOT AND WITH
THE HELP IT IS A CAN. WELL
CENTER CAN PREVENT. BUT WHAT.
PARTICULARLY WITH THE SENATE
DISEASE PREVENTION IN LOOKING
AT WHAT THE UNMITIGATED ARE NOT
VALUE LOOKS LIKE IN TERMS OF
THE HOSPITAL. WE'RE LOOKING AT
IT PERCENT STATION RATE WITHIN
THIS PARTICULAR MODEL WE ARE
ALSO LOOK AT A 32% CLOSE THIS
OF VETERANS WERE HOT. IN THE
SEE YOU SO THE ARE KIND OF
UNDER S. THAT FEED INTO THIS
PARTICULAR MODEL HAVE. YOU
MIGHT HAVE SO ONE ONE OF. A
FOLLOW UP TO THAT TO THAT IS
THAT CERTAINLY THE MODELING AND
THE ASSUMPTIONS ARE BASED ON
THE TESTING LEVELS AND EACH
EACH CAT IS HAS. A CERTAIN
PROTESTING CAPACITY- CORRECT
YES TO MORE THAN OTHER
COUNTIES- IN THE CENTRAL VALLEY
LA IN THE BAY AREA CERTAINLY
OUR TESTING. DUE TO THE LA
ABRASIVE EXISTED DOES THE
MODELING THAT YOU CURRENTLY
USED THE JOB AT. AT THE MODEL
NOT A ANY THE MODELS ARE NOT
BAKED IN TESTING WHAT WHAT
REALLY- THE ACTUAL DATA THAT
WE'RE GETTING CERTAINLY IS
BASED ON TESTING BECAUSE THAT
SOMEBODY HAS TO BE TASK IN
ORDER TO CONFIRM POSITIVE BUT
THE ACTION THAT WERE THAT
FUNCTION OF TESTING TO SOME
EXTENT- BUT THE ACTUAL MY OF
DATA THAT'S COMING OUT OF THE
MODEL. NOT ADJUSTED TO THE TIME.
SO THEN IN OF THE INTERACTIONS
BETWEEN THE DATA AND THAT AND
THAT AND THE MODELING EVEN A
QUE THEY CLEARLY WERE MAKING
DECISIONS ON REAL TIME DATA SO
HOSPITALS UP AS AT LEAST THE
ONES THAT I'M FAMILIAR WITH AND
KERN COUNTY THAT THEIR- THEY-
SO HOW. YOU ADJUSTING THEN FOR
A HOW DO YOU AND HOW ARE YOU
FACTORING IN THOSE TYPES OF-
DATA. TO IS TO ALLOW. THE
DOUBLE HOSPITALS TO RE OPEN AND
A LOT AND DO DO SURGERIES ARE
YOU IS THAT PART OF THE GEN IN
TERMS OF WELL AS WE JUST MOVING.
YEAH THAT'S QUESTION DOWN A
TREE JOB INCLUDING THE IN YOUR
DE I'VE BEEN IN INCREDIBLE JOB
OF DOING TWO THINGS ONE THEY
HAVE DEPRESSED MEANING THAT
THEY'VE MOVED LEVEL JOBS DON'T
NEED AT A KEY LEVEL CARE
HOSPITAL LEVEL CARE TO OTHER
STRINGS- AND THEN MORE
IMPORTANTLY THEY'VE ALSO BUILT
UP A SURGE CAPACITY AND SO THEY
ARE PREPARED IT. CAN HAVE
OVERNIGHT. OUR I SEE YOU BACK
RATE RK STRAIGHT OUT THAT WILL
HELP IN THINKING REGARDS TO THE
INDICATORS THAT THE GOVERNOR
OUTLINED OUT WE CAN BE ABLE ARE
RIGHT THE DISH INFORMATION ON
THIS WE- I AROUND HOW DO WE-
HAVE. TO CERTAIN THINGS IN
ORDER TO MAKE MY- SUCH AS ARE
CERTAIN REASON PARTICULAR
HOSPITAL'S ASSET THAT WILL BE
PART OF THAT EQUATION THAT REAL
DATA REALLY HELPS US THINK
ABOUT WHAT DO WE DO MOVING
FORWARD AND THE SURGEON ONE OF
THOSE ASKED. SO I GUESS THE
FOLLOW UP ON THAT IS THERE
JUST. ALLOW FOR LACK OF BETTER
TERM NON HOT SPOT COUNTIES THE
ABILITY TO FACE AND BACK TO
WORK TO ALLOW HOSPITALS TO
REESTABLISH- THE SELECTED
PROCEDURES TO ALLOW PHYSICIANS
TO SEE PATIENTS TWO SIX CLEARLY
WITH THE SAME. CRITERIA
ESTABLISHED BODY IS THAT A
POSSIBILITY. SO THAT'S PART OF
THE EQUATION AND THAT'S PART OF
OUR THINKING IN REGARDS TO THE
SIX INDICATORS- I'VE BEEN
GOVERNOR ALTERNATELY WILL BE
ADVISED BY HIS PUBLIC HEALTH
AND SCIENCE ADVISERS AROUND-
YOU KNOW WHAT WE'RE SEEING WITH
GUARDS DATA AND THEN HOW. TO
MODIFY THOSE AT. HIGHS ARE
INTERNET THAT WE CAN PLACE THAT
CERTAINLY COULD BE AT STATE AID
OR IT COULD BE YOU KNOW BUT WE
HAVE TO BE VERY THOUGHT. IS
WHAT WE DON'T WANT. WHAT COMING
IN CAREER. PAN OR WHAT HAVE.
NINETEEN SIXTEEN PANDEMIC WITH
REGARDS TO THE CITY STAFF OR
ACT AREAS THAT TOOK ASKED WE
ACTION TO REACH AND WE NEED TO
BE VERY VERY THOUGHTFUL ABOUT
HOW WE DO THAT TOO. BUT THAT BY.
I WILL BE OUT SET IT. AFTER THE
INTERVENTIONS LEFT IN. OKAY AND
IN ERMS OF THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE- FOR THE PUBLIC
HOSPITALS MUCH OF THE SUB TO
FUNDING- IS PART OF THE CURRENT
ELEVEN FIFTEEN WAIVER WHAT IS
THE CURRENT STATUS AN EXTENSION
AND I THINK THAT. THE IT ON A
PER REPORTING BASIS JUST
BECAUSE AND NOW EVERYTHING IS
AS COVERT FOCUSED.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER ALTERNATE OVER
TO MY COLLEAGUE ADAM DORSEY TO
ANSWER THAT. HI MY- COMPUTER IS
FREEZING UP A LITTLE BIT OF
SEEMING EVERYONE CAN HEAR ME-
SO YES WE HAVE A NUMBER OF
WAIVER REQUEST- PENDING FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT NOW I'M SURE A LOT
OF THOSE WERE WERE WERE WAITING
STILL- FROM THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT YOU KNOW YOU'RE BACK
ON OF. I DON'T ANYTHING ELSE
FOR. THIS STAGE I'M BUT
DEPARTMENT HEALTHCARE SERVICES
HAS BEEN. RELEASING YOU KNOW
INFORMATION PUBLICLY AT SOME OF
THOSE THINGS THAT BECOME
APPROVED- THE SHOW- WILL WILL
PROVIDE MORE UPDATES ON THAT IS
THAT COM- BUT WITH RESPECT TO
FUTURE- YOU KNOW WHAT I THINK
SO. WITH THE GOVERNMENT I THINK
RIGHT NOW WHAT WE'RE TRYING TO
DO IS WE'RE TRYING TO CLOSE.
HOW THE ROLL OUT OF THE FEDERAL
ASSISTANCE. HAPPENED AND WE
KNOW THAT THERE'S A LOT OF
FEDERAL MONEY THERE THE FIRST.
GEN PROVIDER REALLY AND WE
THINK THAT'S BEEN HOW YOU KNOW
THE MORE I TO BE DONE AND THEN
THIRD THING I WOULD SAY IS THAT
WE CONTINUE TO WORK ON FEDERAL
ASK ON NEW FOR THAT PLACE AND
SPORTS AND WORKING FEDERAL
PARTNERS- TO MAKE SURE. THAT
FOR ASSISTANCE- IS KIND AND IS
THERE TO HELP SUPPORT THE
PROVIDER COMMUNITY. SO TO
FOLLOW UP ON THAT CERTAINLY
THERE YOU'VE EVEN A KID THERE
IS A SIGNIFICANT FINANCIAL
STRESS ON AND OFF DOCTORS RIGHT
NOW WE HAVE POSITION. STEMS
THAT MAY NOT BE ABLE TO
SURVIVE- THE DEPEND MAKE JUST
BECAUSE PATIENTS AREN'T ARE
GOING. DID THE REGULAR CHECK
UPS INTO GETTING SERVICES. THE
FEAR THAT THERE'S A SECOND
SURGE OUR HEALTHCARE SYSTEM BUT
CERTAINLY NON COVALENT MEDICAL
NEEDS- OF. THOUGH YOU KNOW THAT
THE INCREASE IN AND OTHER-
OTHER THAT. INCREASE OTHER
TREATMENT DISEASE IS AN AND
OTHER FACTORS IT WHAT IS THE
ADMINISTRATION'S PLAN TO
ADDRESS THAT. YEAH SO- MAYBE
I'LL START AND THEN- I CAN KICK
IT OFF TO. THE AGENCY HAS
ANYTHING ELSE TO ADD ON THIS
BUT- YOU'RE RIGHT OUT THIS IS
HAPPENING THIS IS SOMETHING
THAT YOU KNOW WE'RE HEARING
FROM THE PROVIDER COMMUNITY-
IT'S A- IT'S A STRESS FOR
INDIVIDUALS- WHO ARE DELAYING
CARE IT'S A STRESS. THE HEALTH-
FROM THE FINANCE ACTIVE- AND
IT'S SOMETHING THAT WERE YOU
KNOW LOOKING AT MODELING AND
TRYING TO THINK ABOUT- AND
FACTORING INTO A KIND OF THE
ASSISTANCE THAT WE'RE TRYING TO
PURSUE- SO. WE'RE OUR- THERE
WILL BE SOME. SORT OF SMART
BACK OF A THIRD SERVICES WILL
LIKELY OCCUR BUT WE DON'T KNOW
TO WHAT EXTENT AND WE'RE WE'RE
TRYING TO SORT OF PLAN FOR THAT
AND MODEL FOR THAT AS BEST WE
CAN- THINKING BEING COMING
MONSOON YOUR AND MARK. FROM
HEALTH. AGENCY YOU GOT IT. I AM
ASSEMBLY MEMBER FONG THANK YOU
FOR QUESTION AND ADAM AT YOU TO
A REALLY NAY JOB CAPTURING AND
I THINK THE THINGS THAT I WILL
ADD IS I THINK WE'RE BEING
PROACTIVE A STUNNED THE MEDIC
SIDE TO REALLY THINK ABOUT WHAT.
WE CAN PROVIDE FOR THEM TO
CONTINUE TO PROVIDE CARE. AS
ADAM MENTIONED YOU DO HAVE A
SERIES OF WAIVERS THAT ARE
PENDING BEFORE THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT. PRESS FISHEL
FLEXIBILITY WE RECOGNIZE THAT
THIS IS AN UNBELIEVABLY
DIFFICULT TIME FOR THEM TO.
ESPECIALLY SOME OF THE SMALLER
PRACTICES- WHERE THEY'RE NOT.
SEEING THE VOLUME. AT COMING
THROUGH THE DOOR. SO THAT IS.
FROM AT LEAST THE MEDICAID SIDE
AND THAT'S AN ACTIVE
CONVERSATION THAT WE'RE HAVING
WITH THE CENTERS FROM MEDICARE
AND MEDICAID SERVICES AT THE
FEDERAL LEVEL I APPRECIATE THAT.
TO HAVE TO THAT TOO CALLOW YES
IN TERMS OF THE PPO DISCUSSION-
I WANT TO I WANT TO PIGGYBACK
OFF WITH ASSEMBLY MEMBER
OBERNOLTE HAD INDICATED THAT
WHICH SEEMS AT IN CONVERSATIONS
WITH MY COLLEAGUES AND WITHIN
MY PUBLIC HEALTH DIRECTOR.
THERE A CORE LET CAN WHAT IS
ORDERED AND WHAT IS RECEIVED.
IS THERE A WAY TO- TO ADDRESS
THAT AND SO THAT IF. THERE IS A
SHIPMENT BEING A PP BEING SET
THAT IF IT'S 50% ORDER OF ITS
TAX AND THE ORDER OF ITS 95%
THE ORDER THAT THAT CAN BE.
THAT CAN BE TOLD IN ADVANCE TO
A PUBLIC HEALTH DIRECTORS SO
THEY DIDN'T TO EXPOSE. THANKS
FOR THE QUESTION SO MEMBER I AM
I WOULD JUST TELL YOU THAT- YOU
KNOW WE CAN CONTINUE TO ENSURE
THAT THAT OCCURS- THERE IS
THERE IS A LOT OF COORDINATION
AND COMMUNICATION IT'S GOING ON
BETWEEN. THE MYSTICS
DISTRIBUTION LIST AND THE
RECEIVING A REQUEST. BUT I'LL
YOU THAT- THAT YOU KNOW WILL
ENSURE THAT IT IF THAT
CONTINUES. IT CONTINUES TO BE.
AN ISSUE THAT THAT THAT WILL
CONTINUE. KEY YOU SHARE SOME OF
THE CRITERIA BEING YOU.
TERMINATING HOW MUCH IS
PROVIDED SO WELL IF. YES IT OUT
THERE YES IT. 10% FULHAM BUT
WHAT GOES INTO THAT GEN. YOU
ALL KNOW YOU KNOW GIVEN WE HAVE
A THIS IS DISASTER HEALTH YOU
KNOW AS AS WE DO IT AND MOST
EMERGES SINCE THIS COME AND
RESOURCE THAT ARE IN HIGH
DEMAND. AND WORK OR MAY SCARE
RE THERE'S YEAH PRIORITIZE
THROUGH THE STAFF AMBER THE
MANAGEMENT SAYS ALL WHICH ALL
THE COUNTIES COMMITTEE'S
JURISDICTION BRITISH. ALSO
SPENDING SOURCE ALLOCATE YEAH
OKAY IN AS RESEARCH A SERVICE
THEIR WE ON A NO. FACTORS IN
THE EXTENT OF BOB IN THIS CASE
IN THIS CASE THAT THE POTS CASE
IN THE THEM. EXCEPT GRAPHIC
AREA. ALL OF THE- CURRENT
SUPPLIES ARE. THERE ARE. AND
HOW MANY DAYS ARE IN THE LIFE
SPECTRA THAT'S CORD BY OUR
EMERGENCY MEDICAL OF THE AND I
HOW CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
PUBLIC AND I THINK IT IF I'M
MISTAKE THE- RECEIVED. I THINK
ALL OF FLOW CHART OF HOW. ON
GET SORT OF. IN LIEU SYSTEM AND
WELL I THINK THEY CAN WE A YEAH
A EXPRESSION IN THE A ARE THAT
THE ALL THE COUNTY AND IN THE
STATE I BEEN ABLE TO RECEIVE IN
AND NINETY FIVE MAY CONSERVE
MASK I TRY ON SO LEVEL ONCE. I
AM REVIEW. SURE THIS. AND THE
PROCESS UP PART OF THE VALUE IS
WHETHER OR NOT TOO MUCH IS
GOING TO Y. YOUR STAY THAT THE
JURISDICTION BE A RE MORE THEN
THE AND YOU KNOW A FINE OF
GORDON BACK AND FORTH. OF THE
BETWEEN THE LEDGES TEAM MERGING
BACK SERVICESAUTHORITY OF THE
AS WE THING OR THE REQUESTING
THE OUT AS REQUIRES CONTINUAL A
WAIT AS A I'M STANCES
CONTINUALLY AND THE IS TO AS
MUCH AS WE CAN THE.
COLLABORATIVELY WITH OUR
FEDERAL PARTNERS AS WELL AS OUR
HEALTHCARE SYSTEM TO ENSURE
THAT THE RIGHT RESOURCES GET TO
THE RIGHT PLACE- IN THIS TIME
THE FAST AS POSSIBLE. I THANK
YOU. JUST A JUMP IN QUICKLY TO
THE- TO THE TO THE B. Y. DE
CONTRACT- HOW IS THIS HOW IS
THIS DEAL DEVELOPED DID. THEY
CALIFORNIA APPROACH BIãU IDEA
TO BE BE WHY THE APPROACH.
CALIFORNIA CALIFORNIA APPROACH
YOU ID AND IN TERMS OF
NEGOTIATING THIS CONTRACT WHO
WHO NEGOTIATED TE CONTRACT. OR
IS NEGOTIATING CONTRACT NOW.
WELL THE CONTRACT WAS GOOD THE
GOOD NEGOTIATED BY- OUR LEGAL
TEAMS AND- AND OF THE- GENERAL
SERVICES- WILL- PROCUREMENT
UNIT. OKAY OKAY AND I
UNDERSTAND THAT THEY ARE THE IN
THE PREVIOUS HEARINGS IT.
THERE'S HESITATION TO RELEASE-
SPECIFICS TO THE AGREEMENT. CAN
YOU COULD TELL ME WHAT OF WHAT
RISK THERE IS IN RELEASING THE
SPECIFICS. WELL AS I MENTIONED-
JUST A MINUTE AGO. THERE'S BEEN
A WORLDWIDE SHORTAGE FOR THIS
BB AS A RESULT OF THE PANDEMIC-
AND THIS IS BEEN WE'VE BEEN
CHALLENGING AND COMPLEX FOR UP
WHERE- GOVERNMENT- AND
HEALTHCARE SYSTEMS AROUND THE
WORLD ARE COMPETING. FOR THE
SAME COMMODITY ALL WE ARE IN
THINGS LIKE FRAUD OF PROMISES
AB SUBSTITUTE ITEMS THE EFFORTS
THAT WE PUT IN IN AND HE IS
ONE. ONE FIVE CHANNEL AT THE
LOGISTICS BRITAIN THE
PROCUREMENT TEAMS HAVE BEEN
WORKING LITERALLY AROUND THE
CLOCK ON. FIRST MATERIALS TV
FROM AROUND THE WORLD RELEASING
THE CALL AT THIS WE BELIEVE
JEOPARDY THE DELIVER OF THE
VERY SUPPLIES AND THAT WE
ACTUALLY NEED- NOW AND I WILL
CLOSE TO I THINK STARTING TO
GET THAT FLOW OF CAMANCHE BIEN
ALL BY. AS A QUORUM WHAT. THAT
NO LONGER JEFF ACTUALLY TO BE.
WE'VE ALSO SEEN I MEAN IT'S
JUST A LOT OF CHIU ALONG THE
WAY GIVEN THE- THE WORLDWIDE
COMPETITION- THERE'S ALSO A
OPPOSITION AMONGST. AND THERE'S
BEEN COMPETITION. EVER MET THE
STATE'S NBA TO GET THIS IS
THESE COMMODITIES- PREVIOUS
QUESTIONS ALONE- TALKING ABOUT
THE NEEDS OF EACH THESE THESE
COMMODITIES AND THE IMPORTANCE
OF GETTING THESE COMMODITIES WE
HAVE BEEN LIVING. AND DEALING
WITH IT SINCE THE DAY ONE AND-
BUT YOU KNOW PART OF THIS IS
THAT WE BELIEVE THAT UP WE ARE.
SECURED OUT NUMBER EIGHTY TWO.
A VERY VALUED COMMODITIES.
EVERY NOT WANT TO JEOPARDIZE
THAT AND THAT THE COME ON. ARE
WRITING THROUGH ALL OF THE
HURDLES AND CHALLENGES THAT ARE
LONG THAT JOURNEY WELL I WOULD
STRONGLY ENCOURAGE YOU AS AS
SOON AS POSSIBLE TO RELEASE
DETAILS EL OR AT LEAST AS AS
YOU REFERRED JUST UNDER PAN IN
A PREVIOUS HEARING AT LEAST A
LOT. JUST LATER TO SEE.
PACIFIC'S AT. TESTING IF I
COULD IF I COULD MAYBE MARK
YOUR CALORIE AS CAN JUMP JUMP
IN- WHAT IS THE TESTING.
PROCESS HOW DO COUNTIES
CURRENTLY A- DISTRIBUTOR HAPPY
THAT HAS A STATUS TO BE TESTING
KITS. IT SEEMS TO BE CONFUSION
ON THOUGH IT MADE CLEAR THAT.
YEAH ASSEMBLY MEMBER THIS IS
MARCO ME EACH WITH A CALIFORNIA
HEALTH AD HUMAN SERVICES
AGENCIES FIRST ME START BY KIND
OF EXPLAINING HOW. TESTING
WORKS AND I THINK THAT WILL
GIVE YOU A LITTLE BIT OF
CONTEXT WHEN- AND WHEN
SOMETHING- WENT LIKE THIS
COMES. FROM OUR FRIENDS. HE'S
FIRST AT BACK A GREAT ANALOGY
WOULD BE WHEN WE HAD THE SEEKER
VIRUS- THE CDC START THEY
DEVELOPED A TEST THEY STARTED
TESTING THEN THEY MOVED BACK TO
THE PUBLIC. OKAY OF SO GO FROM
CDC TO STATE PUBLIC HEALTH
LABORATORY THEN WE GO TO COUNTY
PUBLIC HEALTH LABORATORIES AND
THEN THEY BECOME AVAILABLE- IN
THE COMMERCIAL MARKET.
CELEBRITIES LIKE. STING AND LAB
CORE WHAT WE HAVE. OVER THE
COURSE OF THE LAST COUPLE WEEKS
WE AT. LEVEL MOVE. BECOME THIS.
ACTUALLY HAPPENS WITHIN
HOSPITALS WITHIN COMMUNITIES
ARE WITHIN- THESE COMMERCIAL
LABORATORIES- AT THE STATE
LEVEL WITH REGARDS TO THE
ABBOTT- CHICKENS WERE PROVIDED
TO US WE'RE LOOKING AT IS WHERE
THERE WAS ON ME. WE WERE THANK
YOU IT WAS REALLY MATCH THAT
AND NEEDS THE TEST ACETATE WE
HAVE A TESTING FOR TASK FORCE
THAT THE GOVERNOR HAS A PLACE
TO. PART LOOKING AT TIRES
CONTINUE OF TESTING KEEP BUT
TESTING OUT. LITTLE OR ADD A-
AT A COMMERCIAL LAB IS
DIFFERENT THAN TESTING A IN IN
A CLINIC FOR EXAMPLE BECAUSE
THAT ABBOTT MACHINE HE IS WHAT
WE CALL A RAPID RESPONSE.
TESTING WHERE YOU HAVE JUST
LIKE IN BLINDS AT TO TAKE THE
TEST AND GET A RESULT WITHIN
MINUTES. THAT IS ABOUT. THE
TOOLS WITHIN OUR TOOL BOX BUT
THERE'S MULTIPLE TOOLS SO WE
HAVE A PCR TEST THAT'S BEING
USED- MORE BROADLY AS A ROBERT
G. TESTS THAT WERE LOOKING AT
OUT. COMMERCIAL LABORATORY THE
LABORATORY ARE GETTING
SUFFICIENT SUPPLIES FROM THE
REST OF THE SUPPLY CHAIN WHERE
THE STATEIS NOT NECESSARILY
GETTING ENGAGED TO THE EXTENT
WE ARE WRITING RESOURCES FROM
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT WORKING
FIRST WITH LAB IS WELL AS
MARSHALL RECENT THE
LABORATORIES. THE I MET HE DOES
RIGHT NOW AT THE ON ME AREAS
ONE IS WHY. AND TWO IS THE ME
SO VIRAL IS WHAT IS USED ONCE
YOU TAKE THE SPECIMEN FROM THIS
WHAT YOU PUT THE SPECIMEN IN
THE VIRAL MEDIA WE ARE TRYING
TO OBVIOUSLY USE THAT ARE. TO
GET A TIONAL SOURCES WEST AND
BARBARA. BUT BECAUSE THERE'S
SUCH AS SECOND STRAY ON THE
SUPPLY CHAIN WE'RE ALSO LOOKING
AT INNOVATIVE WAYS WE CAN.
APPLY CHECKS OF SAMPLE WE ARE
WORKING WITH VARIOUS PARTNERS
TO LOOK AT WHAT YOU'RE NOT WE
CAN THREE D. PRINT- STOPS OR
WHETHER HE'S OTHER SWAPS WITH
PERMISSION FROM THE DAY. ISSUE
WE'VE GOT A GROUP. CITY IT OUR
OWN BY THE MEDIA. NOT NOT AS
WELL SO WHAT WE'RE TRYING TO DO
IS ARGUE THE SUPPLY CHAIN AND
NOT. ON THE BROADER SUPPLY
CHAINS CAN MITIGATE THE PROBLEM
TESTING. I'VE BEEN GOING. I
THANK YOU VERY MUCH JUST A JUMP
QUICKLY TO SOME OTHER TOPICS ON
ON HOMELESSNESS AT A TO PICK
BACK UP AS A MEMBER COOPER WAS
TALKING ABOUT I LIKE TO FINANCE.
IS IT LIKELY THAT THE OPERATION
OF HOMELESS SHELTERS WILL BE
DIFFERENT FOR THE FOR SIEBEL
FUTURE- YOU'VE WE'VE SIR THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA HAS
OBVIOUSLY INCREASED COSTS. DUE
TO INCREASE AT TAKE SECURITY
WELL SIR. CASE MANAGEMENT AND
AN EDIT THIS IS TO BE PROVIDED.
ARE THERE ADDITIONAL
ALLOCATIONS THAT WILL COVER
THESE ADDITIONAL REQUIREMENTS
ON OUR SHELTERS- MOVING FORWARD
AND IF THAT THAT BE DONE WITH
THE WITH THAT. BEING DO WE KNOW
WALKER. ASSEMBLY MEMBER ON THE
HOMELESSNESS- I THINK SO RIGHT
NOW THE HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS.
IN ADDITIONAL FUNDING WAS
DIRECTLY ADDRESS SORT TERM
NEEDS WHEN IT COMES TO THE
TYPES OF. TERM PROGRAMMING-
THAT YOU'RE DISCUSSING IN THIS
TIME THAT WE WILL ADDRESS MORE
FULLY IN THE NAY REVISION AND
ALL WE GO SHE IS WHAT THIS
LETTER IT'S REALLY THE THIS IS
IT I ARE FOR THE INPATIENT
ALREADY. FOR PRICE WHEN THEY
GOT DIVIDED THE- DATE AT THE
STATE ADDRESS. YOU RIGHT THIS
IS SINCE. ARE THEY NEED TO HOW
THE SPREAD OF CLOTHING BUT WE
ALSO ARE A LOYAL OF THE FISCAL
CONSTRAINTS THAT WILL BE
OPERATE UNDER I GIVE AND THAT
JACK TO DROPPING REVENUES
INCREASED. TAX ONCE. AFTER THAT
CHRIST. SO WE PUSHED ALL THE WE
CAN WITH THE CONTEXT OF THE
BUDGET AND SO WE'LL HAVE MORE
TO SAY ON THAT AND COUPLE. THE
YOU IF A FEW MORE QUESTIONS- IN
TERMS. UP INTO THE- INTO THE
PUBLIC SAFETY TO DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE. CERTAINLY THERE'S A
FIVE TO COST- TO OUR- CITIES
COUNTIES. ONCE THING FOR AM.
YOU KNOW SIR. IMPACT OF THIS AS
A PANDEMIC. IS THIS THE
ADMINISTRATION PLANNED TO LOCAL.
IT'S CAN YOU SPECIFICALLY. MAY
I AND THE COMMITTEE IF THEY
MISS WAS PART OF THIS IS ZERO
BAIL PROPOSAL- AND WHAT WENT
INTO IT. ON THAT QUESTION I
WILL TURN IT OVER TO MY
COLLEAGUE AB JARVIS OR ONE OF
THE COLLEGE. HI THIS IS AMY
JARVIS BUT THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE. I'M SO WE HAVE BEEN
WORKING THE COUNTY IS AND I
THINK ONE OF OUR SECTION THIRTY
SIX. STATE ROUTE I. SUPPORT OUR
LOCAL PUBLIC. AND WHILE OUR I'M
EARLY RELEASE PLAN OUR SIXTY
DAY EARLY RELEASE AS WELL AT
OUR PLAN TO STOP INTAKE. FROM
THE COUNTY JAILS SO WE HAVE
RECALL. FOR THOSE I AM ZERO
BELL HI. I THINK THAT WAS THAT
SOMETHING THAT THE CHIEF
JUSTICE WORK ON AS WE ALL KNOW
WAS THAT HER EXACT OR HER I. OR
WE ARE WORKING CLOSELY WITH AND
ON IN THE ISSUES IN THE
CERTAINLY AWARE OF SOME OF THE
CASH FLOW ISSUE THERE HAVE BEEN
AS TOLD THE- AND THAT WOULD
INCLUDE. INCLUDED IN THE- HOW
I'M IN. A THE- SALES. PAYMENTS
I'M UP TO FIFTY THOUSAND
DOLLARS FOR SMALL BUSINESSES.
SO THERE ARE SEVERAL THINGS IN
PLAY THAT ARAFAT LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS IN CERTAINLY PER.
THEM HELP ME WORK THROUGH IS
GOING TO BE A- CONTEMPLATE FOR
US BUT WE ARE STILL WORKING
THROUGH THOSE EIGHT ISSUES AND
I. AM AS- SO WE EXPECT. THE
BUDGET. MINISTRATION TO LOOK
VERY PAT BUT WHAT IS YOU HAD
CERTAIN CRIMES- LIKE CHILD
ABUSE OR L. S. OR RESISTING
ARREST MADE NOT NOW CALL FIVE
ZERO AND THAT HAS PUT STRESS
AND CONCERN. AMONG SO SHARES
PLACE TO DISTRICT. I'M I WOULD
WAS. I WAS ON A THEIR CONCERNS
AS WELL ESPECIALLY AS WE ARE
MOVING FORWARD- IN TERMS OF TO
THE TO THE ALLEY I WOULD PARA
FINANCE. I GET TO THE ONE CAN
ANSWER THIS QUESTION BUT
STATING. HAVE BEEN EXPOSED.
WHATEVER THAT'S HAPPENED EDT
WEBSITE HAS BEEN OVERWHELMED-
DUE TO DEMAND- WE CERTAINLY
HAVE SEEN SOME HIGH PROFILE-
THE I. T. CHALLENGES- HIGH LED
TO. HER WITH THIS IT THE MAIL
AND THEY'LL BE SIR. ON TO. OUR
ONLINE SERVICES CAN IT CAN SHED
SOME LIGHT ON. WITHOUT THE
FAILURES THAT OCCURRED IN THE
PAST. MAYBE I'LL DO I GOT TO
THE LA- FIRST AND THEN- MAYBE
TEN TO THE POWER FINANCE. WE
OKAY FONG I'D LIKE TO ASK IF MY
COLLEAGUE CAROLINE CHIU COULD
WEIGH IN ON THIS PARTICULAR
QUESTION. HELLO GOOD MORNING
KAREN TO FROM THE LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S OFFICE. IN MONSTER
YOUR SPECIFIC QUESTION I CAN
GIVE AND COULD DISCUSS
POTENTIALLY WHAT THEY'RE
THINKING FOR THE MAY REVISION
OF THE TWO YOU DO IT. IS IN THE
CAR TRY TO STAND UPMORE ROBUST
OUR SYSTEM IN ORDER TO ANY ON A-
SO IT ONE OF THE- THANK YOU IT
IS. I THERE WAS A LETTER BROUGH
RECENTLY TRY TO WOULD THIS AND
INDUSTRY BUT THEY COULD I
ANSWER SORT OF WHY FUTURE OF
THE STATE UP THIS THIS EFFORT
IS A AS WELL AS HELP WE MY BE
ABLE TO SEE ANY RESULTS. MAYBE
I. CAN YOU SHOULD ENTER. BUT
THIS IS FOR THE I. T. SPENCER
NEED TO BE DONE. YES I CAN SAY
FOR THAT THAT IT COMES TO THE
OVERALL YOU ISIS THAT A FEDERAL
IS ALL FROM. SOME ASSIST OR
WHAT ADD TO GET MY AS SOON AS-
OBVIOUSLY WORKING VERY QUICKLY
MAKES THAT PEOPLE GET RESOURCES
THAT THEY GET A CLOSE AS
POSSIBLE. WHEN IT WERE RESOURCE
NOW BEYOND WHAT WE SEE IN THE
ENVELOPE JEFF FROM THEIR PLACE
I THINK YOU. I KNOW NAMES. OUT
WE IN TERMS OF OUR HISTORY THE
MORE PAST THING WE- A TOP PRIDE
GIVEN THE NUMBER OF CLAIMS WE
ARE SO AND A SHORT OF TIME.
OKAY IN MY LAST QUITE TO THE
FORMER BY. CERTAINLY THE BUDGET
I AT THIS AT ALL THESE ARE
DEPENDENT ON THE FUNDAMENTAL OF.
ECONOMIC HE'S CALIFORNIA AS SIR
CAN CULTURE AND A ACTION IS IT
IN THE IMPORT A IS THERE A THIS
WITHIN THE MINISTRY OF THE
PROVIDER SOME ADDITIONAL SAYS
THOSE IN I KNOW THIS A CLEAR AS
A MEMBER. THE CONCERT THE FOOD.
WITH MINISTRY ENTERTAIN USING
SOME OF THE S. DOLLARS TO YOU
ASSIST PURCHASING AG PRODUCTS
AND FOR FOOD BANG TO ENSURE
THAT THE NEEDY GET YOU KNOW
MEALS. FOR EXAMPLE. THREE IS
THE I THINK US OF ALL WITH
REGARD TO FOOD BANKS IN COURTS
ENOUGH DESIGN TO BE DIFFERENT
PARTS OF THE STATE I'VE BEEN
YOU HAVE STATE MY ALLOCATE AND
BILL ON OF THE ITEMS THAT WERE
IN FEDERAL. MEMBERS FROM ACROSS
THE STATE FROM INCLUDING A
PRIVATE NONPROFIT SECTORS SO
THERE TO I BELIEVE IN THE NECK
SIXTY DAYS DEVELOPS INITIAL
RIGHT SHIN ON WHAT THE STATE DO.
PART SURE AND ASSISTANCE IS
GETTING TO. SPECIFICALLY IN
THIS A THAT OR EIGHT I THINK
THIS IS A AREA AT THE- SHE
PROGRAM WHICH YOU AS WE RUN OUT
OF FUNDS OF THE FEDERAL LEVEL
WE'RE HOPEFUL THAT. COMES AN
AGREEMENT INCLUDES. TO CONNECT
BUSINESSES INCLUDING SMALL
BUSINESSES TO FEDERAL- WORK- WE
ARE ALSO PROVIDING OUR OWN
SUPPORT GROUP EXISTING AT
RESOURCE INCLUDING AT THE
GOVERNOR'S. ECONOMIC AND THEN
OCCASIONALLY AT. SB EIGHTY
NINE- THERE WAS- WITHIN ONE OF
OUR ALLOCATIONS FIFTY NINE
DOLLARS THANK WHICH IS A
CALIFORNIA'S INFRASTRUCTURE I
WENT BACK AND GOT. OUT CERTAIN
ASK YOUR IS IT. OUT OF THE
FEDERAL PACKAGES AND I HAVE A
COLLEAGUE WHO CAN SPEAK TO THAT
PROGRAM IF YOU LIKE IT- DETAIL
I DO THINK THAT ONE THING THAT
WE CAN IT ONE WAY IS NOT I KNOW.
THIS YEAH. NOW LESS THAN ONE.
WHAT SAN. WHAT SO THESE
UPGRADES THAT FOREST EXISTING
AT THE GOVERNOR'S AND IS NECK
AND DEVELOPMENT BROCK LESNAR
FEDERAL OR DOES NOT TO GET
MONEY AND TO THE HISTORIES THAT
ARE IN. OUR PASSED THE IS
LIMITED WITH THE SMELL FEDERAL.
WE'RE GOING TO CONTINUE TO WORK
DO WHAT WE CAN AND I YOU'LL SEE
BOTH WITH THE NEIGHBOR PROPOSAL%
I WELL AS THIS TO. WHICH ALL MY
PARTY. CALIFORNIA GOT. BRING ON
NEXT WE'RE HOPING WE GET SOME.
IS NOT A SUPPORT. I SAW
APPRECIATE AND ONE I WILL I
WENT THE CHAIR FOR HIS SINS
PATIENTS FOR THE FOR BUT I DO A
IT THE BY TO AID TO THEM
SITUATION THE PART OF AYE. THAT
WHILE. FROM THE FOR A- ARE TO.
OUR INITIALLY PARTNERS TO
MAINTAIN WHAT THEY HAVE THE
ADMINISTRATION IS STILL
PRODUCING AND TAKING ACTIONS
THERE ARE POTENTIALLY MAKING.
DIFFICULT TO STAY IN BUSINESS
IN CALIFORNIA A SPECIFICALLY
POINT OUT TO YOU THE POTENTIAL
LITIGATION AND FROM THE WATER
TO LIVE- THE FACT THAT- AT THE
END AND THE ENDED ON. AND THAT
THE THAT WAS BACK EAST A BY BY
THE NEWS MINISTRATION. IN THE
DID. HUNDRED THOUSAND ACRE FEET
WATER TO VALLEY OURS AT THAT WE
NEEDED DURING- POSTED GEN AND
OF COURSE THE REGULATORY YOU
CAN. I WOULD DO IT. HE BRUSHED
AS ASKING FAMILY CALIFORNIANS
IS. DURING THIS BAND TO BE THEY
NEED THEIR LIFE ON IN EIGHT IN
THEIR HOMES HAS EITHER FAMILIES
AND SO WE NEED IT ENSURE THAT
THERE'S STABILITY. TO AN- I IN
OUR STATE THANKS VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR AND- IF I MAY I THINK
AFTER- COVERT NINETEEN MANY OF
US. OF A PUBLIC HEALTH MASTERS
WE HAVE SPENT A LOT OF TIME
THINKING AND READING AND
PREPARING THIS. AND THE STUDY
THE PANDEMIC I THINK CALIFORNIA
THE END OF. OUR ADMINISTRATION
AND HIS EXECUTIVE TEAM THAT HAS
PROVIDED THE REAL TIME UPDATES
AND THE- ALICE'S BASED ON
SCIENCE AND I AM PROUD TO BE
ABLE TO ASK IF YOU QUESTIONS.
HELP OUR STATE FOR WORK WANT TO
KEEP US FROM IF I CAN ON WHAT I
JUST HEARD BECAUSE I DO SEE
THAT IT IS A FOR GOVERNMENT
RIGHT NOW BE PROVIDED. TO THOSE
WHO NEED AN SO IN A PREVIOUS
LIFETIME. SAY I WAS A FIRST
RESPONSE AND I THINK WE OF MY
QUESTION TODAY ARE REGARD WHAT
IS A RISK. ARE WE INSURANCE.
SACRAMENTO OF THIS CONTRA. OUR
IS GOING TO THE WHO ARE HELPING
OUR PHONE COMMUNITY ACCESS
CRITICAL HIS RIGHT NOW. WE'LL
BE SPEAKING TO FIVE AREAS THAT
I THINK ARE IMPORTANT AND I'M
HAPPY WORK FINANCE OR- THE SIGN
THE QUESTION PLEASE FIT BUT
WANT TO US TO TALK ABOUT OUR
NURSING FOR. BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
YES. SEAFOOD THE EMERGENCY AID
FOR THE DOCK AS WELL AND
FINALLY OUR H. US. AND ADULT
THE CHART PROTECTIVE SERVE. IF
I CAN I JUST LIKE TO WITH
BECAUSE- AS I MENTIONED IN MY
OPENING COMMENTS IT'S THE AREA
I THINK WE NEED TO FOCUS ON.
AND MIKE ARE WHAT ARE WHAT TO
DO. AS AN ADMINISTRATION TO
ENSURE THAT WE HAVE ADEQUATE
STAFF AVAILABLE TO WORSE. WHAT
PEIRCE AGES OF THIS NEXT THAT
WE- IS THERE. THAT IS NEEDED.
OVERALL HOW EFFECTIVE ARE WE
DOING AT ISOLATING COVERT
NINETEEN POSITIVE CASES WITHIN
SNAPS. HOW EFFECTIVE ARE THE
**** SAID PROTECTING THEIR
STAFFS. WHAT IS THE
ADMINISTRATION DOING TO MAKE
SURE THAT WE GET MORE P. EASE
TO OURS. FINALLY FOR JUST THIS
OF KHAN FOR **** THE GOVERNOR
PER A HEALTH CARE WORK FORCE
AND HAVING BEEN ONE OF THE P.
ALONG WITH DOCTOR SO UP FOR IT.
I THIS IS IT IT THOUSANDS AVAIL
HEALTH WORKERS AND MICHAEL FOR
THE ADMINISTRATION. IS ARE THEY
ARE EFFORTS TO CAN THESE OF
WORKERS NURSING FOR THAT ARE IN
NEED OF HALF. OVERALL THOUGH I
WILL SAY PERTAINS TO **** FIVE
WE HAD A WORK FORCE. MORTGAGE
AND ISSUES BEFORE THIS CRISIS
OCCURRED AND AS WE GO THROUGH
WORK FORCE. ISSUES AND- CHILD
CARE IT IS I THINK WE HAVE TO
FIGURE OUT HOW TO MAKE SURE TO
INCENTIVIZE THIS WORK FOR. AND
WOULD WANT TO WORK WITH AND
TALK WITH THE ADMINISTRATION
ABOUT WHETHER OR NOT- AND HOW
THIS INCENTIVE COULD LOOK TO
MAKE SURE THAT WE HAD THE WORK
NEEDED FOR TOMORROW. SO
REGARDING SNAPS. THANK YOU
ASSEMBLYMEMBER RANDALL I KNOW
YOU COVERED A LOT OF GROUND AT
FIRST ON THE QUESTION AND I
THINK I WILL IT OVER FIRST TO
ACT WORSE FOR OUR AGE YOU AND
THEN MARK MAGICJACK H. H.
OCCASIONS MAY HAVE ADDITIONAL
THIS YEAR'S WELL BUT FOR
HAPPENED. YOU YES SO THERE'S
TWO THINGS TOUCH ON BEFORE HIM
IT OVER TO THE AGENTS SO. THE
FIRST THING IS THE FUNDING AND
SO BUT WE'VE BEEN WORKING
REALLY. WITH INTO. AND REALLY
INCREASE. AN INDIRECT THE IN
TWO APPLY FOR THE FOR THAT'S OF.
THIS MADE TO TRY TO. THOSE INTO
IN WE KNOW THAT SKILL NURSING
IF TAKE. HAS SO SOME REALLY YOU
GALA WITH HER EX. JUST AT AND.
JUST ACCORDING. THIS STILL IS.
OPTIONS GOING FORWARD AS WELL-
AND THE SECOND THING THAT I'LL
TOUCH ON WITH RESPECT TO
CONNECTING WORKERS THE
ADMINISTRATION- IS ENGAGE IN A
HEALTH CORD THAT IS TRYING TO
CONNECT WORKERS TO WHERE THEY
ARE NEEDED. AND NO UTILIZED
PEOPLE WHERE THEY'VE GOT YOU
KNOW THEY'RE KIND OF
PROFESSIONAL SKILLS THAT THEY
CAN BROUGHT TO BEAR THIS AND I
KNOW THAT THERE'S A NUMBER OF
OTHER THINGS THAT- THE AGENCY
WILL BE ABLE TO ADD. ONS ALL
HIT NUMBER MARK OR. I GOT READY
THIS IS A FROM ME WITH THE
HELPING YOU SERVICES AGE. FOR
AT REALLY THANK YOU THAT. BE
THE INDIVIDUALS IN THE GOVERNOR
THINK. ARE INDIVIDUALS WHO ARE
MOST VULNERABLE- AND SO THERE-
WE'VE TAKEN. CON ACTIONS- OVER
THE LAST COUPLE OF WEEKS. ADD
TO ENSURE THAT WE ARE
SUPPORTING US FACILITIES SO LET
ME START BY. OUTLINING FOR YOU
AS- THINGS THAT WE- DON DATE.
FARM WE CALLING EVERY SINGLE
NURSING TO. EVER DAY AND WE ASK
THEM IS. QUESTIONS AND- IF
THERE HAVE STAFFING SHORTAGE IS
WHETHER OR NOT THEY HAVE SINCE.
HE OR WHETHER THEY HAVE ANY ON
ME. AND SO. TAKING DAILY. WITH
EACH ONE OF THOSE. WHAT WE ARE
HAVE PROVIDE. ALL TECHNICAL.
WITH AND- DISEASE POSITIONS.
WHAT. EACH OF THE SKILLED
NURSING FOR. AND AFTER. SO
THERE'S PLEASE THAT WE ARE
PRACTICAL PROVIDE TECH
ASSISTANCE ON AROUND DO YOU I
HAVE IN. FROM HAVING AN OUT
BREAK WITH ANY PART FOR. AT
PART OF THAT AFTER WE AGREE SIX
HUNDRED. FROM THE OF THAT THE
APART OF PUBLIC HEALTH TO HELP
WITH THAT IN ORDER TO PRESS TO
BE ABLE TO REACH THOSE GOVERNOR
THIS AS HAVE AYE AYE HAVE STAFF
PROVIDE THAT TO SYSTEMS AB RICK
TO PP WITH PP TRIP TO. HIS FACE
THESE PLANTS ARE OF OUR DAILY
ALL A FACILITY DID IS NOT HAVE
HE. FIFTEEN ABBOTT MACHINES
WHICH DO POINT OF CARE WE
DISTRIBUTED AT THOSE TO HOT
AREAS OR HOT COUNTIES WITH
REGARDS TO SKILLED NURSING
FACILITIES AND WE'RE LEVERAGING
THOSE TO TEST INDIVIDUALS
WITHIN THOSE FACILITIES SO THAT
WE HAVE THE ADEQUATE TESTING
CAPACITY WITHIN EACH ONE OF US
ALSO KNOW THAT THE- IT WAS SO.
CAN NEED PLEASE. OUR DO IN THIS
AMOUNT WORK EACH AND EVERY DAY
AND THERE ARE TRUE HEROES IN
MANY SENSE AND SO WE PARTNERED
UP WITH FACEBOOK AT THE OFFICE
OF STATEWIDE HEALTH PLANNING
DEVELOPMENT AND- WE ARE
PROVIDING FIVE HUNDRED DOLLARS
STATE INSTITUTE WAS GOVERNOR
ADD TO SEE. AN LPN ANY SPECIFIC
I EIGHT WE RECEIVED OVER A
QUARTER US AND I. THAT WE HOPE
TO MEET WITH THE TWENTY MILLION
DOLLAR DONATION THAT WE
RECEIVED FROM WORK OKAY THERE
IS. MORE WORK TO DO. ON THE
SKILLED NURSING. BUT KNOW THAT
WE HAVE ARE STEPS THE LAST
COUPLE WE AND DAYS TO ENSURE
THAT WE ARE PROVIDING- AS MUCH
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE AND REAL
ASSISTANCE TO THESE FACILITIES.
THANK YOU AND IF I MAY I JUST
WANTED TO FOLLOW UP MARCO I
THINK THAT IS TREMENDOUS
REGARDING THE STIPEND THAT YOU
MENTIONED IN THE DONATION FROM
FULL. WHAT MAKES THE ECHO THE
COMMENTS OF THOSE WHO ARE ON
THE FRONT LINES RIGHT NOW THAT
SEEM TO. LIKE THEY- APPRECIATE
THE PRAISE THAT THEY RECEIVE
BUT REALLY NEED HELP DURING
THIS CRISIS AND OFTEN TIMES
THAT IN TERMS OF. BOTH BETTER
SUPPORT- FINANCIALLY AS WELL AS
MORE BODIES SO THE STIPEND IS A
WONDERFUL WOULD WANTS TO JUST
CONTINUE TO WORK AND TALK WITH
THE ADMINISTRATOR IN REGARDING
OFF LEASE FOR HAZARD PAY. IT'S
HARD WHEN YOU'RE GETTING PAID
MINIMUM WAGE AND BEING ASKED TO
DO THE WORK THAT IS REQUIRED AT
A SKILLED NURSING FACILITY NOT.
THE END. IS A NOTHER MINIMUM
WAGE JOB AND SO I BELIEVE WE
CAN DO SOMETHING AS A STATE TO
INCENTIVIZE. WHAT IS NOT
MINIMUM WAGE EMPLOYMENT BUT
TRULY A VITAL AND QUIRK SERVICE.
WITH THAT WILL MOVE ASKING RE
BEHAVE HEALTH I WANTEDTO MAKE
SURE THAT WE WERE. DOING
EVERYTHING THAT WE COULD AS AN
ADMINISTRATION TO AND HER
ACCESS TO BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
SERVICES DURING THIS PANDEMIC
WANTED TO ASK ARE WE LOOKING
TOWARDS EXPANSION TO.
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH TELEHEALTH.
HOW CAN WE SUPPORT WHAT IS AN
ALREADY. FRAGILE WORK FORCE
THAT IS REALLY SET IN THAT IS
TEMPORARILY AND SUDDENLY
RECEIVING DROP WITHIN SERVICES
AND FINALLY IF I CAN I DID WANT
TO TALK ABOUT BECAUSE I DO
THINK THOSE WHO ARE HELPING
WITHIN OUR BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
SERVICES AREA. ALSO FIRST
RESPONDERS IN THIS CRISIS WE
ENSURING THAT THEY ARE
RECEIVING ADEQUATE KEY PIECE OF
THIS AS THEY- IN FACT CONTACT
IN WITH MEN. HOMELESS
INDIVIDUALS. THIS ALSO IN FOR
THE NEXT SET OF HEALTH RELATED
QUESTIONS ONLINE ADAM DORSEY
FROM OUR TEACHER THE LATE. HI
THIS IS THAT ADAM DORSEY FROM
THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE SO.
YES WE ARE PURSUING IT TELEWORK
OPTIONS AND SO WE DO HAVE A
WAIVER- WITH THE- THROUGH OUR
M. I'M- ALL WE ARE HEARING WHAT
YOU WERE HEARING FROM THE
PROVIDER INUNDATED BUT THERE
WAS A SUBSTANTIAL DROP IN IN
HEALTH TREATMENT THAT WAS
HAPPENING- FOR THOSE PRACTICES
I. AND WE THINK IT IS IMPORTANT
TO TRY TO SUPPORT UTILIZATION
OF THOSE SERVICES PARTICULARLY
DURING THIS TIME- YOU KNOW IT
ALSO JUST SORT OF REFERENCES IS
YOU KNOW SOME OF THE HOUSING
SUPPORTS THEM- THAT WERE ALSO.
DOING THAT. WE THINK WILL BE
SUPPORTIVE OF THE OF THE
INDIVIDUALS WHO- MAY BE
EXPERIENCING BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
CHALLENGES WELL AS- YOU KNOW
HOUSING INSTABILITY- AND SO
YEAH I WAS SOME OF THESE THINGS
ARE ARE ACTUALLY BEING SHOOT AT
THE MOMENT. AND WE WILL. ASK
YOU FOR TO YOU MARKHAM EACH AT
THE HEALTH AND HUMAN SERVICES
AGENCY SOME OF THE OTHER ISSUES
ALL. DOCTOR THANK YOU FOR THAT.
I THINK THAT THAT INDIVIDUALS-
MENTAL HEALTH AND BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH NEEDS ESPECIALLY AT THIS
TIME. IS UNBELIEVABLY IMPORTANT
I'M AND WE ARE DILIGENTLY
WORKING ON ENSURING THAT THESE
READ SAYS THEY'RE AVAILABLE TO
MEANS WE PARTNERED UP WITH
DOCTOR NEEDING BURKE HARRIS
WHO'S OUR FIRST SURGEON GENERAL
ALICE. TO REPEAT THE SOME.
JOINT AROUND AND MENTAL HEALTH
BE ABLE HEALTH TOOL KIT- AND SO
THAT IS AVAILABLE WE ARE ALSO
AT AND BEING UP OUR OUTLINES
FERRIES MENTAL HEALTH IN APRIL
HEALTH HOT LINES IN THOSE ARE
AVAILABLE. T. B. A. WE'VE GOT A
SEE THE RESPONSES FOR END OF
THERE ADD TO SUPPORT THEM THAT
OBVIOUSLY OR WORK THAT SHOULD
NOT ADD UP TO THE MEDICAID TO
SUPPORT. BETTER IS THERE'S SO
WE WILL LEAVE ONE OF THE THINGS
YOU'VE DONE ADMINISTRATIVE HE
IS YOU. OUR REGION TELL. SAME
LEVEL. AS IN PERSON VISIT WOULD
JUST ENCOURAGE THE MINISTER
CHEN TO CONTINUE THIS PRACTICE.
AND I GUESS I IN OF HAD BEEN
TAPED FOR TO LOOK TOWARDS THIS
TECHNOLOGY IS A RESOURCE. BUT I
WOULD TO TELL YOU. RIGHT WAS
YESTERDAY SOMETIMES I THINK WE
HAVE TO. BE HUMAN AND HAVE
STORIES AS WELL I WAS IN SOME
PLACE WHERE I'VE PRACTICED
MEDICINE FOR TEN YEARS AT A
FOOD DISTRIBUTION YESTERDAY
WITH THE- ROBBIE SEEK CHURCH
THAT WAS DISTRIBUTING SEVENTY
FIVE THOUSAND POUNDS WORTH OF.
GOODS TO A COMMUNITY THAT I
KNEW WELL AND THEY HAD HUNDREDS
IF NOT MORE THAN A THOUSAND
CARS LINED UP TO RECEIVE GOOD
SEE. IT IS A ROOM FOR ME AND A
GOOD PRACTICE FOR MANY OF US
WITHIN PUBLIC SERVICE TO
REMEMBER THE NEED OF COMMUNITY
RIGHT NOW. AND SO I WANT TO
TALK IF I COULD HAVE BROUGHT
THIS UP. FOR BUT TO MAKE SURE
THAT OUR FOOD YOUR SUPPORT. NOW
I UNDERSTAND THAT THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT IS HAVING. RELIEF
COMING IN JUNE OR JULY AND THAT
INITIAL APPROPRIATION FOR
EMERGENCY RELIEF ALLOWED US TO
GET SOME FOOD OUT THE DOOR NOW.
ARE WE AT FULL POWER THE FOR
OUR FOOD THANKS FOR THE NEXT
SEVERAL MONTHS AND HOW CAN WE
ENSURE SINCE WE KNOW THERE'S
GOING TO BE A GREAT NEED. THAT
THEY HAD. REAL FRIENDS NOW WE
NOR GET TWELVE GRID PEOPLE WHO
APPLY FOR CAL FRESH IN A MONTH
AND LAST MONTH IT WAS SHORTENED
BECAUSE OF THE STAY AT HOME
TIMELINE. WE HAD TWENTY SEVEN
HUNDRED PEOPLE WHO APPLIED FOR
CALIBRATION. SO I KNOW THAT.
FOR OUR BANK SOMEONE JUST ASKED
THE ADMINISTRATION TO MAKE SURE
THAT THEY'RE FULLY FUNDED AT
CAPACITY AT ABLE TO DISTRIBUTE
GOODS AT THIS TIME. HOPING THE
ADMINISTRATION CAN COMMENT ON
THAT QUESTION. YES I THINK I
WILL TURN IT OVER FIRST TO
MARCO YOU CAN TALK SPECIFICALLY
ABOUT THE V. G. ISSUE RECOMMEND
ANY OTHER CONCERNS ADDRESSED.
DOCTOR ARAMBULA THANK YOU AGAIN
AND I THINK. IN TERMS OF YOUR
FIRST AT PEACE AROUND FOOD
BANKS AS WE LOOTED TO EARLIER
THIS WAS AN INTENT MASTER. IN
AND MAKE SURE THEY DID NOT.
HAVE A BIG GAPS AS WE WAIT FOR
ADDITIONAL FEDERAL FUNDING ON
THE EBT OR ARE AT MY APOLOGIES
CALTRAIN SNAP SIDE CONFERENCE
SHE AS I THE CALIFORNIA IS NOW
GRANT. YOU HAVE ALREADY HE- IS.
WHAT MEANS TO ONE POINT THREE
MILLION HOUSE OUT WE ALSO HAVE
A PEN EACH WAIVER ASKED SUBMIT
IT TO THE PROGRAM IN THE U. S.
T. IN PARTICULAR AND WHAT I
WOULD DO IS IT WOULD ALLOW US.
OUR FOOD IS. WHAT GETTING
NORMAL THERE'S SO WHY HOPING TO
GET APPROVAL THAT AND ORDER
ADDITIONALLY WE WORK WITH THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT TO ALLOW OUR
CALVET EXTRA HANDS TO USE THEIR
EBT CARDS ON LINE AND WE DID
RECEIVE APPROVAL APPROVAL FOR
AND WE WILL BE DOING. SELECT
GROUP. HE SAID THAT. YES SIR WE
HAVE TO THE BUT THEY HAVE THE
ABILITY TO GET THERE ONLINE I'M
WE KNOW THEIR IS BIG YOU NEED
AFTER FOOD AND WE'RE WHAT.
AFTER THE VARIOUS FOOD. PROGRAM
WE- IN ADDITION TO OUR
PARTNERSHIPS I WITH THE FOOD
BANKS AS YOU PROBABLY KNOW BUT
BANKS ARE ALSO HAVING A HARD
TIME RECRUITING VOLUNTEERS. ARE
AT OUR- THE NATIONAL GUARD WAS
TREMENDOUS AND HELPING AND SO
IS THERE. ARE ACT CAL BALLING
TEARS WE ARE SERVICE FARMER BE
ADMINISTRATION TO REAL. I'VE
BEEN ABLE TO PROVIDE THE- PACK.
ACTION DELIVERING FOR FOLKS SO
I THIS IS A AS AT THAT DIRECTOR
GO DUE TO SAYS ONE ONE WHERE
TRYING TO DO ALL OF OUR RE.
ACROSS THE VARIOUS ENERGY
PROGRAMS MAY WE'RE MEETING THE
MANTIS CAN I AND WE READ WE'RE
WORKING ON LEVERAGES TOOLS AND-
THAT'S BETTER RESOURCE. FIRST
TO BE A- THE MOST. THERE'S A
QUOTE AND I DON'T WANT TO TRIED
FROM ARE CHAVEZ ABOUT AN IRONY
ABOUT. ANOTHER PEOPLE'S FOOD
TO. BUT I BRING IT UP BECAUSE
IT FEELS PARTICULARLY UNFAIR AS
ARE UNDOCUMENTED COMMUNITY WAS
EXCLUDED FROM THE FEDERAL
STIMULUS AND SO MY NEXT
QUESTIONS ARE REGARDING THE
LEADERSHIP THAT THE STATE IS
TAKING AND PROVIDE IT IN SEAVER.
TO OUR COMMUNITY. THIS IS A PPO.
CAN COLLECT INFORMATION AS THEY
DISTRIBUTE THE SEVENTY FIVE
MILLION DOLLARS IN INCOME
SUPPORT HAT CAN HELP US TO
INFORM WHAT ARE UNMET NEEDS
FUTURE EFFORTS THAT WE CAN
PROVIDE TO RELIEVE OR OUR
DISPATCH. THAT WOULD HELP US
IN- THE FUTURE DECISIONS. YEAH
COLLECTION. I CAN FOLLOW UP
OFFLINE IF THE QUESTION IS
STUMPING HOUSE WHAT I REALLY AM
TRYING TO. UNDER UP CAN YOU
HEAR ME SORRY WE HAVE TO
TECHNOLOGY ISSUES THERE WE GO
ALL RIGHT YES OKAY GREAT- SO AS
YOU FOR THAT QUESTION HE ARE
WORKING THAT LEAD TO THE
DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL SERVICES I
THERE IS TO MAKE GROUPS. WE
WERE ON A ON A- IS TO ASSESS
NEED A THE LOCAL LEVEL
CERTAINLY HAPPY FOLLOW WITH YOU
AND YOUR TEAM I WOULD NOTE THAT
THE GOVERNOR AND I DID STEP UP
IN THIS YEAH WHERE THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT I WAS NOT ABLE TO
PROVIDE RESOURCES TO OUR I'M DR
ED. RIGHT THINK BEFORE. WHERE
PROVIDE ASSIST TO THEM SO I
WOULD YOU KNOW THE
ADMINISTRATION IS ATTEMPTING TO
STEP IN AND MAKE SURE THAT WE
ARE REALLY CALIFORNIA FOR ALL
AS THE GOVERNOR OF THIS IS OUR
OUR OUR OUR VALUES AND WE'RE
STEPPING OUT THERE WE WILL BE
HAPPY FOLLOW UP WITH YOU ON THE
TEKHELET PONENS. SO I'M AS WE
MIGHT BE LOOKING- FOR. WHEN I
WOULD HAVE PAID THAT FOLLOW
LINE. AND THEN I WILL FINAL
QUESTION IF I MAY AND THAT'S-
IN TERMS OF SAFEGUARDING OUR IN
HOME SUPPORTIVE SERVICES AS
WELL AS OUR ADULT PROTECTIVE
SERVICES. I WANT TO SEE IF YOU
CAN SPEAK FIRST TO. HOW THE
CASELOADS HAVE CHANGED IN BOTH
THE HSS AS WELL AS APS. AND HAS
CHANGED DURING THE BASIS. AND
DO WE HAVE ANY PROBLEM THANKS
FOR THE NEXT SEVERAL MONTHS
LOOKING AT THESE TWO
POPULATIONS. AND WHAT IS THE
STATE OF. PROVISIONS FOR OUR
AYE HSS AND APS WORKERS AND
THEN FINALLY IS THERE A
DIFFERENCE AMONGST CERTAIN
COUNTIES AND WHY I'M TRYING TO
GO THERE IS TO ENSURE THAT ALL
OF OUR CONTRACT EMPLOYEES.
RECEIVED AN APPROPRIATE ACTIONS
AND THAT ALL COUNTIES ARE DOING
THE SAME. THIS IS MARK A MAJOR
AGAIN WITH THE CALIFORNIA
HEALTH AND HUMAN SERVICES
AGENCIES SO WE ARE UNBELIEVABLY
GRATEFUL TO AYE HSS PROVIDERS
WHO ARE STEPPING UP AT THIS
VERY DIFFICULT TIME- AS PART OF
THE INITIAL ROUND OF FUNDING
THERE IS A SECTION THIRTY SIX
LETTER WHERE WE REQUEST FIVE
MILLION DOLLARS. CHECK IN- FOR.
CONSUME WITH THE WRITERS AND
THAT WAS MATCHED BY WITH THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT WE ARE ALSO
SETTING ASIDE PP FOR PROVIDER
SPECIFICALLY- WHO ARE DEALING
WITH INDIVIDUALS WHO ARE
COVERED NINETEEN POSITIVE OR
SUSPECT SO WE ARE WORKING WITH
OUR COUNTY PARTNERS TO MAKE
SURE THAT WE ARE. REACHING OUT
THAT AFTER AT THAT PP OUR TO
THE AND SO THAT WORKING TEAM
DOESN'T THEM AND I KNOW THAT
OUR DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL
SERVICES WORKING CLOSELY WITH
OUR LABOR. I TO ENSURE THAT WE
ARE PROVIDING REAL TIME
INFORMATION I TO THE- WORKERS
WHO ARE DOING A TREMENDOUS
AMOUNT OF WORK. AND IT'S A
DIFFICULT TIME AND WE'RE
LOOKING TO STEP TO PROVIDE AS
MUCH SUPPORT AS WE POSSIBLY CAN.
WELL I. AM HAVE HEARD ANECDOTAL
THAT APS REPORTS ARE DOWN BUT
WOULD ACTUALLY WANTS TO MAKE
SURE THAT THIS VULNERABLE
POPULATION AT THE MOMENT- WAS
SUPPORTED AND- WE HAVE LOOKED
TOWARDS HELPING THIS POPULATION
WITH A HOME SAFE PROPOSAL AS
WELL AS A SUPPORTING COUNTY YES
WORKERS AND- THAT WOULD BE
HELPFUL. CRISIS FINE IF I AND
JUST TO HIS OWN. I THINK IT'S
IMPORTANT FOR US. BOTH BILL
I'VE SPOKEN. TO THE CHAIR AND
ABOUT KEEPING AN EYE TOWARDS
RECOVERING AND REBUILDING AND
WOULD BE FEARFUL THAT WE ARE
BEING UNFAIR TO OUR PROVIDER
COMMUNITY AT A MOMENT WHEN IT
IS THEIR PRACTICES ARE
DRASTICALLY CHANGED. THAT WE
ARE GOING TO HAVE TO FIGURE OUT
HOW TO PROVIDE SUPPORT WAY THAT
INSURANCE THEY CONTINUED TO BE
AROUND TO PROVIDE THAT SUPPORT.
SO WHILE WE LOOK AT THE FINANCE
THIS OF THIS I WOULD JUST
ENCOURAGE THE STATE TO GO IN
THAT DIRECTION AND I DON'T.
MIND BEING TRANSPARENT ABOUT
THAT I AUTHORED A BILL IF YOU
YEARS AGO CODIFYING INFORMATION
DONE THROUGH THE AFFORDABLE
CARE ACT BY PRESIDENT OBAMA.
REGARD MEDICAL LOSS RATIO AND
WHAT ENCOURAGE US AS A BODY TO
LOOK TOWARDS OUR HEALTH
INSURANCE PLANS THAT HAVE A
CERTAIN AMOUNT OF RESOURCES
THEY'RE SUPPOSED TO BE
PROVIDING TOWARDS MEDICAL CARE
I HAVE CONCERNS AS WE ARE
LOOKING TOWARDS OUR INSURANCE.
THAT THEY CAN BE A PART OF THE
SOLUTION TO ENSURE WE HAVE THE
RESOURCES NECESSARY TO ADDRESS
THIS CRISIS HEAD ON. WANT THE
ADMINISTRATION TO HOPEFULLY
ENGAGE IN THOSE CONVERSATIONS
AND WORK WITH US AS A
LEGISLATIVE BRANCH TO MAKE SURE
THAT OUR DOLLARS THAT WE PAID
FOR PREMIUMS ARE ACTUALLY GOING
TO PROVIDE CARE. SO RIGHT NOW
WOULD. TURN MY TIME BACK OVER
TO YOU MISTER CHAIR I WOULD
ENCOURAGE OUR STATE TO CONTINUE
TO PROVIDE LEADERSHIP DURING
THIS CRISIS AS WE CAN PROTECT
OUR COMMUNITIES AND OUR
CONSTITUENTS. CREEK DR ED WHAT
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN I'D
LIKE TO THANK THE CHAIR AND THE
SPEAKER FOR THE OPPORTUNITY- TO
ACTUALLY BE HERE TODAY THIS IS
NOT A COMMITTEE THAT I SAID ON.
BUT THIS IS AN OPPORTUNITY FOR
SOME QUICK. BUT I'VE BEEN
REALLY WANTING TO ASK FOR QUITE
A WHILE. I ASK THESE QUESTIONS
IN THE SPIRIT OF- ACTUALLY
LOOKING AT SECTION THIRTY SEVEN
OF SB EIGHTY NINE. WHERE IT
SAYS ONCE AGAIN AS AS- ONE MAKE
SURE THERE'S A BIPARTISAN
CONCERN- MISTER OBERNOLTE READ
THIS SUMMER. THE FIRST LINE
AGAIN BECAUSE I THINK IT'S
IMPORTANT THAT. WE HE- BY THIS
AS A NAME. THE WAY I WANT TO
DISCUSS THINGS HERE TODAY. THE
END OF THE LEGISLATURE IT
MINUTES. TO WORK STAKEHOLDERS
ANG TEAM MEMBERS I JUST.
PLEDGES STAFF. IT'S CLEAR THAT
MR WORKING WITH. THEIRS BUT NOT
PLEDGES SURE. THE STAFF. I HAVE
A HEALTH COMMITTEE STAFF HAS
OVER A HUNDRED OF HEALTH POLICY
X. AND WE HAVE NOT BEEN ENGAGED
AND WE HAVE BEEN TRYING TO
ENGAGE. I WANT TO COMPLIMENT
THE GOVERNOR I THINK IT'S AN
AMAZING- AND I'M PROUD
CALIFORNIAN AND WITH THE LEADER
THAT THE GOVERNOR SHOWN. IT'S
BEEN AUTUMN. WE COULD GET TO AN
NOVEL. THERE IS TREMENDOUS
EXPERTISE IN THIS LEGISLATIVE
BODY. TO BE ABLE TO HELP TAKE
THINGS TO A LEVEL AND IT FEELS
LIKE EVERY FOR I MAY TO. GET
THAT TO ANOTHER LEVEL- I'VE-
SINCE QUITE FRANKLY- AND SO.
GETTING INFORMATION THAT MIGHT
DID YOU ONCE HE DESPERATELY
NEED BEEN DIFFICULT. IT'S A
MYTH OPPORTUNITY IT'S A MISSED
OPPORTUNITY BECAUSE EACH OF US
ON THE DíAS REPRESENT FOUR
HUNDRED AND SIXTY FIVE THOUSAND
PEOPLE. WE HAVE RELATIONSHIPS
WITH LOCAL GOVERNMENTS- CITIES
COUNTIES- SPECIAL DISTRICTS ARE
HOSPITALS ARE DOCTOR GROUPS A
VARIETY OF THINGS. WE'RE NOT
GETTING- INFORMATION THAT WE
THAT WOULD BE HELPFUL TO US TO
BE ABLE TO COMMUNICATE PEOPLE
AND TAKE THINGS TO THE NEXT
LEVEL SO I SAY THESE THINGS IN
THIS OF- WE GO FORWARD- AND HOW
DO WE- GET THE YOU KNOW GET TE
OPTION TO BE ENGAGED- MORE. AND
ACTUALLY HELP SOLVE THESE SOME
OF THESE LUNCHES- I HAVE SOME
SPECIFIC QUESTIONS BUT THAT'S
FRAME WHICH I TRY TO BE. CORD
HOW DO WE- LIVE UP TO- THE
INTENT IN SB EIGHTY NINE AND-
ENGAGE LEGISLATURE ENGAGE
LEGISLATIVE STATE STAFF. WE
OFTEN AS LEGISLATORS- HERE
MAYBE FIVE MINUTES BEFORE AN
EXECUTIVE ORDER COMES OUT. OR
OR WATCHING THE GOVERNOR. DALY
AIDS TO GET INFORMATION YEAH-
THAT'S THE CHAPLAINS MIGHT.
WHEN I MY DISTRICT I HAVE
COUNTY PUBLIC HEALTH OFFICERS
IN HOSPITAL EXECUTIVES MEMBERS
THE KINI. INFORMATION I TO SAY.
NO I'LL TRY TO GET BACK TO YOU
AND THAT'S- I THINK THAT'S A
MISSED OPPORTUNITY- AS FAR AS
QUICK IN SOME SPECIFIC
QUESTIONS HERE. WE HAD AN EVENT
HAPPENED- OVER THE WEEKEND TO-
WHERE- A AN INMATE FROM CDC ARE
FROM CHINO WAS RELEASED- WAS
SUPPOSED TO GO TO STANISLAUS
COUNTY- AND SO AND SELF
QUARANTINE THERE FOR TWO WEEKS-
THAT RELEASED. THE INMATE UP IN
MENDOCINO COUNTY ARE WHERE. WE
HAVE WE HAVE CASES IN MENDOCINO
COUNTY- THE LAST ONE WAS A
TWENTY TWO OR TWENTY THREE DAYS
AGO NOW. AND NOW WE HAVE
SOMEONE WHO EXPOSED TO ENDED UP
IN OUR COUNTY NO NO THIS. AN
THE IS A CONCERN TO ME SO MY
QUESTION MY FIRST QUESTION IS.
AS WERE READ SEEN IN MAYES FROM
STATE PRISONS ARE WE TESTING.
OR WE AND ARE WE FOLLOWING UP
TO SEE THAT THEY ACTUALLY ARE
SELF QUARANTINE SO THAT WE
DON'T END UP WITH ANOTHER
SITUATION WHERE AN INMATE-
FORMER INMATE- ENDS UP IN A
COUNTY THAT LOCAL LAW
ENFORCEMENT ISN'T EXPECTING.
PUBLIC HEALTH IS AN EX. AND HOW
DO WE YOU KNOW HOW DO WE GET
THAT INFORMATION OUT THERE- SO
THE QUESTION IS ARE THEY BEING
TESTED PRIOR TO. PRIOR TO
RELEASE AND IF NOT HOW WE
ENSURING THAT THEY ARE ACTUALLY
QUARANTINING IN PLACE WHERE
THEY WERE SUPPOSED TO. THIS IS
IN THE REST OF THE DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE AND WE ARE AWARE OF
THOSE SITUATIONS- AND THE
INCIDENT THAT TOOK PLACE
MENDOCINO. AND UNDERSTAND THAT
THE INDIVIDUAL WAS REMOVED AND-
THERE ARE CIRCUMSTANCES WHERE-
THAT HAD TO. BE IN THE OUT
BECAUSE IT IS A PLACE THAT
WOULD PLACE THEM. THE THAT WHAT.
I'M IN A SENSE THAT OR REST.
CATEGORY SO I'M I'M NOT A COULD
NOT SAYING THAT THAT WAS RIGHT
I THINK THAT WE ARE I'M- JEFF
AWARE THAT YOU CAN. WE ARE NOT
TESTING. AND WE ARE. CONTROL
EXPOSURE IT HAS I'M I'M LEAVING
IS FEES OF AT THIS I. IN THE
GORE WORKING ON ADDITIONAL
PARTNERSHIPS WITH CHEAP ARCHIE
PROBATION OFFICERS OF
CALIFORNIANS CDC ART- IDENTIFY
MORE AND PLACEMENTS EITHER
THROUGH PROJECT DRINKING OR
OTHER AND HOUSING OPTIONS I
THINK WE'RE STILL WORKING
THROUGH A LOT OF THOSE ISSUES
WITH PREMATURE TO GIVE YOU MORE.
THAN POINT BUT WE ARE AWARE AND
WORKING TO THE ISSUE CAN THIS
MONTH WEREN'T THE RELEASE OF
ABOUT THOUSAND OFFENDERS AND IT
WOULD BE OUR TO OUR TEST EACH
ONE OF THEM AND AS THEIR
LEADING BUT ONLY. TO BE TEAM
HAS A POTENTIAL. HAVE I DO. IS
THE INDICATION WITH OUR COUNTY
PART COULD BE I THINK IN REALLY
WE STAR COMMUNICATING FROM C.
ARE WITH COUNTY PROP PUBLIC
HEALTH DEPARTMENT BUT NOT
NECESSARILY PROBATION WHICH WE
RECOGNIZE AS OF. ACTIVE AND
MAKING SURE THAT WE EIGHT SEVEN
INDIVIDUALS EARLY AND SO THAT
THEY CAN ENGAGED HER PROBATION
OFFICER LOCALLY LOCALLY AS WELL.
WELL I THINK THE CONCERN IS
THAT- YOU DO YOU DO YOU HAVE
SOMEONE WHO IS NOW IN A
COMMUNITY. THAT WAS CLOSED- IN
A SETTING AND THE COMMUNITY
DIDN'T KNOW THE PERSON WAS
COMING IN AND THAT COULD HAVE
BEEN. SO WE DON'T KNOW HOW MANY
PEOPLE AT THIS POINT I'M SURE
OUR PUBLIC HEALTH AUTHORITIES
IN MENDOCINO COUNTY OR TRYING
TO TRACE UP WE DON'T KNOW HOW
MANY PEOPLE THAT THAT PERSON
CAME IN CONTACT WITH. WE DON'T
KNOW. NOW I'M NOT EVEN SURE IF
THAT. HAS JUST POSITIVE BUT IT
I HOPE THIS. BEEN OTHER OTHER
NEEDS I'M JUST. FIVE I'M
CONCERNED ABOUT THAT AND I KNOW
MY- MY SHARE OF FROM MY
DISTRICT ATTORNEY AND- MY
COUNTIES. YEAH AND A HUGE RIGHT
OF OTHER PEOPLE ARE. SCRATCHING
OUR HEADS ON THAT I'VE ASKED TO
A VAST MODELING DATA AS- AS AS
OTHERS HAVE PASSED AND- AN
APPRECIATE THE CHARTS THAT WE
SAW I DO NOTE THAT- THERE'S A
THEIR- IT DOESN'T. COMPLY HE
LINES ON THE BOTTOM THAT SHOW
THE DAY AND SHE THE IN THE
NUMBER OF CASES. IF YOU LOOK AT
THE DATES- AND THE RED LINES IT
SHOWS ABOUT THE FIRST THIRD OF
APRIL YET WE ARE IN THE- THIRD
THROUGHOUT APRIL AND- I'M- I'M-
AS A DATA DATA IS SENT IS NOT
CURRENT SO WE DON'T REALLY KNOW.
LAST WHERE. ARE SO. I RECOGNIZE
THAT THERE'S ALL THAT BUT AS
SOMEONE WITH A SCIENCE
BACKGROUND AS SOME OF THE
HEALTH CARE BACKGROUND AS DOES
OUR DOCTOR ARAMBULA- I THINK WE
ARE PROBABLY UNIQUELY
POSITIONED TO UNDERSTAND THE
DATA AND UNDERSTAND THE
IMPLICATIONS OF THE DATA BUT WE
HAVE BEEN GIVEN THE OPPORTUNITY
TO LOOK AT- AND- MORE TO CALL
FOR ME TO PAY WITH CONFIDENCE
TO MY- THESE. THEY WANT. AND SO.
IN FEET I KNOW WE'RE GOOD NEXT
WEEK ABOUT RECOVERY AND I'M I'M
LOOKING TO THAT- THAT PP IS
GOING TO BE A HUGE ISSUE AND
IT'S NOT JUST A ISSUE FOR RIGHT
NOW WITH WE WITH OUR SNIFFS AND
HOSPITALS AND SO ON BUT AS WE
LOOK TO THE FUTURE AND A RE
OPENING- I. THINK IT IS MY BACK
AND WE ARE IN IN DEBT THREE-
ONE OF THOSE- AND I THINK IT
TAKES A SCHOOL FOR THIS FOR
THIS CONDITION BECAUSE OF THE-
SCHOOLS. THERE IS. AND I WORRY.
THE PEOPLE PROFESSION ALREADY
STRUGGLING TO GET PP IT'S NOT
JUST THE MASKS IT'S NOT JUST
THE GLOVES IT'S FACE SHIELDS
IT'S- PROTECTIVE EQUIPMENT ITS
HEAD WHERE. AND A VARIETY AND
MATH AND GLOVES AND SO- WE KNOW
THAT MOST DENTAL OFFICES ARE
DOWN NOW- AND ONLY SENIOR
URGENCY PATRONS PRETTY BEEN
STRUGGLING TO GET PP. AB FOR
OUR- THIS IS SOME CAL WHERE
THERE ARE PROVIDERS THAT THESE
PEOPLE ARE GOING TO END UP IN
EMERGENCY ROOMS- THE PLACES
THAT REALLY AREN'T THE SAFEST
BECAUSE THEY'RE SEEKING DENTAL
CARE AND I'M I'M VERY WORRIED
ABOUT THAT. I WANT TO THANK
DOCTOR REGULAR FOR BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH WE'RE STARTING TO SEE A
LOT OF CHALLENGES WITH WITH
THAT. AND I'M VERY CONCERNED
ABOUT THAT AS ARE THE- COUNTY
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH OFFICERS I
KNOW THAT THERE'S A AT A MISTER
TING AS AND RECEIVE A LETTER OF
SOME OF THEIR CONCERNS. ECHO
THOSE KIND. AND SUPPORT FOR
THAT. AS IT WERE TO HOSPITALS
AND THE CHALLENGES HOSPITALS
ARE GOING TO FACE- YOU KNOW NOT
A HOSPITAL IT EQUAL I
REPRESENT. A CAT A GO GO. TRICK
WORK ON WE HAVE A LOT OF STE
HOSPITALS BEING SICK CRITICAL
ACT HOSPITALS AND THEY'RE SMALL
AND THEY'RE GOING TO STRUGGLE.
SO I ASK THAT THE- HE IS THE OF.
IN TASTE GOVERNOR'S OFFICE OF
AT THIS RETROFIT REQUIREMENTS
THAT ARE COMING FORWARD- AND A
POTENTIAL DELAY FOR THAT
BECAUSE- HOW COULD WE POSSIBLY
MOVE FORWARD ON THAT WHEN WE
KNOW THAT OUR HOSPITALS RIGHT
NOW MANY OF THEM ARE ON THE
VERGE OF REALLY REALLY
STRUGGLING SO IS THERE BEEN ANY
CONVERSATION ABOUT. A
POTENTIAL- PUSH BACK OF SOME OF
THE TIME LINES. THE POTENTIAL
FOR ADDITIONAL SUPPORT- FOR
THOSE GOV HOSPITALS ESPECIALLY
THOSE. THAT ARE NOT PARTS OF
MAJOR HOSPITAL SYSTEMS THAT
DON'T HAVE THE RESOURCES. I
GUESS BEFORE. ALTERNATE OVER TO
MY COLLEAGUE ADAM DORSEY AND
THEN MARK ON A WATCH AWAY AS
WELL. HELLO THIS IS ADAM DORSEY
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE AND SO.
YOU KNOW WHAT I CAN SAY THAT I
MEAN THERE'S A OF A NUMBER OF
DIFFERENT WAYS THAT WERE
HEARING FROM HOSPITALS IN IN
HEARING ABOUT THE SUPPORT
THAT'S NEEDED AND CERTAINLY
OVER THE ERRORS THE SEISMIC
REQUIREMENTS OR SOMETHING. THAT
ALWAYS HAD WILLING TO.
WILLINGNESS TO DO EVALUATE RE.
ON A CASE BY CASE BASIS-
DEPENDING ON WHAT WAS NEEDED-
BUT I WILL TURN IT OVER TO.
SERVICES AGENCY. FOR ANY
ADDITIONAL INFORMATION ON ON
THAT TYPICALLY. THANK YOU
DOCTOR I THANK YOU ADAM AND
THEN THANK YOU DOCTOR WORK FOR
THAT QUESTION LET ME JUST ADD
THERE'S TWO PIECES THAT I'D
LIKE TO RESPOND THE FIRST IS
THAT PEACE AROUND THE DATA
COMPONENTS SO WE PROVIDED IN.
BOOKER PROVIDED. EVERY COUNTY
AND THAT IS BOTH EMERGENCY
MANAGERS ASWELL AS PUBLIC
HEALTH OFFICERS. AND I'M
CERTAINLY HAPPY TO SHARE THAT
WITH YOUR STAFF AND WE WOULD
LOVE TO HEAR YOU KNOW. YOU HAVE
TO PROVIDE US FEEDBACK ON IT.
MODEL BUG DIES PROVIDE COUNTY
LEVEL DATA AROUND AT THE MEDIAN
THE MEANING OF THE MODEL AS
WELL AS HOSPITALIZATION. RATES
ASH- BOTH IT WITHIN THE APP
<c.cyan>RAD TWENTY PERCENTILES THE</c>
SEVENTY THREE. AND ALSO I WE
CERTAINLY ARE. A LOT IF YOU AND
PROVIDE INFORMATION TO YOU AND
YOUR STAFF. AND WE ALSO ISSUED
A MEMO. TO ALL. DOCTOR AND THE
MANAGERS PROTECTING THEM
ADDITIONAL GUIDANCE AROUND THE
PARAMETERS PERCEPTIONS THAT
THEY COULD USE IN VARIOUS
MODELS THAT THEY CAN USE IN OUR
HOUSE. FROM THERE I MEAN. I.
THREE DAY. YEAH THE EIGHT YEAH.
STATIONS AS WELL AS I SEE USE
THAN CASE NOW ADD THAT WE
PROVIDE TO THE GOVERNOR MORNING
SO THAT IS ALSO MADE A BILL SIR
HAPPY TO FOLLOW UP IN MAKES
THAT YOU IN STAFF LINKS OF
THOSE IN TERMS. HI SO I MAKE
CITY AS ADAM ALLUDED TO THAT A
SOMETHING THEY WE ARE SO. AT TO
LOOK IN AND IT'S THAT WE HAVE
BEEN LOOKING AT- PRIOR TO THE
PANDEMIC- AND IT'S SOMETHING
THAT WE TAKE SERIOUSLY. HAVE TO
BALANCE BOTH THE ABILITY FOR
HOSPITALS TO BE READY- IN THE
EVENT OF AN EARTHQUAKE AND MAKE
SURE THAT I HAD THAT THE- THAT.
POSSIBLE TO ME SURE THAT THE
STATE. OUT BUT WE RECOGNIZE
THAT AND ALSO THE FINANCIAL TO
SOME EXTENT AND SO WE'RE HAVING
TO BALANCE THAT. CERTAINLY
WOULD HAPPY TO FOLLOW UP AS
PART OF THE MAY REVISION AND
HAVE THAT CONVERSATION WITH.
THANK YOU A COUPLE MORE
QUESTIONS MISTER CHAIR IF
THAT'S OKAY- FIRST FOUR ONE
THIS I WANT TO. COMMEND THE
GOVERNOR ON THE CALL FOR THE-
HEALTH KERR VOLUNTEER. HELP
LAUNCH YOUR CORE- AND- THE
AMAZING RESPONSE WE SAW
WITHOUT- ON. UNBELIEVABLE QUITE
FRANKLY AND- AND JUST GOES TO.
SHOW THAT- THERE ARE THERE'S A
THERE ARE A LOT OF FOLKS OUT
THERE WHO REALLY WANT TO REALLY
WANT TO BE ENGAGED. AND BE
HELPFUL- DO ONE. YEAH AS MAYOR
WHEREBY MANY. MANY I DON'T MIND
OVERCOME IN MY JUST BUT I WOULD
GATHER THAT THERE ARE MANY
OTHERS IN THE STATE HAVE LAID
OFF STAFF. AND ARE FEDERALLY
QUALIFIED HEALTH CENTERS ARE
LAYING OFF STAFF- AND- DID THE
IT IS IT DID OR IS THE IS THE
HEALTH CORPS LOOKING TO THOSE-
NOW LAID OFF- STAFF WHO ARE
FAMILIAR WITH SPINDLES HAVE
WORKED IN HOSPITALS CURRENT
CERTAIN. CAN HOSPITALS AND HAVE
OF CURRENT LOOKING THEM TOO AT
THE INITIALLY- IN COMMUNITIES
TO- HELP WITH THIS- AND THE
REASON I ASK IS THAT WERE THE
VOLUNTEERS ARE ARE ACTUALLY MY
UNDERSTANDING IS PAID SO IT'S
A- THEY ARE GETTING ME FOR
THAT. THESE OTHER PEOPLE ARE
NOW ON UNEMPLOYMENT SO.
ESSENTIALLY THE SPENDING MONEY
IN TWO DIFFERENT DIRECTIONS
POSSIBLY THAT WE MIGHT HAVE TO
SO- HABSI ADMINISTRATION READ
TWO. OF AT AND COMMUNICATE WITH
THE- NIXON THE HOSPITAL SIBLEY
YOU SOME OF THESE ARE NOW LAY
OFF- STAFF MEMBERS- IN THE
HEALTH CORPS- AS A WAY TO
EXPEDITE- FILLING THAT OUT.
THIS IS MARCO MEETS WITH THE
HEALTH AND HUMAN SERVICES
AGENCY I DON'T BELIEVE WE HAVE
CERTAINLY CAN TAKE THAT OFF
LINE AND GET BACK TO YOU. THANK
YOU. REGARDING ANTIBODY
TESTING- WE HEARD I DON'T KNOW
MAYBE TEN DAYS AGO THAT-
THROUGH STANFORD A
COLLABORATIVE THAT THERE WOULD
BE- IMMINENT APPROVAL OF-
ANTIBODY TESTING- AND- I KNOW
THAT THERE HAVE BEEN ANTIBODY
TESTS DONE BUT I HAVE. SOUNDS
MEANT HOW'S THAT EFFORT HAS
THERE BEEN FDA APPROVAL OF THE
END OF MY BODY TESTING WHAT IS
THE STATUS ABOUT. SENATOR PAT I
MEAN SIX SORRY ADD DOCTOR WED-
APOLOGIES ABOUT THAT AT ON THAT
ON THAT STAND FOR CASTTHE
STANFORD CAST- WE INITIALLY
THOUGHT REQUIRED FDA APPROVAL
HOWEVER IT DOES NOT REQUIRE
AFTER THE APPROVAL WHICH
BECAUSE IT IS A CLEAR LAP- AND
IT IS THE PROPERTY. OF TEST IT
IS APPROVED BY THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT AND CAN BE PUT INTO
USE- AND SO WE'RE WORKING
CLOSELY WITH OUR STANFORD
PARTNER. TO SEE HOW WE- I WOULD.
AROUND THE ENTIRE CAST AND
PRODUCE BECAUSE THE VALIDITY
AND THE RELIABILITY AS YOU KNOW
AS A POSITION AND SOME OF THE
SITE BACKGROUND. AT THAT SINCE
IS REALLY IMPORTANT AND IT WILL
TAKE SOME TIME TO GET THAT A
TIE TREATED A PRO. IS WE'LL
WORK VERY WITH OUR STANFORD
COLLEAGUES AND MAKE SURE THAT
THAT HAPPENS BUT FROM A FEDERAL
PERSPECTIVE THAT TEST HAS BEEN
APPROVED- AND CAN BE YEARS. I
WASN'T AWARE OF THAT SO I
APPRECIATE THAT AND THEN MY
FINAL QUESTION IS ON HEALTH
RELATED BUT IT'S EQUAL IT'S
VERY VERY IMPORTANT. TO MY
COMMUNITIES I REPRESENT A
DISTRICT THAT HAS NO ENTITIES
LET THAT ARE GREATER THAN FIVE
HUNDRED THOUSAND IN POPULATION.
SO WHEN THE CARES AT WITH THE
CARES ACT IN THE MONEY FOR
GOVERNMENT SO LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS- EVERY CAN BE
PUTTING COUNTY AND WHAT LIVE.
IS THAT FIVE THOUSAND THREE. I
TODAY IT SEEMS NO INFORMATION
ABOUT HOW THE SMALLER
JURISDICTIONS ARE ACTUALLY
GOING TO RECEIVE FEDERAL MONEY-
AND- THAT'S A QUESTION I GET A
LOT HOW IS IT GOING TO HAPPEN.
HOW MUCH WITH BE TESTING THE
CAT. AND SO I'D LIKE TO KNOW
WHERE IS WHERE ARE WE ON THAT-
IN OUR OUR COMMUNITY GOING TO
HOW WE GONNA GET THAT IN A XIN.
DESPERATELY WANTED NOW I
UNDERSTAND RIGHT. MAYBE I MAYBE
YOU CAN CALL. THE RISK TO THE
MY FOR FROM FOR THE CARES ACT
RELATED TO OUR WORK BUT THERE
IS FOR THE- SINS OF HUNDRED
THOUSAND OR UNDER. SO THOSE
RESTRICTIONS AS WELL ARE THEY
GOING TO SEE REDUCTION IN THE
AMOUNT THAT THEY MIGHT GET SO
THAT THE STATE- COOPS SOME OF
THAT THROUGH. FOR
ADMINISTRATIVE COSTS BECAUSE I
THINK THAT WOULD BE A CHALLENGE
AS WELL- SO- AND UP THAT WOULD
BE REALLY HELPFUL. ASSEMBLY
MEMBER WOULD IT WHEN IT COMES
TO THE- FEDERAL MONEY WHICH IS
APPROXIMATELY FIFTEEN POINT
THREE BILLION DOLLARS. YOU'VE
IDENTIFIED VERY SIGNIFICANT
ISSUE WHICH THAT GOVERNOR HAS
ALL BLACKED OUT FOR THE REST OF
THE NATION IS THAT. WE NEED TO
MAKE SURE THAT THIS IS SYSTEMS
REACHES STATE AND LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS ACROSS THE SPECTRUM
AND THAT FIVE HUNDRED THOUSAND
CAP. THE THING. YOUR CITIES
OAKLAND AND LONG BEACH ON
RECEIVE THAT STUCK REALLY FUN
MONEY BIG THEY FALL THAT I
HUNDRED THOUSAND CAPTAINS WE
HAVE RAISED IT AT IN RUSSIA
PRESENTED AS WE KNOW THAT ALL
STATE SENT ON THE SAME THERE
ARE WHERE THERE'S NO. PRESSURE
AND SUMMER. THAT CONGRESS THAT
CAN MAKE ADJUSTMENTS TO THAT
FORMULA AS PART OF A BROADER
PACKAGE A FEDERAL FUNDING. YOUR
WEATHER COMES THIS WEEK OR IN
THE NEXT SEVERAL WEEKS THAT'S
SOMETHING. HIS WROTE. AND IN
FAXED THE GOVERNOR HAS CALLED
FOR ONE TRILLION DOLLARS IN
STATE AND LOCAL ASSISTANCE THAT
FROM CONGRESS TO HELP COVER
SOME OF THE ISSUES THAT WE'RE
FACING OVER THE NEXT THREE
YEARS WHEN IT COMES
SPECIFICALLY TO THE ALLOCATION.
YOU OR THE POINT THREE POWER.
UNDERSTANDING IS THAT THAT FOR
CONSCIOUS THAT IS AND SEVERAL
BUILDINGS OF DOLLARS IS ON WAY
SO WE SHOULD HAVE A UPDATE
WITHIN THE- COUPLE. OF DAYS IN
TERMS OF THAT WE IS THE
CALIFORNIA PLAN FROM THE
TREASURY DEPARTMENT BELIEVES IS
THAT ALL OF THAT MONEY SHOULD
BE ALLOCATED BY APRIL FOURTH
WHICH IS. ALLEN SPOKE DATE
THOSE GOVERNOR. HELP FOR THE
ACTUAL CASH IWILL BE RECEIVED
FROM THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT
PRETTY SOON WHEN IT COMES TO
THE ACTUAL SPENDING OUR MONEY
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT HAS
PROVIDED SOME GUIDANCE WE HAVE
HAD SOME ISSUES WITH THE ITEMS
THAT THEY PROVIDED ALTHOUGH IT
IS THE GENERAL SOME THAT WERE.
WERE HOPE. GUIDANCE. DID THE
SPENDING PRETTY FOR BECAUSE AS
WE COVER IN THIS YEAR. THERE
ARE SO MANY FACETS TO THIS.
THERE THE DIRECTOR'S. HELPING
VULNERABLE COMMUNITIES THEY'RE
STEALING WITH CASELOAD
INCREASES ARE ALSO. GAPS OUR
STATE HAS LOST ITS CROSS
COUNTRY ARE SAYING BUT THE
ACTUAL ALLOCATION OF THAT
FEDERAL I'M SORRY AND IT STATE.
MY NAME. IS SOMEWHERE IN THE
NEIGHBORHOOD IT OR NOT. NOW
THIS. HE'S NOW AND THEN WHEN IT
COMES TO LOCAL GUY THAT THEY
HAVE THE FREEDOM TO MAKE THEIR
OWN DECISIONS ON HOW TO SPEND
THAT MONEY WITHIN THE
GUIDELINES SET. OKAY DAIS I'LL
PASS IT OVER TO CHRISTY ON OUR
TEAM IN CASE SHE ANYTHING
ADDITIONAL. THANK YOU THE BACK
THAT THAT YOU COVER ALL OF HYPE.
AND THE OTHER I WOULD ADD IS
RELATIVE TO THE LOCAL
GOVERNMENT SHARE THERE'S FIVE
POINT EIGHT BILLION THAT CAN
BE. ACCESSED DIRECTLY BY THOSE
LARGER INTO LARGE ANTI AS- AT
AM. LARGEST THAT REPRESENTS
ABOUT THIRTY FOUR CENT AT THE
TOP. IN THOSE LOW BODIES. YEAH
HOWEVER DURING THAT IN A LARGE
WAY BUT PROBABLY IS NOT TING
SOME OF THOSE. I'D AS LONG AS
IT WASN'T PREVIOUSLY AND- ANY
BUDGET PLAN IN TERMS OF
SUPPLANTING THOSE FINES AND BUT-
RELATE IT NINETEEN IT BROADLY
USABLE AND WITH THE EXCEPTION
OF BACK FEELING LOST REVENUES
WHICH IS AN ISSUE WE HAVE REYES
AND RIGHT IS. IT FAIR TO SAY
THEN ONE NIGHT WHEN I MASS BY
LOCAL GOVERNMENT THAT QUESTION
WE JUST NEED TO WAIT UNTIL THE
MAY RE BOXES OUT FOR THE
SMALLER STATIONS REALLY DON'T
KNOW WHAT THEY MIGHT BE GETTING
HOW THEY MIGHT BE ABLE TO GET.
I AM OR WHEN TO BE ABLE TO GET
THE BEST ANSWER TO THAT
QUESTION AND THEN CHRIS THIS
WAY IT IS RIGHT NOW THE SMALL
GOVERNMENTS ARE AN ELIGIBLE FOR
A DIRECT. WILL SHARE. THE
STATE. I'M DATING ON DAY ARE
STILL HAVE TO DECIDE HOW TO
ALLOCATE THAT WERE OBVIOUSLY
FACING A LOT OF CHALLENGES. A
CERTAIN WE DECISIONS THAT HE
MAKES WILL BE TO SPEND THAT
MONEY IN A WAY THAT BENEFITS
THE WHOLE STATE BUT WHEN IT
COMES. EFFORT. OKAY LOCAL. MAPS
SO THE POSSIBILITY THAT SMALLER
JURISDICTIONS MIGHT NOT GET
MONEY WHERE LARGER
JURISDICTIONS MIGHT IS THAT
WHAT YOU'RE SAYING UNLESS
CONGRESS TAKES ACTION. TWO
RIGHT NOW LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
THAT ARE ABOUT FIVE HUNDRED
THOUSAND. I DON'T HAVE ANY OF
THOSE SO THAT'S MIKE WE ASK MY
CONCERN I DON'T HAVE ANY OF
YES. YES IT WOULD BECAUSE RIGHT
NOW ON THE MONEY GOES TO THOSE
GOVERNMENTS OR TO THE STATE- SO
THE MONEY THAT LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS ABOUT FIVE. WHICH I
KNOW. ARE NOT YOUR DAY THANK
CANNOT APPLY TO. THAT'S NICE.
THE STATE OUT NOT IS A NAY
REVISION NOT IN TERMS OF HOW
GOVERNOR ONE TO SPEND MONEY.
BUT THERE'S A POSSIBILITY THAT
THAT SOME OF THE THAT THAT
LARGER JURISDICTIONS COULD GET
A HIGHER PERCENTAGE OF THEY
MIGHT BE ELIGIBLE. THEN RURAL
JUST WHAT I'M CONCERNED ABOUT
IS WE'RE ALWAYS FIGHTING IN
RURAL DISTRICTS FOR ARE JUST
OUR FAIR SHARE. AS NOT EVEN GET
OUR FAIR SHARE HERE. I I'M A
LITTLE HELLO I AM VERY
CONCERNED AS ARE MY LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS ON THAT. I JUST
WANT TO CLOSE BY SAYING YOU
KNOW I ASK DIRECT QUESTIONS AND
I'M VERY POINTED IN MY
QUESTIONS AND- AND BECAUSE I'M
I'M CONCERNED AND- I DO IT IN
THE SPIRIT OF REALLY WANTING TO
MAKE THIS. BETTER FOR ALL OF US
THAT WE CAN TAKE THIS TO THE TO
THE NEXT LEVEL AND I HOPE IT
WILL FIND A WAY TO DO THAT- WE
HAVE- OF. THOSE UNIQUE
RELATIONSHIPS WITH OUR LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS- WE- ELECTED. I
EMITS DISTRICT AND- I EXT. OF
WITH MISTER GILL WOULD DO SHE
THROUGH FIRES AND FLOODS- THE
STRENGTH OF OUR EMERGENCY
RESPONSE IN THOSE EVENTS WAS
THE ABILITY TO ACT. WITH PRETTY
MUCH ANYWHERE HE WANTED TO
WHENEVER I NEEDED TO GET
INFORMATION WHICH IS QUITE A
LOT WHAT WE'RE EXPERIENCING NOW
I WANT. THE MOST CURRENT
INFORMATION TO THOSE PEOPLE WHO
ASK FOR IT THE- I'M IN IN A
DISASTER OUR- HAITIAN WHETHER
IT'S GOOD NEWS OR BAD NEWS IS
REALLY REALLY IMPORTANT TO
BESIDE AND THEIR ABILITY TO
PLAN FOR FUTURE ASKING. OF
USING US AS A RESOURCE- WE FEEL
LIKE WE'VE BEEN NOT USED AT ALL
QUITE FRANKLY AND- WOULD HOPE
IN THE FUTURE YOU CAN FIND A
WAY. LEGISLATURE THE EXT. ALL
THE COMMITTEES AND- HOUSE-
THERE'S PROBABLY THOUSANDS OF
YEARS OF EXPERIENCE IN THIS
BUILDING- IN THE ASSEMBLY AND
IN THIS THAT. THAT IT IS UNDER
UTILIZED NOT UTILIZED AT ALL SO
WITHOUT YOU. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR. THANK YOU DON'T. MISS
MCCARTY. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
I HAVE SOME EARLY EDUCATION
CHILD CARE K. TWELVE QUESTIONS
BUT FIRST JUST TO GENERAL A
QUESTION RATHER THE LA. I'M IN
A FINANCED SO WHEN WE GOT THE-
THE LEGISLATURE ON THE HEAD I
GUESS IT WAS THE SIXTEENTH OF
MARCH WE- APPROPRIATED FIVE
HUNDRED MILLION UP TO BILLION
FROM THE GOVERNOR TO SPEND THIS
AGENCY. YEAH OUR- THE
GOVERNOR'S UP. SEVEN BILLION
WHICH ADDRESSES THE NEEDS TODAY
WE UNDERSTAND THAT SO THE
QUESTION WE NEED TO KNOW IS
THAT OF COURSE COMES OUT OF OUR
ONE TIME MONIES ARE RAINY DAY
FUNDS WHAT'S THE ROOM THEY'RE
REALISTIC EXPECTATION THAT.
BACK FEDERAL. HAS THE DECAL.
THAT CAN BE EITHER FINANCE OR
LA A- THANK YOU SIMILAR
WORKING THROUGH AND- RIGHT NOW
SOME SIX CERTAINTY BUT OUR BEST
ESTIMATE AS YOU MANAGED TO THE
STACKS FOR I CAN ONLY YOUR
TWENTY. FIRST ALL. WE SEVEN
BILLION DOLLAR AND
TRADITIONALLY PARTS LIKE DAIS
EMAIL CENTER EMERGENCY
MANAGEMENT AGENCY WILL
REIMBURSE ALL SEVENTY FIVE
CENTS 225% BASIS ON THAT WORD
TO APPLY TO ALL EXPENDITURES
AND NOT ACTUAL TOTAL. MEAN THAT
A LITTLE MORE. THE STATE BUT AS
MENTIONED THAT SUBJECT. HE AND-
WORKING WITH WE ASK HELPING
TAKE THE LEAD TO MAKE SURE AND
SPENDING THAT YOU IN CONTRACTS
THAT WE EXECUTE ARE DESIGNED A
WAY. MIGHT BE OUR ONLY IN POP.
LAST NIGHT AN ALTERNATIVE TO.
RECENT CALVERT IN CASE ANYTHING
IT'S A THAT SHE WOULD LIKE TO.
HELLO AND NOTHING FURTHER TO
ADD THE EXACTLY RIGHT WE
TYPICALLY HAVE A SEVENTY TWENTY
SHERIFFS WERE I NOTICED. OKAY
THANK YOU I NOW TO OUR TO OUR
SCHOOLS. MY LOCAL
SUPERINTENDENTS HERE AND MY
COLLEAGUES ACROSS THE STATE
HAVE CONTINUES BE ASKED
CONTINUOUSLY ASKS ABOUT THE
STATE OF OUR EDUCATION FUNDING
THE UNCERTAINTY TO. ON THE
SIXTH OF MARCH WE LAUGHED WITH
A PASS- SB ONE ONE SEVEN IN
THERE WE HAD FOR OUR SCHOOLS A-
OLD HARMLESS PROVISION FOR THE
CURRENT YEAR. AND NOW THERE'S A
QUESTION ON THE MAY REVISED OUT
SO THIS REALLY IS TO YOU.
FINANCE WHEN THE MAY REVISE
COMES OUT. WHAT'S THE STATUS OF
THE COLA WILL EVERY SAY CAME
THERE'S ELATION OF COULD. ON
THERE IS MONIES IN THEIR- ADD
WOULD THE DISTRICT COUNTING ON
TO GO TO KEEP THEM WHOLE- WHAT
WHAT'S THEIR REALISTIC
EXPECTATION FOR SCHOOL
DISTRICTS TO THE PLAN. WHETHER
IT'S THIS SUMMER AND PROGRAMS
OR THE FALL- RELATED LAYOFFS
AND PROGRAM- FOR BOTH THE
CURRENT YEAR. AND A TWO YEAR DO
NOT. HAVE A HEARING ON OUR
SUBCOMMITTEE IN A FEW DAYS ON
THIS BUT THIS KIND OF A MAN.
THING UP TO ADDRESS HERE AS
WELL. WHEN IT COMES TO THE
EDUCATION ISSUES ARE WITHIN
THEIR VISION WILL ALSO HAVE ARE
UPDATED REVENUE PROJECTIONS AND
THEN DASH J. ANY UPDATE THE
PROPOSITION NINETY EIGHT WHAT.
ABOUT CERTAINLY FROM WORK RIGHT
NOW I LOOKS LIKE WE MAY HAVE TO
FACE SOME DIFFICULT TRYING TO
SOLVE. PRETENTIOUS. ME JUST
HOMES DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE SO
WE HAVE BEEN CLOSELY TRACKING
AND INFORMATION REGARDING
REVENUES AND IS BEATING
MENTIONED WE DON'T HAVE I DON'T
REVENUES YET- BUT WILL HAVE
THOSE VISION. HOWEVER IT IS NOT
THAT WE'RE GOING TO BE LOOKING
AT SOME DIFFICULT MISSIONS. AND
WE'VE BEEN OUT IN SCHOOL
DISTRICT THAT ARE CONNECTIONS.
IF YOU PLAN. SYBIL AND TO PLAN
FOR A VARIETY OF SITUATIONS-
THERE'S JUST NOT ENOUGH DETAIL
AND OUT OF INFORMATION ATION
AVAILABLE YET ON ALREADY
STRESSED GIVE FOLKS A REALLY
STRONG SENSE OF WHAT TO EXPECT.
SO THE THAT THE CURRENT YEAR IS
PRETTY MUCH GONE BECAUSE THE
SCHOOLS ARE SHUT DOWN RIGHT NOW
BUT AS WE ADDRESS THE BUDGET
YEAR THAT'S WHAT HOPEFULLY
SCHOOLS. OPEN IN. BUT DISTRICTS
ARCHER ARC PLANNING ON GETTING
SOME OF THE CREEK CURRENT YEAR
RESOURCES TO KEEP THEM WHOLE DO
YOU. ROLE RESOURCE WHETHER THAT
THE CURRENT ALLOCATION THAT FOR
THE NEXT ONE THAT WE'RE LOOKING
TO GO TO HELP. BUT AGAIN I'M
JUST GO HOMES DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE SO WE KNOW THAT THAT
CARES ACT INCLUDES MORE THAN
THIRTEEN BILLION DOLLARS WERE
GOALS THROUGH A TUNNEL ONE A
ALLOCATE XIN AND WE HAVE A-
SEAT. THE APPLE. AND THE-
TWENTY SIX I'M WE ANTICIPATE
RECEIVING APPROXIMATELY ONE
POINT SIX FIVE BILLION OF THOSE
FUNDS BASED ON OUR TITLE ONE A
ALLOCATION AND THE FUNDS.
SENATE THEM ARE PART BE
ALLOCATED TO ELLIE A ON THE
BASIS OF TIME WHEN STATUS ON
THE ADDITIONAL AND SATISFIED
THAT THE STATE. FIRST IT LEVEL
ACTIVITIES. THERE IS AN
ADDITIONAL SET OF THAT ASIDE
THREE BILL TO BE NATION. FOR
WHAT ARE CALLED GOVERNOR'S AND
CATION MARGINS. AWARDS AND
WE'VE RECENTLY RECEIVED.
ALLOCATION THAT OR THE OF THE-
AND THE APPLICATION WAS REALLY
A WERE ON THAT AND IT LOOKS
LIKE THAT'S GOING TO BE ABOUT
THREE HUNDRED AND FIVE MILLION.
EIGHT AND THAT FOR K. THROUGH
HIGHER AND- EDUCATION SO OKAY
ABILITY TO USE THOSE FOR WHAT
IDEA THIS IS WHAT WE WILL.
DISCUSS WITH THE CHAIR. AND
AGAIN WE'LL GET THIS I'M
HEARING BUT JUST. YOU KNOW OUR
OUR EDGE ARE ARE TEACHERS ARE
JUST DO THEIR BEST RIGHT NOW
FOR ON DISTANCE LEARNING IN.
YOU KNOW PERRANCE AT HOME
REALLY THE IS RIGHT NOW FAMILY
MEMBERS TRYING TO FIGURE OUT
TEACH THE KIDS IN MANY OF THAT
IN THIS ROOM. YEAH SO THIS IS
THE TIME. THAT MOST WE DO FOR
SCHOOL IS TO KEEP HALL AND SO
THEY DON'T TO SHOW UP IN THE-
WITH LAYOFFS IN. AND REDUCE.
PORT GRANT WE A THAT THAT IT
SHE MADE GUY. AND OPPORTUNITY
GET. FRANKLY IT ONLY IS GONNA
GET WORSE IF WE IF WE HAVE TO.
THESE CALL THE- WE NEED A VERY.
A MY AT. NOW TO. BUT FOR WILL
THE GET THAT TO THAT IN OUR-
HEARINGS. BUT RELATED TO THESE
UP. HE STOCKPILE. THERE HAVE
BEEN SOME QUESTIONS FOR THE
ACCESSIBILITY FOR THIS FOR OUR
OUR SCHOOLS AND SPECIFICALLY
MORE- RELEVANT RIGHT NOW
BECAUSE MOST OF OUR WAS
SHATTERED OF COURSE. OUR OUR
CHILD THERE'S PROVIDERS SO WITH
THIS STATE- US. PP IT IS GOING
TO BE AVAILABLE TO OUR CHILD
CARE CENTERS AND PROVIDERS.
WHAT IS YOUR ALTERNATE OVER TO
YEAH. SPEAK TO THE PEOPLE IN
SOCCER CENTER PROVIDERS. SO
ACCORDING MARK A LARGE OF THANK
YOU FOR THE YOU KNOW THE- IN A
IN THE HIERARCHY OF THINGS
BEING ABLE TO SOURCE THE P. B.
AND THEN GET IT OUT. ONE OF MY
OF IT EITHER THOSE. THESE NEED.
AGAIN GETTING BACK TO BEING
ABLE TO- PROVIDE FOR A SECURE
AND SUSTAINABLE PIPELINE OF PBS
SO FOR US SO THAT WE'VE GOT
RESOURCES AND ABLE TO SUPPLY
THAT NEEDED. WE ALSO ENCOURAGE
OUT. SEC AND NOW. OF HERE THEIR
OWN. THE WORDS OUT THERE
THEY'RE GETTING UP GETTING FACE
COVERINGS OF- IF THAT'S A
REQUIREMENT IN DICTION OF THEM
TO TRY TO SORT. OF MAKE EVERY
EVERY CAN'T. SUPPORT ALL THE-
WE IT IN IS THE ME I'D BE ABLE
TO OUT OF RESTRICTIONS. YEAH I
THINK IT'S- NOW BUT I THINK
IT'S OBVIOUS THAT IT WE REACH
THE MARKERS AT THE GOVERNOR
ALLUDED TO AND START TO SHIFT
RIO IN PARTS OF OUR- ECONOMY
THAT'LL BE A GREATER. OUR CHILD.
THIS IS SPECIAL YOU HAVE. A
DIFFERENT SEN AND HOW THEY-
UPPER PROTECTIONS FOR THE
WORKERS AND JUST A PUBLIC
HEALTH OF CALIFORNIA- AT THE
NEXT ONE TO GO TO THAT FOCUS
ON- ACT. FOR OUR WORK IS BETTER
CENTRAL SERVICE WORKERS WHEN WE
TALK ABOUT- THE WORK OF
CALIFORNIA MAY TAP TYPE BUT OF
COURSE PEOPLE ARE RIGHT THE
FRONTLINE WORKERS. FIELD AND
SAFE BUT- POOREST RETAIN ON THE
THREE INDUSTRY. AG THE PEOPLE
TO LIVE. DOOR AND THE YOU KNOW
ALTHOUGH OF THE FOR SO MIKE IS
FOR YOU DEPART OF FIVE THAT'S-
DO WE FEEL CONFIDENT THAT THE
CURRENT NEEDS OF OUR THE SENT
TO WORK NOT AGAIN. THE HELP
PUBLIC SAFETY BUT ARE DEEMED
ESSENTIAL WHO ARE OUT DOING THE
NOW. AND WE THINK DOING TO MEET.
BUT AS OF THE SAM. THE
ADMINISTRATION IS WORKING AT TO
MEET THE NEEDS ARE ESSENTIAL
WORKERS AND WERE IN CLOSE QUIRK
CHEN AT THE STATE OPERATIONS
CENTER WITH A WE ASKED I THINK
IN THIS SESSION. ON THIS
QUESTION. THANKS ALL ORGAN HERE
SO THERE ARE NUMBER OF EFFORTS
THAT ARE UNDER WAY AND HAVE
BEEN UNDER WAY TO SUPPORT
ESSENTIAL WORKERS- IN FROM.
AGAIN WHERE WE CAN'T PROVIDE.
V. SO THAT THEY CAN GET YOU TO
DO WHAT THEY NEED TO BE DOING-
BUT ALSO- IN THE IF FOR
EXAMPLE- OF PROVIDING. OF TELL
A SPACE FOR THE SHOULD THEY BE
WORKING AND THEY'RE EXPOSED IN
ENVIRONMENT THEY ONE OF THE
CERVICAL THEIR FANS ARE. PLACE
TO- AND EIGHTY WHAT OTHER GOING
TO THIS PROCESS OF THAT THEN
THEN THAT'S IT HE FAMILY. WE
ARE. WORKING COURT AND THAT
WORKS WORKING WITHOUT ANY
ATTACK OUR OF OUR PURSE ARE AND
FIRE AND SHARE OF WATER YOUR ON
A REGULAR TO INSURE THAT THEY
GOT WHAT THEY NEED OTHER ARMED
OF THE WORK CORD MEETING AND-
WORKING CLOSELY HEALTH AND
HUMAN SERVICES SURE THAT ARE
ASKED. ONE IS. A GET THE F. AS
FAST AS POSSIBLE IN CASE WE
NEED TO GET THEM BACK INTO THE
LINE OF DUTY OR- TO MAKE SURE
THAT YOU CAN FORM AS MUCH AS
POSSIBLE. I CAN I DIDN'T PROP
R. LATE. FOR US STILL FOCUSED
ON THE CHILD CARE SHE- AND WHAT
ARE WE DOING TO MEET. THE CHILD
CARE NEEDS OF OUR- WORKERS I
KNOW THAT MANY JURISDICTIONS
ARE FOCUSING THAT RELATE TO.
HEALTH CARE PUBLIC SAFETY AS WE
KNOW THERE ARE. WHETHER YOU
ENSURE WORKERS OUT THERE. AND
READ GROCERY SO WHAT ARE WE
DOING TO HELP THESE FAMILIES
DEAL WITH THEIR CHILD CARE
NEEDS AND ARE WE CONFIDENT
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE THAT
WE'RE MEETING. THEIR CHILD CARE
AND- USE THAT WILL BE TURNED
OVER TO JESSICA HOMES THANK YOU
FOR THE CLARIFICATION. YES
THIRTY SO I- THERE HAVE BEEN A
FEW DIFFERENT INITIATIVES AIMED
AT ENSURING THAT ESSENTIAL
WORKERS ACCESS CHILD CARE SAID
THAT YOU BIGGEST PIECES ARE
REGARDING- POP UP CHILD CARE
THAT HAS BEEN. COLLABORATION.
HEALTH CARE ENTITIES AND THAT
HEALTHCARE PROVIDERS AND THEN
ADDITIONALLY THERE HAS BEEN
ADDITIONAL FUNDS PROVIDED BY
THE STATE FOR SUBSIDIZED CARE
FOR LOWER INCOME ESSENTIAL
WORKERS- FIRST THE POP OF CHILD
CARE ON MARCH SIXTEENTH THE
DEPARTED SO IT'LL START IS PUT
OUT FOR. OR CHILD. WHO AM FOR
IT FOR ENTITIES THAT WANTED TO
CREATE PUBLIC CHILD CARE
CENTERS EMERGENCY CHILD CARE
CENTERS FOR THE. THREE OF THESE
POP UPS WE'RE NOT SURE YET
EXACTLY HOW MANY COULD BE
SERVED IN NEEDS BUT AND WE DO
KNOW THAT THEIR THEIR THEIR
WRONG THING AND THEY'RE
STARVING CHILDREN. HOSPITAL
PRISONERS ARE UP. SHOULD IT TO
STOP THAT- THERE HAS BEEN SOME
WORK DONE AT THE DEPARTMENT OF
SOCIAL SERVICES AND THAT SPEAK
AND IN PARTNERSHIP WITH LABOR-
AND LABOR. THAT CAN HELP FOLKS
WHO NEED ACCESS THAT LOOKING AT
THE WORKERS WITH AVAILABLE
CHILDCARE AND THEIR AREA
WHETHER THAT'S PRIVATE PAY OR
PUBLIC. AND THEN FINALLY- AS
YOU KNOW. THE STATE OR THE
ADMINISTRATION I'M ALLOCATED
FIFTY MILLION DOLLARS- THROUGH
THE SB EIGHTY NINE FUNDS- FOR
THE PURPOSE OF PROVIDING SHORT
TERM VOUCHERS FOR. THROUGH THE
AT THE EASTERN OR ESSENTIAL
WORKER WHO. HAVING A 5% OF THE
IN INCOME. QUESTION ABOUT
WHETHER THAT BE TO TRACK YOUR
AT THE STATE LEVEL THE
DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION HAS
BEEN DOING SOME SECTIONS AND SO
HELP ME OUT WE ARE NOT SURE
EXACTLY NUMBER AND- CURRENTLY
WE ARE CAN. TO WORK AT TO TRY
TO MAKE SURE THAT WE'RE PER
ESSENTIALS THROUGHOUT THE STATE.
OKAY OUT OF OUR LAST THAT
QUESTION ON THE FIFTY MILLION A
SACK BUT YOU'RE CUTTING IN AND
OUT SO WE DIDN'T QUITE HEAR
WHAT YOU'RE SAYING I THINK YOU
TALKED ABOUT THE ESSENTIAL WORK
THE POT. CERTAINLY HEALTHCARE
WORKERS THAT OUR PUBLIC SAFETY
WORKING AT A HOSPITAL CITED
CLINIC WHAT HAD YOU THAT THEY
ARE ESSENTIAL AND ARE DOING A
LOT OF WORK SERVING. OUR SYSTEM
THREE IN THIS CRISIS AND WE
NEED TO MAKE SURE WE RECOGNIZE
THE NEEDS OF PLEASE TELL US
ISSUE. OUT THUS LAW. MAX EIGHT
NOT SURE IS OR- OR A CENTER
BASED PROGRAMS AND DO WE REALLY
THINK THAT WHERE- MEETING THE
NEEDS I THINK THERE'S
FRUSTRATION THAT WE HAVEN'T
READ UP. ALL OF THE FEDERAL. AS
T. V. G. THE WE'RE ALLOCATE THE
KEY PER. AND ALSO AFTER IT THE
REALITY THAT WE'RE NOT SPENDING
ALL OF THE CURRENT YEAR MONEY.
THE NINETEEN TWENTY. RESOURCES
FOR PRE STATE PRESCHOOL
PROGRAMS CHILDCARE PROGRAMS AND
SO I KNOW THAT PI DEPARTMENT
FINANCES THINKING HEY THAT'S
OPPORTUNITY TO SWEEP UP THE
COVER. GAP THAT MAY FACE FUTURE
BUT THE REALITY IS WE HAVE A
NEED TODAY. AND THAT YOU KNOW
WE ARE LOOKING AT AND SPENT
RESOURCES NOW AND WHY CAN'T WE
USE OF THOSE. TO START EXT. I'M
MERGING SEE- CHILD CARE NOW AND
LOOK AT THOSE RESOURCES PLUS
THAT THE FULL FEDERAL MOUNT
THAT WE HAVEN'T- PER YET. CAN I.
CERTAINLY THANK YOU FOR THAT
QUESTION SO- THERE'S A THERE'S
A COUPLE PIECES TO THAT'S ALL
BREAK IT DOWN INTO THE INTO AND
WILL PEACE AS SO WE PROCEED ARE
ALSO HE I'M IS ACTIVE PROBE
MISSION UNTIL JUST THIS WEEKEND
AND SET ARE. YEAH CLICK. AND
WILL BE ENGAGING WIH
LEGISLATURE ON THAT THAT WE
ABOUT THREE AND FIFTY MILLION
FOR THAT WE JUST RECEIVED THAT
INFORMATION AND I'M REGARD
FUNDS. THE STRUCTURE THAT'S THE
FIRST PIECE OF THE SECOND PIECE
IS REGARDING SAVINGS- IN THE
VARIOUS PROGRAMS AND WE HAVE
BEEN WORKING VERY HARD. WITH
THE MISSION IN THE DEPARTMENT
OF SOCIAL SERVICES TO IDENTIFY-
SEVERAL PIECES OF DATA THAT ARE
ESSENTIAL FOR US UNDERSTAND
EXACTLY HOW MUCH YOU HAVE IN
SAVINGS IN THESE DIFFERENT
PROGRAMS INCLUDING. THERE'S
THAT ARE ARE CLOSED WHETHER OR
NOT AND- AS- PROGRAMS ARE FULLY
SUBSCRIBED IF THEY ARE OPEN. UP
AND THEN THERE BEEN SOME OTHER
ISSUES AROUND ATTENTIONAL
DOUBLE PAYMENT FOR STUDENTS AND
FOR CHILDREN IN VOUCHER
PROGRAMS THAT WE'VE BEEN TRYING
TO GET SOME. GRASS THE
MAGNITUDE AS- BEAT THE SHORT
ANSWER TO YOUR QUESTION IS THAT
WE HAVE BEEN USING SAVINGS IN
THESE PROGRAMS TO COVER THE
COST OF POLICY DECISIONS THAT
WE MAKE IT WOULD DRESS CODE BUT
NOT. SO SAMPLE WE WAIVE FAMILY
IS IN ALL OF OUR PROGRAMS AND
HAVE BEEN USING SAVINGS FROM
THIS PROGRAM TO COVER THE COST.
I'M WE ALSO SEEN THAT OR- CLOSE
WE'VE ENSURED THEY'VE THE
VOUCHER SIDE THEY'VE RECEIVED
AT LEAST THIRTY DAYS OF PAYMENT
BUT IS IN ADDITION TO THE TEN
DAY THEY ALREADY HAVE BUILT IN
THEIR CONTRACTS- SO THAT'S
ANOTHER US MINNESOTA IT'D COST
WITH PAYMENT FOR FAMILY. THEY
WOULD HAVE OTHERWISE WOULD HAVE
BEEN. AS A VARIABLE SCHEDULES
ON THERE ARE MANY DIFFERENT
COSTS THAT WE'RE CURRENTLY-
TRACKING AND UTILIZING SAVINGS
TO COVER SO. THERE ARE MANY
THINGS HAPPENING CURRENTLY IN
THE CHILD CARE SPACES AND WE
LOOK FORWARD TO CONTINUING TO
WORK WITH YOU- TO IDENTIFY WHAT
RESOURCE AVAILABLE AND WE CAN
UTILIZE THOSE FUNDS. THE US.
THANK YOU I THINK IT'S FAIR TO
SAY THE PIZZA THERE IS A GREAT
APPRECIATION OF WHAT WE'RE
DOING TO DATE THERE'S STILL AND
I MADE EIGHT AND- I KNOW
LEADERSHIP FROM THE ASSEMBLY
HAS PUSHED ON THIS I KNOW IT'S
BEEN A LETTER FROM THE LET'S
SAY IT'S CAUCUS PUSHING ON WAS
PROVIDERS THE STATE AND WE'VE
GOT AN ACCESS ISSUE HASN'T GONE
AWAY. WORST AS SOME OF THESE
PROGRAMS ART ARE TINKERING
FINANCIALLY BUT WE NEED TO
REALIZE THAT WE HAVE IT'S AN
ISSUE TODAY WITH THE SENSOR
WORKERS OUT THERE- STRUGGLING
SO WE WANT TO MAKE SURE WE STEP
IT UP AND SERVE THEM. THANK YOU.
YOU MISTER BRECHT. DEFINITION
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN WANNA
THE KNOWLEDGE BOTH YOU AND THE
SPEAKER FOR INCLUDING DOCTOR
WOULD NOT AYE IN TODAY'S
HEARING I IN OUR CAPACITY IS
THE ROCK BUT POLICY AND HEALTH
AND GOVERNMENT ORDERS. ORGANIZE
MY QUESTIONS FOR. FROM THE
PERSPECTIVE OF THAT COMMITTEE-
BUT WHICH I CHAIR. ALL START
WITH THE- CALIFORNIA'S THIS
DISASTER ASSISTANCE ACT AND FOR
THOSE OF YOU NOT INTIMATELY
FAMILIAR WITH THAT. THIS JACKET
AUTHORIZES THE REIMBURSEMENTS
AND- IN FACT THIS IN PLACE-
PARTIALLY. TO AVOID PARALYSIS
OF GOVERNMENT RESPONSE IN THE
TIME OF PURCHASE TO SET A
FORMULA OF WHICH THERE CAN BE
EXPECTED REIMBURSEMENT- STATE
ROOM LEVEL. PERFECTLY IT. ALLOW
RESEARCH FIVE FOR COST BY THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT THE
REMAINING COST 75% OF THAT IS
BORN BY THE STATE GOVERNMENT
LEAVING ROUGHLY SIX POINT 25%
FOR LOCAL GOVERNMENT- TO.
INHERIT YOU KNOW WITH FEW
EXCEPTIONS- THE AW PROHIBITS
THE STATE SHARE FOR ANY OVER
PROJECT FROM EXCEEDING THAT 75%
OF THE STAY ELIGIBLE COSTS.
THERE ARE A HANDFUL DARKLY OF
LEGISLATIVE THE OUTLINE
DISASTERS WHICH ALLOW THE STATE
TO COVER UP TO. PERCENT NON
FEDERAL. AWESOME THAT LIST
INCLUDES THE NINETEEN EIGHTY
NINE LOMA PRIETA EARTHQUAKE THE
NINETEEN NINETY ONE EAST BAY
FIRE THE NINETY FOUR NORTHRIDGE
EARTHQUAKE THE TWO THOUSAND ONE
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA WILDFIRES
AND THE TWO THOUSAND THREE
CENTS A MINUTE OF QUAKES.
EARTHQUAKE UNFORTUNATELY MORE
RECENT EFFORTS TO INCREASE THE
STATE SURE DISASTER MITIGATION
COSTS FROM 75% TO A FULL 1100%
HAVE FAILED TO REACH THE
GOVERNOR'S DESK. FOR EXAMPLE
DURING THE TWENTY NINETEEN
TWENTY TWENTY SESSION. AB TWO
FORTY SEVEN BY- AT THAT POINT
ASSEMBLY MEMBER DOLLY NOW
CENTER DOLLY- AS WELL AS- IT
BEFORE ONE. OF OUR CALLERS WERE
GAP. AND TWENTY FIFTEEN TWENTY.
SIMILAR EFFORTS SENATOR DODD.
IN BOTH CASES HELD BY THE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE THERE
IS A SIGNIFICANT HISTORY OF
THAT IN FACT TO SIT THE GREAT
RECESSION. WE HAVE AUTHORIZED.
REIMBURSEMENT LEGISLATION.
WE'VE DONE THE START TIME OF. I
PRESS SAID GROWTH AND
PROSPERITY IN REVENUE SO
THERE'S REALLY NO EXCUSE FOR IT
BUT IT- WHAT WE PASSED. I WANT
TO. APPLAUD THE ADMINISTRATION
FOR THE MULTI FACETED APPROACH.
THEY'VE TAKEN AND THE
GOVERNOR'S TAKEN TO SLOW THE
TRANSMISSION COVER NINETEEN I
THINK I'VE HEARD IT SAID A
COUPLE TIMES I COULDN'T AGREE
MORE I'LL BE PROUD TO. HELP I
AM RIGHT. HE SAID THAT IT'S
TIME TO SEE WHAT WE CAN DO
BETTER. PRODUCT KEY FOR
EXAMPLE. WOULD PROVIDE SAFE
ISOLATION CAPACITY FOR TENS OF
THOUSANDS OF PEOPLE
CALIFORNIANS HOMELESS YOUR
CALIFORNIA. IS A PERFECT
EXAMPLE WHERE WE'VE CREATED
UNCERTAINTY THROUGH THE
ADMINISTRATION OF CDA- JUST A
FEW DAYS AGO THE GOVERNOR
KNOWLEDGE SOME OF THE- YEAH
JUST. OUR LOCAL INCLUDING SOME
MY COUNTIES TO QUICKLY SECURE-
OVER SIX THOUSAND HOTEL ROOMS.
AND I THINK WE SHOULD THAT- MY
CONCERN. COMES FROM THE FACT
THAT LOCAL GOVERNMENTS ARE ARE
TO TAKE THE NEXT STEPS AND
EXECUTE ON THE SECURING OF THE
ROPES ARM. AT ALL TO DO WITH
WHO IS RESPONSIBLE FOR THE
COSTS OF COMMITMENT SERVICE.
OFFICIAL OVER HEAD MEALS
UTILITIES. IN THE INDIVIDUALS
REMAIN ISOLATED. HOW ABOUT
SECURITY- WRAPAROUND SERVICES
IT'S SATURDAY AND I JUST WANNA
MAKE THE POINT DOESN'T MATTER
YOUR HOW BOLD DATA. THE STATE.
IS IF LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
PARTICULARLY THOSE THAT MY
COLLEAGUE- DOCTOR WOULD
MENTIONED THAT DIDN'T RECEIVE
THE MORE FLEXIBLE FUNDING POTS
ABLE TO OR YOU'RE JUST TO CASH
STRAPPED FOR TOO WORRIED TO
IMPLEMENT. I ASKED THE
REPRESENTS THE PART OF FINANCE
AS WELL AS ALWAYS TO EXPLAIN TO
ME THE COMMUNICATION PROCESS
KIND OF GO BOTH WAYS I'M GONNA
I'M GONNA START WITH THE
FOLLOWING THREE QUESTIONS.
FIRST HOW DOES HE ADMITS SURE
THE SUPER TO IMPLEMENT THE
PACIFIC DISASTER RESPONSE
EFFORTS SUCH AS PROJECT CRANKY
DOES THE ROLLOUT INCLUDES
PROCESS. INFORMATION REGARDING
EXPECT AS ELIGIBLE FOR
REIMBURSEMENT TO HOW THE
NEWSMEN MINISTRATION HAD A
LOCAL GOVERNMENT REIMBURSE FOR
REQUEST FOR THE COSTS INCURRED
DURING THE RESPONSE EFFORTS AND
HAS THE ADMINISTRATION
CONSIDERED ADDING CO TEAM TO
THE WEST OF THE ELIGIBLE 41100%
STATE REIMBURSEMENT PURSUANT TO
CD. WHAT STEPS CAN
ADMINISTRATION TO TODAY TO
ENSURE BETTER AND CLEAR
COMMUNICATION WITH LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS REGARDING THIS
REIMBURSEMENT. ASSEMBLY MEMBER
ON THE FIRST QUESTION
REGARDING. ROOM HE ALTERNATE
OVER TO MY COLLEAGUE MARCO. THE
OTHER QUESTIONS AND- I HAVE A
VAGUE ACTUALLY DIRECTOR GELLER
DUTY SINCE THIS IS A THEME A
PROGRAM- WELL A LACK RIGHT A
LITTLE BIT MORE ON THE- BUT THE
QUESTIONS ASSEMBLY. TO CLARIFY-
UP ROOM KEY OPERATION IS BEING
FUNDED THROUGH WHAT WE CALL
DIRECT FEDERAL ASSISTANCE ITS
JOB AT CENTER I CATEGORY- MADE
AVAILABLE- THROUGH THE MAJOR
DISASTER. THAT HAS BEEN BY THE
GOVERNOR SO WE'RE LEVERAGING
THOSE BUILT THAT PROGRAM TO BE
ABLE TO PROVIDE REIMBURSEMENT
TO OZ- AND THEN- THAT TIES IN
WITH. THIS WILL OPEN A STATE
FUNDING TO BE ABLE TO BACK UP
ALL OF THAT THE CDA OR THE
FOR A PRO. IS A STANDALONE.
YEAH THAT COURT SHOULD. THANK
YOU DRAW LET ME MAYBE DRE DOWN
THE LITTLE BIT MORE WASN'T SICK
IS FUNDED BY THE I THINK I WAS
SICK THAT SHE A SUPPLE THE
LOCKER MY UNDER. COSTS INCURRED
ONLY FOR INDIVIDUALS WHO TEST
POSITIVE INTEGERS WE'VE BEEN
EXPOSED INDIVIDUALS WHO ARE
ASYMPTOMATIC BUT OUR HIGH RISK-
SO THERE'S LIMITATIONS I GUESS
IS POINT AND WHAT THE SCENE YOU
KNOW AND I READ BOTH ONE COUNTY
THAT IS BELOW THE FIVE. I THINK
FOR THOSE COUNTIES SHOULDER
HAVE POTS OF MONEY THERE'S BEEN
SOME LEVEL BUT I AM A TO USE
BECAUSE BECAUSE PEOPLE A-
AROUND THE BUT KIND OF A PER
HOUR. OF X. I. SO I'M I'M PUT
ON THE TAPE. RUSSIAN AND RISK
FROM BOTH ARE WE A FINAL. IS A
WAY WE PERHAPS YOU SOME OF THE
FUNDING TO THE CARE ACTIVE FARM
ALONG WITH THE CDA CALL SHARE
TO MAYBE ALL PROBLEMS LET ME
LET ME MOVE IT THIS TO THE-
KERR'S ACT. YELL CAL WHAT TO
OVER BILLION ON THE CARE ACT
WOKE GOVERNMENTS WITH
POPULATIONS ARE FIVE ON A
THOUSAND AS WE DISCUSSED DIRECT
RECEIVING PAN FOR THE U. S.
THAT'S TWENTY TWO LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS CAL. WHAT THOSE
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS DOWN THEIR
DIRECT ANSWER REMAINING FONG
WILL BE A TO STATE. I'M
CERTAINLY THRILLED THAT I
GREATLY APPRECIATED IN STANNIS
COUNTY DE THAT DON'T EVEN.
NEARLY A HUNDRED DOLLARS
THROUGH THE FOR ARE FAIRLY
FLEXIBLE. THEY GO A LONG WAY
TOWARD TO. THESE ISSUES RAISING
NOW. HE CALCULATIONS I SEEN IN
A THAT THE LAW GUY. WERE OF.
COULD CLAY ROUGHLY SIX TO SEVEN
TO DOLLAR OF THAT FIFTEEN.
BILLION DOLLAR POT SO. WANT
DOES THE ADMINISTRATION PLAN TO
USE THE- EIGHT NINE BILLION
REALLY FOR. TO WHAT IS THE
ADMINISTRATION PLAN TO A COLD
IS LOCAL THAT DO NOT BE THE
FIVE HUNDRED PERSON METRIC. AND
THREE HOW WHEN HIS INITIAL
PLANNED NOTIFY GOVERNMENT
WITHOUT A CARE ACT PAYMENT IF
THEY WILL RECEIVING THIS FLAG
FIND. OR SOMETHING SO TO.
CIRCLE TO MY ABOUT CDA REAL.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER ON THAT CA
REIMBURSE I'D LIKE ON THAT
COLLEAGUES RISSO COMMENT JUSTIN
I'LL MAKE THE ON CARE IS A
MONDAY YOU KNOW IS TRUE THE
GOVERNOR STILL MAKING JUST FOR
WHAT HE WANTS TO FREDDIE USE
THAT STAY PART OF FUNDING WILL
BE SAYS YOU'RE- NINE. YES YEAH.
WHERE THE CONSTRAINTS ON THAT
STATE BUDGET ITSELF WHICH OF
COURSE WORK ON WITH ALL OF YOU
ASSEMBLY ISSUE SENATOR
DISCUSSED TODAY WHICH SCHOOL
THEN CORRECTIONS AND HEALTHCARE
AND SO WE ARE GOING TO DO OUR
BEST TO MEET OUR OWN
CONSTITUTIONAL MANDATES AND OUR
RESPONSIBILITY FOR ENTITLEMENT
PROGRAMS WHILE ALSO WORKING
WITH THE LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
BECAUSE WE UNDERSTAND THE
PRESSURES THAT WORKSTATION THE
DETAIL ON THE GOVERNOR POSING
STAND. OUT WILL AVAILABLE. JUST
A COUPLE WE- REGARD TO SEE.
WHERE ALTERNATE NUMBER TEACHER.
I THANK OUR FINANCE I'M NOT TOO
MUCH TO AT THIS POINT BUT WE
ARE WAY AGAIN AS NO THEY AWARE
NEW REGISTRATION REGARDING LOOK
GOVERNMENT IMPACTS JUST A
REITERATING THAT THE ARE A LOT
OF PIECES PLAYING THIS YOU AND-
SO THE QUESTION WILL BE.
SOMEONE WAS IS OR ANYTHING THAT
WOULD THE MYSTERY FROM IS.
ORDER THAT WOULD. FOR COUNTIES
THE FIVE HUNDRED THRESHOLD. TO
RESTORE Y. HUNDRED PER REMEMBER
THROUGH. I HAVE TO GET BACK TO
YOU ON THE EXACT ORDER YOU KNOW
I WANT TO THAT IT IN THEIR THE
LEGAL DECISION THEN THERE'S A-
HOW EVERY FITS INTO OUR OVER.
FISCAL PLAN. WHY WE WANT TO PUT
IT IN THE CAR. THE OVERALL
BUDGET EXACTLY KNOW I WOULD
HAVE. BUDGET REQUIREMENTS. WE
TO DO. WHAT WE CAN. WITHIN THAT
STRUCTURE. PUSH A LITTLE BIT ON
THAT REMIND YOU DOES OF US THAT
READ. RURAL COMMUNITY LOOKING
THIS CAN ROOM I. A SET AMOUNT
AND- THAT READ RULER. THAT
JURISDICTION'S THE DON'T MEET
THAT FOR HER DOES THRESHOLD
SUCH GOING RECEIVED FUNDING OUT
WERE OFTEN TOLD AND CALIFORNIA
THE WORD KERRY. AND LATER SO
NEVER NOT WILL COME. ADMIN AND
DISCOVER. FOR MAKING A MENTAL.
IN THOSE JURISDICTIONS THAT
FALL UNDER THE FIVE HUNDRED
THOUSAND I THINK IT WOULD
PROVIDE. SOME LEVEL OF
CERTAINTY THAT WOULD REDUCE ANY
PARALYSIS WORD WERE SEEING AS
FAR AS MOVING FORWARD ON SOME
OF THE- MANAGER LOCAL. THAT'S
WOULD BE FAIR CAN THE FIRST
ROUND FEDERAL WENT TO THE
LARGER URBAN AREAS LET ME
TRANSITION AT THIS POINT AND
TOUCH ON THE PROVIDER ISSUE
THAT BOTH DOCTOR WOULDN'T DR
RANDALL RAISED AS OUR IT'S TO
OUR BUDGET GOING FORWARD NOT SO
MUCH. WORDS AND- BEEN AROUND
THIS BUILDING NOW I REMEMBER-
THE LEGISLATIVE RESPONSE TO THE
GREAT RECESSION I REMEMBER THE
DIFFICULT DECISIONS- THEY WERE
BUT BEFORE BOTH THE EXECUTIVE
AND THE LEGISLATURE AT THAT
TIME. BUT THE CRISIS IS
ILLUSTRATED TO THE STATE THE
DIRE NEED TO NOT JUST. DO THE
STATUS QUO WHEN IT COMES TO.
INVESTMENTS OR PROVIDERS BUT
ACTUALLY MAYBE DOUBLE DOWN OUR
EFFORTS AND I REALIZE THAT'S
NEW SPENDING BUT I HOPE IT'S
NEW SPENDING THAT MY COLLEAGUES
AND GOVERNOR TAKE. SERIOUSLY I
LIVE IN MERCED COUNTY ONE OF
THE COUNTIES THAT SUFFICIENT OR
THE WORST PROVIDER SHORTAGES-
IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
THEN CAN ASSEMBLY CISCO HAVE
NEARLY THREE TIMES THE NUMBER
OF DOCTORS PER ONE HUNDRED
THOUSAND RESIDENTS THAT WE DO.
AND THAT. WRITER WHICH IS- EVEN
MORE DANGEROUS OBVIOUSLY DURING
A CRISIS LIKE THIS AND AGAIN I
AM FULLY- EYES WIDE OPEN AND
RECOGNIZED EVERYONE IN THE
STATE. IN THE COUNTRY. IS FIFTY
THIS YOUR ISSUE BLACK OF PP
SUPPLIES A LACK OF- HEALTH CARE
PROVIDERS. BUT THIS AGAIN
SHOULD EMPHASIZE TO US WE'VE
NOT DONE ENOUGH THE LAST
SEVERAL DECADES IN MAKING SURE
THAT THEY'RE ENOUGH NOR THIS.
PHYSICIANS NOTHING APPEARS.
COMING UP CRISIS I HOPE. WITH
THE MAYBE WITH THE TOP TO THE
BOTTOM. SOME THIS. GROUP AND
FIND A WAY AND THE WILL AN THE-
TO DOUBLE DOWN ON THAT
INVESTMENT. REGARDING CAN IN
MAY TOPIC AND THIS IS BEEN ON
MY MIND- AS WE STRUGGLE TO.
DEAL WITH THIS CRISIS AND- CAN
YOU PLEASE FACE HAVING- EARLY
RELEASE OF INMATES AND PERHAPS
SOME DISORGANIZATION TO THAT IS
DOCTOR WOULD. SEVERAL YEARS AGO
WE DID LEGISLATION HERE IN THIS
BODY- RELATIVE TO. WHAT WAS
DEEMED HOSPITAL PATIENT DUMPING.
AT LEAST STANDARDS IN PLACE
HOSPITALS TO EXERT STEPS YOU
MAY REMEMBER THIS TO- PRIOR TO
PUT SOMEONE ON THE STREET AND I
THINK I'VE CERTAINLY HAS
DIRECTED MY STAFF TO GO BACK
AND LOOK AT LEGISLATION AND
CONSIDER CRAFTING- A POLICY
SIMILAR WHERE WE CAN ASK CITIES
ARE IN. OTHERS TO HELP THIS ONE.
BOTH FIFTY COMMUNITIES SO I'D
LIKE TO PUT BEFORE EVERY FOR
CONSIDERATION. THE FINAL THING
I WANT TO RAISE. THE SPEED HI
DRAFT A LETTER EARLY IN THIS
CRISIS TO THE GOVERNOR-
RELATIVE TO THE LEFT WHICH IS
ENGAGEMENT WITH TASK FORCES ARE
WE'VE HAD SUBSEQUENT ONES WITH.
HIS ALL THIS WE'VE NOT. DRAW
THE CONCLUSION AND- TODAY'S
HEARING I HOPE WE CAN- DOUBLE
LEFFERTS TO ARRIVE AT THAT
INTERFACE. LEGISLATIVE I THINK
THE- DOCTOR. CLEAR THERE IS
ESSENTIAL IT THE LEGISLATURE
WITH THESE MEMBERS WE ARE
ACTUALLY SPOKESPERSONS FOR THE
STATE IN OUR DISTRICTS ARE ABLE
TO ENGAGE COMMUNITY AND BE AN
ASSET TO THE EXECUTIVE AS THEY
DEAL WITH THIS DIFFICULT- IN
CLOSING. I WANT TO ASK THE
DIRECTOR. WE'VE ASKED FOR
INFORMATION REPEATEDLY-
SPECIFIC INFORMATION NOT SO
MUCH HIGH LEVEL INFORMATION BUT
MORE SPECIFIC AND JUST TO MAKE
A POINT ONE OF THE SPECIFICS
PIECE PIECES OF INFORMATION.
SAYS REPEAT FOR IS ALL OF AS WE
RECEIVED PP SUPPLIES WHERE DID
THAT. THERE THERE ISN'T ALL
START TALKING. HERE THAT AGAIN
WIDE AYE AYES WIDE OPEN TOTALLY
AWARE THAT WE ARE ALL SUFFERING
FOR LACK OF SUPPLIES AND
APPRECIATE THE EFFORTS OF MADE
TO. RAMP UP PRODUCTION AND
RAMPANT. POSITION OF ADDITIONAL
SUPPLIES. BUT THAT LIST WAS NOT
PROVIDED- TO. EFFECT THAT IT
BECAUSE LIKE. HERE WITH THE
BUDGET COMMITTEE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE PROVIDED. A WE'LL HAVE
TO HAVE BUT OVERSEE HEARINGS
TO. INFORMATION AND- ILL AGAIN
I REALIZE PEOPLE WORKING AROUND
THE CLOCK THIS IS BEEN
TREMENDOUSLY STRESSFUL AND
DIFFERENT. WITH ADDED A
PERSONNEL BUT PLEASE ACCESS
BOLDEST OVERSIGHT COMMITTEE THE
G. O. COMMITTED HEALTH
COMMITTEE THE RESPECTIVE
MEMBERS SO THAT WE CAN HELP. ON
THAT IT IS FRUSTRATING AS CAN
BE THAT I KNOW MORE ABOUT
NUMBER VENTILATORS CALIFORNIA
SAY THE OTHER STATES THAT I DO
ABOUT THE NUMBER VENTILATORS
BEING SENT TO MY DISTRICT. AND
AGAIN I APPRECIATE WHAT THAT
MEANT TO BE MISCONSTRUED I
APPRECIATE THE GOVERNOR.
LEADERSHIP PRESS THE NEEDS OF
NOT JUST CALIFORNIA. AND I
THINK WE SHOULD ALL HAVE THAT.
BUT THE SAME TIME THE FULL
INFORMATION AND THE ACCESS TO
IT- I'D LIKE YOUR COMMITMENT
TODAY- DIRECTOR THAT WE CAN
COUNT ON. GET THAT INFORMATION
A LITTLE- QUICKER. AND DIRECT
AND MORE STIR GOING. FOR
SEPTEMBER THANKS FOR THE
OBSERVATION IN YOUR AND YOUR
REQUEST AND I'LL JUST. THAT
WILL CONTINUE TO TRY TO PROVIDE
AS MUCH INFORMATION AS WE CAN'T
DO AT. TO DO BETTER WHAT WHAT
YOU'RE LOOKING FOR. THANK YOU
AND ALL YOUR MY TIME THAT TO
THE CHAIR. THREE BRAVE MISS
SMITH. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN- IS REALLY DO CHAD
LIKE TO EXPAND A LITTLE BIT ON
WHAT MY COLLEAGUE MISTER GRAY
JUST- WITH DELVING INTO YOU
KNOW AS CHAIR OF OUR JOINT WITH
JUST ANY ON EMERGENCY
MANAGEMENT IT'S CLEAR. MOVE
POWER. COMMITTEE WERE AS AMOUNT
OF WORK TO DO ESPECIALLY WHERE
WE FIND OURSELVES AN
ENVIRONMENT WHERE THE FEDERAL
RESOURCES THE ANTICIPATED THAT
WOULD HAVE BEEN DEPLOYED IN
NATIONAL DEFENSE PRODUCTION ACT
AND THE LINING OF A LEDGE FROM
THE STREET FROM NATION LARGE.
FORMULA HAS LARGE AND SOME. IN
STERN IT'S PART AND THEN OF
COURSE READ OUT TO OUR FOR ON
THE OTHER SIDE THE KIND IN YOUR-
THAT'S THOUGH I FINE IT PER.
TROUBLING THAT WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT A ONE BILLION DOLLAR
CONTRACT FOR RESOURCES. THAT WE
DON'T DO TO AB AND I WANNA BE'S
ADDED TO THE FACT MINISTRATION
HAS CAN AND ON THE DILUTES
BALLS. FOR THOSE CONTRACTS WERE
WE JUST DISCUSSING THIS KLAY
RIGHT NOW. I WOULD ABSOLUTELY
THAT IS A STORY THAT. HE TOLD.
MY FEDERAL LEADERSHIP. HERE
EVERYONE WE ARE MY HOPE THAT WE
WILL CAN YOU WILL PLEASE A
LITTLE BIT MORE ON ONCE THOSE
COMMODITIES LEVERED WHAT IS
OKAY AND XIN OF THOSE PIECE
REYES THIS. THANK YOU FOR THE
QUESTION- SO- AS I MENTIONED-
WE HAVE A OF A VERY. WE HAVE A
PRO PLACES THE STATE EMERGENCY
MANAGEMENT SYSTEM. DID YOU CAN
RESOURCES A PROGRAM. I'M IN
FROM LOCAL JURIST IN THIS CASE
IT WOULD GO FROM HOSPITALS AND
TO THE PUBLIC HEALTH SYSTEM ALL
THROUGH THE MEDICAL HEALTH
COORDINATOR- OR THEIR COMMITTEE
THE EMERGENCY MANAGEMENT SYSTEM.
QUESTION COME UP- IT AND IF
THEY CANNOT BE FILLED AT THE
REGIONAL LEVEL THAN OF COURSE
THEY'VE COME UP WITH THE STATE-
WELL. DO YOU. HAVE A MEDICAL
HEALTH COORDINATION CENTER OF
THE NATION AND PRIORITIZATION
OF WHERE THE- I NEEDED MY-
BASED ON THE RESOURCES THAT WE
HAVE A THIS IS A STANDARD- A
PROCESS THAT WE HAVE IN PLACE
HERE IN CALIFORNIA WHEN WE
MANAGE- OF SCARCE RESOURCES
DURING HIS AT. AND WHY THIS
PROJECT- CONTRACT IN THIS
PIPELINE OF COMMODITIES SO
WHERE DOES IS THAT IT DOES
PROVIDE AS WITH- OF A RELIABLE-
AND SUSTAINABLE- SOURCE OF.
COMMODITIES THAT WE CAN OF
COURSE GET DOWN TO THE LOCAL-
AFTER THESE WORDS NEEDED MOST-
THIS IS CRITICAL FOR US BECAUSE
THROUGHOUT THE COURSE OF THIS
OF. THE CHALLENGES OF BEING
ABLE TO GET. HE FROM SOURCES
AROUND THE WORLD NOT JUST NOT
JUST FOR IT BUT EVEN DOMESTIC
SOURCES- HAS BEEN A HUGE
CHALLENGE AND AS I MET EARLIER
FOR ALL THIS THE ALL THE SAME
REASONS OF COMPETITION AND-
FRAUD AND MANY OF THE THINGS
THAT WE'VE BEEN SEEING
THROUGHOUT THE- THROUGHOUT THE
EVOLUTION OF THIS PROCESS. SO
ONCE WE GET THE COMMODITIES IN
WE WILL WE WILL OUR OUR PLAN IS.
THE AMOUNT OF TIME THAT THEY'RE
SITTING IN A- ELSE AND REALLY.
START PUSHING THOSE OUT OF
REALLY ALMOST AS SOON AS WE'RE
GETTING THEM- TO AREAS THERE.
ARE NO- ARE WE HAVE REQUESTED
ASSETS- WELL AS YOU KNOW WE
HAVE ALREADY PUSHED OUT SOME
FOR ALMOST FORTY SEVEN MILLION-
AND NINETY FIVE MASS AND
SURGICAL MASKS- TO ALL FIFTY
EIGHT COUNTIES- THROUGHOUT THE
STATE. AND AS WE ARE SOURCING
SOME- A SMALLER QUANTITIES AS
THEY COME IN. ALL FROM. WHEN
THEY COME UP OF ALL OF AN
CITIZENS ARE IN WITH A FELLOW
I'LL OPENED WERE WHERE IT'S
NEEDED AND AGAIN THIS IS A
WEIRD NEEDED LIKE MANY WHEN YOU
HAVE ME IF YOU LOOK AT THE
AREAS THAT ARE AT THE GREATEST
NEED WHERE ARE THE FIVE I TOOK
THE PROCESS. I TO A SOURCE ALL
THE HOSPITALS AND FIRST
RESPONDERS BUT- PRIORITIES ARE
GIVEN- THROUGH THAT PROCESS TO
WHERE. IT'S NEEDED MOST. THANK
YOU MISTER GELLER DIGIT MY NEXT
QUESTION IS FOR DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE AND- YOU KNOW IT'S
SECOND ONLY TO QUESTIONS ABOUT-
ASSESSING. EIGHT IN MY ARE SAID
THAT WE BONTA OUTSIDE FOR LOW
SMALL. SO THOSE LOOK TO DO THE
WORK OF ADVOCACY TO OUR ORAL
PART. MANY DID NOT. FOR
EMPLOYER WHO APPLIED ARE
WAITING FOR. THOSE PEOPLE.
RESOURCES OR DO WE HAVE AN S.
OF THE NEED BASED ON CALIFORNIA
PAYROLL NUMBERS BECAUSE I THINK
THIS. CRITICALLY IMPORTANT I
HAVE AN-IN MY MOST MY DOES.
ARE PERSONALLY LEFT. FIRST
TRENTE ONE PICTURE THAT I'M OUT
OF A ACTIVELY OF THE SECOND GOV.
SO ALL THAT ISSUE I'M GONNA
TURN OVER TO CHRIS SHALL WHO
HELPED NUMBERS THE FACT.
FUNDING. HI THERE HI CHRIS
SHOPS OF FINANCE. I AM WE
RECEIVED AN UP IN TERMS OF THE
NUMBER AS IS. WHO FOR THE PAPER
TAX ONE. AND AS OF THE SIX I
HAVE A ALL AND HAVE A HAVE
TWELVE ALMOST A HUNDRED AND
THIRTEEN THOUSAND SMALL. SO
UNDER FIVE HUNDRED SAID OF. AS
LITTLE OVER THIRTY POINT FOUR
AND DOT IN CALIFORNIA. WE
FORTUNE TO HAVE THE DATE OR
TIME INFORMATION IN. ON HOW. BE
ABLE TO GET THAT. OUR GET A LOW.
AND YOU KNOW WE'RE CONTINUING
TO PURSE ADDITION FUNDING FOR
THIS IN THIS VALUABLE
PROGRAMMING BUT- THANK YOU SO
IF BUT IF YOU DO IT ANY MEANS A
MECHANISM WHICH TO MAKE THAT
ESTIMATE OR IS THAT JUST SIMPLY
YOU KNOW MAYBE I CAN OF LOCAL
CHAMBERS OF. OUR COMMUNITY BANK
I THINK IT'S URGENTLY IMPORTANT
THAT WE ASSISTANCE OF WERE AT
GETTING AND THIS NEXT ROUND SO
NOT PEOPLE BEING LEFT OUT. IS
TO KEEP. WE WOULD HAVE TO ADD
FROM AT PERHAPS WE CAN TALK TO
OUR GOVERNOR'S OFFICE OF
BUSINESS AND ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT TO SEE IF THEY HAVE
KIND OF SMALL BUSINESS NOT IN
TERMS OF WHAT YOUR GOALS AND OR
ELIGIBLES BUT APPLY. HAVE NOT
HAVE NOT BACK AND. AND WE WOULD.
CALIFORNIA'S APPLIQUE. AND AS
FOR OUR A FEW. THOUGH NOT A SIX
AS PARTICULAR. THANK YOU MUCH
MR CHERRY A BACK MY TIME. THANK
YOU MISTER. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN. A LOT OF HIS OSCAR
ABOUT A COVERED. DURING HEARING
BECAUSE ALL I'LL STICK TO A
COUPLE SPECIFIC ONES. AGAIN AS
WAS BY MY COLLEAGUES YOU ALL
HARD WORK SIT IN GERMAN THE
WEEK AFTER EXT. I THINK WHAT'S
DIFFERENT ABOUT THIS CAR. ONCE
WE- SURE. THE USE SHOULD MEN
STATE GOVERNMENTS HAVE BUSINESS
YOU'VE EVER ENTERED INTO AND SO.
THE NEED TO ACCURATE
INFORMATION CONSTITUENTS ON
WHAT WAS ACTUALLY HAPPENING WAS
TOUGH. I REMEMBER ONE DAY A
WOMAN IN ORDER TO PUT ON
FACEBOOK THAT ORANGE COUNTY
SEVEN PM TO PM CURVE. NO THEY
DON'T DID STOP FOR. PATIENT SO
THAT IT SEEMS THE BEGINNING OF
IT LET ME ASK YEAH THERE IS OF
MARCH TWENTY SEVENTH. LA TIMES
STORY- THAT ABOUT. HELLO TO TWO
THOUSANDS THAT CALIFORNIA HAD
BUILT A LARGE SUPPLY OF. THE
MILLION AND NINETY FIVE
RESPIRATORS TWENTY FOUR HUNDRED
VENTILATORS KIT SET UP FOR
TWENTY ONE THOUSAND ADDITIONAL
PATIENT BEDS WHENEVER- THIS ALL
WAS DISBANDED BEFORE ANYBODY ON
THIS COMMITTEE OR IT ASSEMBLY
WAS ELECTED TO DO YOU HAVE ANY
HISTORICAL. KNOWLEDGE OF WHY
THOSE AS WERE SAYS THEY WERE
BOUGHT FOR THE AVIAN FLU
OUTBREAK TO BE. SURE SHE- OKAY.
THANKS FOR THE CALL THE ARE
WELL ME JUST START OFF SAYING
NOT NOT ABOUT A BIG PORTION OF
AS I UNDERSTAND IT- THE- ISSUES
WITH THE OP ALL COMMODITIES OR
TALK ABOUT HOW TO DO IT FOR
ASIAN THE BILL THEIR TIME. LIFE
IN THE BILL TO MAINTAIN ALL
OVER THE COURSE THE THERE WERE
SOME THAT WERE UP YOU MY OF THE
MATCH. IN CASE OF ASKED WE HAD
LIKE WHEN WE USED SIX ADDRESS
ALL WE USE SOME SHALL. LARGE
NUMBERS OF THE COMMODITIES TO
SUPPORT- CATASTROPHIC FIRE
DISASTERS- AND- AND SOME SOME-
ALL I. SIMPLY JUST THEM OR LOST
THEIR SHELF LIFE ANDI THINK-
ALL OVER THE YEARS. THE FOCUS-
WAS TO. TAKE SOME OF THOSE
COMMODITIES AND REPURPOSE THEM
IT ALSO SUPPORTED REGIONAL
CAPABILITIES BY PUSHING THEM
THAT OUT BY PREVIOUS THAT A
PART OF THE STATE LEVEL AND
PLOT OUT YOUR LOCAL PARK. OR
GUARD. SOME OF THE MODERN THANK
YOU. BY THE WAY OTHER WORDS
LAUGH OR THAT WHERE DID THE IN
SOME FOR. AND A SOME TO
SOMETHING MILLION MASS THAT WE
HAD A- ALL OF THAT HAVE BEEN
YOU HOW YOU LIVE UP. BENT IS IT
PART YOU'RE PLANNING THIS TO HE
SOME THE ORDER WERE CURRENTLY
DOING TO BUILD BACK UP THAT
STATE STOCKPILE. THIS OKAY LET
ME US ON THE CONTRACT HAS BEEN-
ABOUT A LITTLE BIT SO YOU DON'T
NEED TO CONTRACT TO KNOW YOU
WELL PAID FIVE DOLLARS A MASK-
IT. IS THAT A GOOD EIGHT. IT
LOOKS LIKE FANS GOT EM AND
HONEYWELL WILL YOU DO IT FOR
LESS THAN A DOLLAR I SEE SOME
OTHER CONTRACTS AS HIGH AS
ALMOST EIGHT DOLLARS I WENT
INTO THE NEGOTIATION ON THE-
MASK. I REALLY COMMENT ON- WEAR
OUT ON UP FOR MASS COST- I CAN
TELL YOU THAT- WE BELIEVE THAT
THE TEAM THAT NEGOTIATED TO GET
A- VERY GOOD PRICE UP. THE
TIME. OF THE- GOSHI ASIANS- WE
SAW MASKS. AT ITS HIGHEST
TWELVE DOLLARS- AVERAGE OF
ABOUT SEVEN DOLLARS. AND THE
QUESTION PRICE FOR THESE MASS I
THINK WILL BENEFIT THE STATE WE
TOOK INTO ACCOUNT MANY THINGS
ASSOCIATED WITH THAT- IN
PARTICULAR- WITH THE VOLUME OF
THE MASTER GETTING TO GET- WILL
BE WE THOUGHT WAS A FAIR. DID
YOU GO OUT IF YOU GO OUT TO
BETTER WAS IT. LIKE A SOLE
SOURCE CONTRACT WITH THE
COMPANY OR HOW TO HOW TO GO
DOWN. PARTICULAR ENTITY- WAS SO
SOURCE OF LET ME BE CLEAR THAT-
YOU KNOW- AGAIN OF THE
WORLDWIDE- A SHORTAGE. A
COMPETITION OUT THESE ASSETS IN
THE INABILITY. TO BE ABLE TO
PRODUCE THIS DOMESTICALLY THIS
PARTICULAR SET OF ITEMS- IN
FACT THE SUPPLIER OF ALL THIS
PP EITHER WE'RE TALKING ABOUT
ARE ALL CHINA BASED AND YOU
KNOW. THIS IS THIS THAT THE
CHALLENGES THAT WE FACE IN
CALIFORNIA WE'RE NOT UNIQUE TO
CALIFORNIA THIS HAPPENED IN
EVERY STATE IN THE UNITED
STATES. AS WELL AS THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT AS WELL AS THE MAJOR
PROVIDERS F COMMODITIES SINCE
OUR EMMETT. ALL OF THESE-
ENTITIES WHAT WERE IN THE SAME
EXACT POSITION. AND THEN OF
COURSE- BEGAN A OF GRACIOUS-
EFFORT TO OF FINE COMMODITIES-
AT WHICH THEY PUT A IN A
MASSIVE AMOUNT OF COMPETITION.
THAT THE POINT IS IN A POSITION
WHERE WE NEED TO REALLY A
UTILIZED EVERY CAPABILITY THAT
WE COULD IN CALIFORNIA I TO BE
ABLE TO GET WHAT WE NEED IT. IT
WAS REALLY- OF EXISTING
RELATIONSHIPS ARE THAT WE HAD
AND THE BUYING POWER OF THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA ARE SIZING
AND IN SCALE OUGHT TO BE ABLE
TO LEVERAGE ALL OF THAT IT WILL
BE ABLE TO GET THAT THE THINGS
WE NEEDED AND LET AGAIN LET'S
BE CLEAR. THESE ARE LIFESAVING
DEVICES. THIS CALL THESE ARE CA
IN. THE LIVES OF OUR HELP
WORKERS AND OTHERS AND- YOU
KNOW WHEN YOU'RE IN THE HEAT OF
THE BATTLE- AND YOU'RE TRYING
TO WORK THROUGH ALL THESE
ISSUES ARE THE INTENT IS TO- DO
WHAT WE CAN BE ABLE TO ADDRESS
WHAT ANY S. AND- AGAIN- ALL WE
WILL WHAT WHAT WHAT WHAT TIME
WHEN THE COURSE OF TIME CORRECT
WILL RELEASE AND IN NOT YOU'LL
FIND THAT THE- PRICE. WAS A WAS
A GOOD BE A CIRCUS. SIR WELL
THE REASON FOR MY LINE OF
QUESTIONING IS BECAUSE I'M FACT
SHEET FROM B. Y. DE AND FROM OF
ME THAT SO THEY ARE A WORLD
LEADER IN ELECTRIC VEHICLE
BATTERY SOLAR AND STORAGE
MANUFACTURING. I WON THIS
CRISIS BROKE OUT BY THE WAY-
10% OWNED BY WARREN BUFFETT'S
BERKSHIRE HATHAWAY AND WHEN
THIS CRISIS BROKE OUT. THEY
ROUTED THEIR MANUFACTURING
RETOOL THAT SO WE COULDPRODUCES MUCH PP FOR HEALTH
CARE WORKERS THERE'S A LOT OF
COMPANIES IN CALIFORNIA ACROSS
THE COUNTRY THEY'RE DOING THE
SAME THING SO I WOULD JUST
SUGGEST NEXT TIME WE HAVE A LAW.
OF TIME AND MONEY THAT WE LOOK
OVER THE COULD BE ALL OVER THE
STATE TO STOP WEARING TA GIVEN
THE GOV YOU ACCESS MONEY IF WE
COULD FOR ALL OF US COMPANIES
TO SPEND MONEY ON SO JUST FOR
WITH THESE LARGE CONTRACTS I
HOPE TO YOU IT UP BROTHER
NOBODY'S. SOME MONEY. IN IN THE
IN THE VISION THAT'LL GIVE US
SOME GUIDANCE GOING FORWARD
WITH THE TAX STATE PUSH TO JULY
FIFTEENTH DO YOU ENVISION A
POTENTIAL AUGUST REVISION-
SEEING THE RATE OF TAX DOLLARS
TO COME INTO THE STATE. SO THE
TAXI BEING PUSHED THAT
DEFINITELY AFFECTS THE STATE'S
CASH FLOW AND SO ONE THING
THAT. I FIND THAT VERY BUSY
BERMAN THE LAST SEVERAL WEEKS
WORKING WITH THE COMPTROLLER'S
OFFICE IS MAKING SURE THAT WE
HAVE- SUFFICIENT CASH QUESTION
OVER THE NEXT TWELVE MONTHS
INTEL SOME OF THAT CASH COMES
BACK AND- ON JULY FIFTY. COMES
TO THE BROADER WHEN THEY'RE NOT
HAVE TO BE AND IT NO BUDGET
DISCUSSION AFTER JUNE FIFTEENTH
AFTER THE FISCAL YEAR STARTS ON
JULY FIRST IT'S HARD TO SAY
RIGHT NOW BECAUSE THERE IS SO
MUCH UNCERTAINTY AND THE FACT
THAT SOME. THINGS WILL BE
DELAYED FOR JULY I CREATE
UNCERTAINTY BECAUSE WE FIVE AND
ON THE RIGHT AND UNITS INTO THE
STATE TO MAKE OUR ESTIMATES ALL
THAT BEING SAID OUR TEAM IS
HARD AT WORK RIGHT NOW IT.
PROJECTIONS THAT WE KNOW HOW.
THE HELL SITUATION AND IT'S OF
ALL THEY'RE GOING TO COURSE
BEEPER ABOUT SOME THAT AND BE.
OF THIS HEARING IN TERMS OF THE
MODEL AND HOW WE ARE ALL OF IT
AND ALSO THE ECONOMIC IMPACTS
WHERE WORSE WORK WHERE WE ARE
BIG. ON OUR OWN BUT WE'RE ALSO.
NATIONAL AND GLOBAL. SO WE'RE
TAKING NATIONAL AND GLOBAL
ECONOMIC DATA INDICATORS AND-
BRING THAT INTO OUR MODEL
WITHOUT REVENUE FOR CASTING
TEAMS SO WHAT WILL- PROPOSAL.
FOR CHEAP. HE ON A DESTINED FOR
MAYES. PROJECTIONS ON HOW HE
EXPECTS RENDON YEARS AND NOT
PROPER STATE ECONOMY TO GO.
SHOULD IT HAPPEN THAT AFTER MAY
FOURTEENTH IN JUNE AND JULY AND
AUGUST WE HAVE. NO INFORMATION-
THAT MAY REQUIRE ADDITIONAL
ASSISTANCE TO THE BUDGET IT'S-
POSSIBLE THAT THOSE ADJUSTMENTS
CAN HAPPEN NUMBER AS JUST.
THANK YOU. FOR MUCH OF THE FOR
THING ON SAID JUST LIKE ECHO
THE- OF THE VICE DON WOULD
MISTER IS. YOU KNOW. IS JUST A-
THE PART ABOUT THE GOVERNOR
EXECUTIVE ORDER TO CLOSE DOWN
RESTAURANTS FROM THE MEDIA AND
THEN I. SURE I WOULD JUST HOPE
THAT THE FREE FLOW OF
INFORMATION COULD BE PROVIDED
TO US BECAUSE WE ARE ON THE
FRONT LINES OF STOPPED WOULD
SET FOR A CONCERT. AND WE CAN.
COULD IT FOR ME. YOUR PARTNER
AS WE ARE IN THIS GOVERNMENT SO
THANK YOU ALL FOR YOUR. THANK
YOU MISTER BUSH THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR I AM KEENLY AWARE
THAT I THINK I'M THE ONLY THING
BETWEEN US AND LUNCH- AND I'VE
GOT A LITTLE MINI SOCCER GOING
ON UNDER THIS MASK SO- I'LL TRY
TO. X. AS SEPARATE POSSIBLE IN
AS MUCH. AS AS QUICKLY AS I CAN
I'M ON THE TOPIC OF THE- THE B.
Y. DE CONTRACT A ON OF ALL I.
CONGRATULATE THE CREATION ON
BEING ABLE TO CLOSE A DEAL
ITEMS THERE TO SAYING THAT THE
TERM CONTRA RIGHT YOU DOCTOR
POINT THAT. OF I THESE ROOMS
ARE PROBABLY BE KEPT TO A
CONFIDENTIAL- AT THE URRENT
TIME AND AT THE AT THE PRESENT
TIME- AND WILL HAVE AN
OPPORTUNITY TO DO A LOT OF THE
BRIEFING GOT A AND THE FUTURE
THERE'S A LOT OF WORK THAT. TO
BE ON THE BUT WHAT TO THE
CONTRACT MY UNDERSTANDING IS
THAT OF PRODUCT- IS SUPPOSED TO
BEGIN BEING DELIVERED BY THE
END OF THE PLOT THE WAR ONLY
TEN MONTHS TEN DAYS AWAY FROM
FROM THAT TIME- THE FIRST
QUESTION- PART ONE IS ARE WE
STILL. CONTRACT TO RISK
DELIVERIES TO AND HOW MUCH CAN
WE EXPECT TO BE DELIVERED AT
THAT TIME. AND THE- OTHER ONE I
READ A LOT I'M SURE MY
COLLEAGUES HAVE TO ABOUT TO THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT THE FBI IN
PARTICULAR STEP IN IT ACTUALLY.
INTERCEPT SLOW DOWN THE
DELIVERY P. AND I'M WONDERING
IF THERE ARE CONVERSATIONS ON
GOING. OUT NOW WITH FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT TO. AVOID BEHALF
THANKS TO THIS IMPORTANT. A
SUPPLY. OUR COUNTING ON A IT
I'M A WOULD POINT OUT THAT
THESE ARE MATERIALS THAT ARE
SOUGHT OUT OF ACROSS THE GLOBE
AND THROUGH EVERY CORNER OF THE
UNITED STATES AND- SHOULD THIS
WORK OUT AS WE ARE EXPECTED TO.
OF THE PRICE WE'RE PAYING IT
SECONDARY TO THE- A SAFETY OF
THE PEOPLE WILL BE PROTECTED TO
WITH WITH THAT THIS MATERIAL
THAT SAID TO. THOSE TWO
QUESTIONS PLEASE ON THE ON THIS
TOPIC. BUT SEVEN ONE THANK YOU
FOR THE QUESTION AND THANK YOU
FOR THE DEMOLITIONBUT IT'S
ASSEMBLY MEMBER. WELL AS
ANDERSON MEMBER. WELL THAT'S
OKAY WELL LET ME JUST SAY- ON
THE ON THE ON THE ON THE- CASE
ME BACK INTO IT AND SAY ON THE
CASE OF THE FBI AND AT LAKE
ISSUES LIKE ON THIS PROJECT. WE
HAVE. BEEN WORKING VERY CLOSELY
WITH OUR PARTNERS AT SHE NOT.
TO ENSURE THAT- THAT THAT THAT
THIS CONTRACT. RECEIPT AS
SMOOTHLY- AND AS EFFECTIVELY AS
POSSIBLE THAT HAS INCLUDED. A
COLLAPSE EFFORT ALL. UP AND
DOWN. THE CHAIN I GUESS YOU
COULD SAY- FROM FROM THEM BEING
OUT PART OF. THE OVERALL.
CONTRACT A DEVELOPMENT OF. NEW
TO. HOW SIMS IMPORT PROTECTION.
HELD HOW THE TSA. ALL OF THOSE
WOULD BE ENGAGED. COMING OR
YEAH IT IS. US IMMEDIATELY
SPIED A CAN CAN BENEFIT OTHER
NEEDS OF THE OF THE IS WELL IN
THE REGION SO THIS IS A OF THAT
IS HOW STREAM THAT WE ALL HAD
NO THAT OF CASES THERE ARE BEEN
SHIPPED IN ANOTHER CAR. WITH
THE TEAM AND WITH STEAM OUT- TO
ENSURE THAT OUR SUPPLY CHAIN IN
THIS PARTICULAR ENDEAVOR
REMAINS- YOU KNOW WHAT WE
EXPECT AND THEN THE SECOND PART
OF THE QUESTION- WE CURRENTLY
DO BACK TO THE TIME FRAMES THAT
BEEN MADE. OUR OF THE CAR. ONE
KEY THING I. IMPORTANT TO KNOW
HOW. IS THE- OF THE MASS. ARE
THAT THEY MEET THE CDC DIE
OFSHE STANDARDS OF FOUR FOUR
AROUND ACTUALLY. AND THAT'S
THAT IS A REQUIREMENT THAT. THE
ENTITY THAT IS THAT IS
PROVIDING THE MANUFACTURERS
PROVIDING US UP AS IT COMES IN.
OKAY WOULD WITH THE- WHAT
THEY'RE MADE OF FAT EACH DAY I
WAS A ACTUALLY CONVERSATION
WITH- THE- BOB AT TWELVE
O'CLOCK LAST NIGHT. START IT'S
WE BELIEVE THAT ALL GOES SMOOTH
WE SHOULD BE GETTING THESE
COMMODITIES COMING IN OF
STARTING UP HERE NEXT WEEK YEAH
WE CAN START TO GET THOSE
DISTRIBUTED OUT THE COMMUNITY
IS POSSIBLE AND MORE LIKE. TO
SEE OF. THE SURGICAL MASKS
INITIALLY ALL BY THE END NINETY
FIVE MASSES WHAT THE PLAN WILL
BE- MOVING FORWARD. THANK YOU I
WANT TO ECHO THE CONCERNS THAT
WERE EXPRESSED BY MY COLLEAGUES
ABOUT THE- FINANCIAL PRESSURE
ON A HOSPITALS SO AND TO CARE
PERSON AFTER. I AM THESE ALLIED
HEALTH CARE. HOUSE I DON'T NEED
TO BELABOR THE POINT BUT I
THINK CUT OF THAT- GOING
FORWARD THE- WE'RE GOING TO
NEED TO ADDRESS THOSE ISSUES
AND I HOPE THAT WERE BEING IT'S-
THANK ABOUT UP. TO ADDRESS THEM
NOW. I'M I ALSO WANT TO ECHO
THE CONCERNS OF MY COLLEAGUES-
THAT WERE EXPRESSED ABOUT- THE-
LACK OF FUNDING FOR SMALLER
CITIES IN THE A AND A COUNTIES
IN THE CARE. PROGRAM WE'LL BE
ABLE TO SUCCESSFULLY- RECEIVE
FUNDS FOR THE SMALLER CITIES- I
DON'T THINK THAT THIS IS A OF A
RURAL VERSES SO- BEEN ISSUE I
AND IN MY DISTRICT- I REPRESENT
OF BOTH THE LARGEST CITY IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA LOS ANGELES
FROM MY CONSTITUENTS RESIDE
THERE AND ALSO FIVE SMALLER
CITIES THE LARGEST OF WHICH
NINETY. MOST OF HIS AROUND.
THIRTEEN I JUST GOT ISSUE
INVOLVING CUT OF THE COVERED
NINETEEN CRISIS. OF THE
ECONOMIC IMPACT CUTS ACROSS
EVERY INDIVIDUAL IN EVERY CITY
IN EVERY SECTOR OF THE ECONOMY-
AND THE- SO I THINK ARE WE NEED
TO BE. OF A COUNTRY ON ABOUT
NOW FOR ONE ANOTHER. EVERY ONE
OF IN THE STATE. I HAVE A-
ABOUT THE- THE GOVERNORS SO
WAIVER OF FOR A FIFTY THOUSAND
DOLLARS IN SALES TAX SO- OF FOR
TWELVE CENTS. SOME IT'S WORKED
VERY WILL CONTACT AND I
UNDERSTAND WERE ORK COMES FROM
AND I THINK BALLOT. NUMBER
BUSINESSES BUT IT'S I'M NOT.
CONCERN AMONGST LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS WHO RECEIVE A
PORTION OF THAT SALES TAX AND
NOW- WILL BE RECESSED TOGETHER
AND IT'S LIKE GOING TO MAKE
BECAUSE ONGOING FINANCED SIR.
NOT MUCH WORK SEN AND QUESTION
IS THE PLAN TO PROVIDE A BACK
FILL OR TO ADDRESS THAT ISSUE
SOME OF. THESE SO THAT TO- THEY
DON'T HAVE TO. CUT EVEN MORE.
GOING TO HAVE TO.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER ROOM I'LL SPEAK%
BRIEFLY YES- AND THEN I NAY
TURNED OVER TO MY COLLEAGUE
EIGHTY JARVIS AS WELL I THINK
FIFTY DOLLAR EXEMPTION FOR
FIFTY THOUSAND DOLLARS
CERTAINLY. THE ARE YOU SURE.
SMALL BUSINESSES ARE THE WAY IT
WAS STRUCTURE IT IS NOT AT
FAULT FOR MONTH REPRIEVE IT'S
RATHER IT ACTS. THOUSAND LITTLE
BIT LASSEN LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
THAT OTHERWISE WOULD BE. THAT
BEING SAID YOU ARE CORRECT WE
UNDERSTAND. THIS IS A PRESSURE
SO WE ARE CERTAINLY AWARE AS
FOR CONSTRUCTING OUR NEIGHBOR
VISION AND AS WE WORK WITH
CITIES AND CAL BASED ON THE-
THAT. THIS. FIND A PARTNERSHIP
WITH THEM OR THAT THEY RUN WITH
LEADERSHIP FROM US THAT WE ARE
WORKING WITH THEM CHECK MAKE
SURE THAT THEY CAN NOW THROUGH
WHAT IS REALLY ON ACROSS
SITUATION. NUMBER EIGHTY DOT ME.
TO THANK. SURE THIS IS AMY
JARVIS I'M ASSOCIATE IS I AM
WORKING ON THIS PLAN AND IT'S
BUSINESSES WITH LESS THAN FIVE
MILLION DOLLARS THE ANNUAL
TAXABLE SALES THAT HAVE THE
ABILITY TO REFER THOSE PAYMENT
I WE CERTAINLY. THIS IS
IMPACTING FLOW TO CAO. I
DIRECTLY FOR THEIR THE CELLS
AS THE SALES AND USE TAX THAT A
TRIP TO. THAT STATE. FUNDS SO
ARE WORKING CLOSELY THEM I'M AT
MY POTENTIAL ALL. AND I THINK
IS THAT IT EARLIER AND THERE A
LOT OF IN. AND WE HAVE WITH OF
STATE LEVEL BUT ALL RECORD THAT
WE WANT TO OF LOCAL GUY LET. TO
THE THAT WERE EIGHT. SCHOOL BY
LIMIT THAT WE. THANK YOU AND
LIKE TO MOVE NOW TO OF THE IS
OF TEN. THE IT IT IT'S QUITE
THAT TAG IT'S GOING TO BE SOME
BE WE HAVE. THE CAPABILITY TO
DO. ATTACHED ON THE LAW THAT TO
BE REQUIRED TO. UGH OBTAINED
DATA THAT WALL ALLOW US TO
START. HE SOME OF THE STAYED
HOME RESTRICT OF SOME. THE OF A
LACK OF TESTING KITS WHICH IS I
THINK THE ADDRESS FIRST AND
BEING CHEN UP BUT AS AS WE SEE
IS A- BY THE FACT AS WAS OR
THAT ARE SHORTAGES OF SWABS AND
TO AND OTHER MATERIAL THAT ARE
NECESSARY TO. COMPLETE THE
TESTS. AB THEN WE HAVE A AND IN
SEROLOGY- TESTING OF WHICH HAS
YET TO BE PROVEN- AND- SO IN
THE NEAR TERM- THAT'S NOT
REALLY AVAILABLE TO US ON ALL A
LARGE SCALE BASIS EITHER. OF
THE ONE THING THAT HAVE BEEN
DISCUSSED AS CONTACT TRACING
WHICH IS OLD SCHOOL- TECHNOLOGY
IF YOU WILL. UP TO SIX. THAT IT
IS SAID IN. THE NUMBER OF WHO
WILL BE OUT IN THE FIELD OF
MAKING CONTACT. WITH PEOPLE WHO
OF I HAVE FOR A COOK NINETEEN
AND- FOLLOWING UP WITH THOSE
PEOPLE TO SEE WHO THEY BEEN IN
CONTACT WITH- THIS IS HOW
PANDEMICS IN THE PAST HAVE BEEN
ADDRESSED IT'S A- OF. A KNOWN
TO WORK AND SO MY QUESTION NAG
A IS ARE WE CONSIDERING
FUNDING- EFFORTS. OF CALIFORNIA
THAT WILL. AT LEAST GIVE US A
START NOW OPEN. THANK YOU AT
SOME MEMBER IS MY MAKE SURE THE
CALIFORNIA HELPING HUMAN
SERVICES AGENCY ON THE TEST
COMPONENT WE ARE ACTIVELY
WORKING ON INCREASING OUR
TESTING AFTER THE PROCESS STATE
I AM IN AREAS. I WHAT I WILL
CALL WE TESTING IN THE SAN THAT
WE- HAVE PROTESTED CAPABILITIES
OUT WE KNOW. SINGLE DAY WERE IN
OUR TESTING OF BALK WITHIN OUR
HEALTH CARE DELIVERY SAID. WELL
SET ASIDE OF HEALTH CARE
RECESSED. BUT WE HAVE A LOT
MORE WORK AHEAD OF US TO CHIEF
THAT I IN TERMS OF YOUR SECOND
CUP AROUND KIND TRACY YORK THAT
A PUBLIC HEALTH AT THAT IS YOU
QUITE FREE. IT IS ACTUALLY
COMMON ONE I'M THINKING SLASH
CASH REGULAR BECAUSE FOR
EXAMPLE WHERE WE ACT CON THE
INTO WHO IT INFECTED AND MAKE
SURE WE ARE ALSO AT THE WHO
MIGHT BE EXPOSED TO THAT
INDIVIDUAL I MONITOR THEM FOR
SYMPTOMS THEY CAN BE A. THE
GOVERNOR ASKED WILL ISSUE TO
ASK. DECATUR'S LOOKING AT HOW
YOU MODIFY THE NON
PHARMACEUTICAL IN. SO WE HAVE
INTO TODAY. AS OF THAT IN IN
ONE WE OUT PLAN TO MAP. OUR
EFFORTS CON TRACY SO THE GUY
AND THE- HAVE COMMITTED
PROVIDING I JUST THE GENERAL.
WITH WEEKLY UP. ON THAT. AND SO
WE LOOK FOR GAUGING THAT AND
BRING WITH. AVAILABLE TO
ACTUALLY DO THAT WORK THERE ARE
MANY MANY QUALIFIED TO-
INDIVIDUALS OUT THERE WHO ARE
NOT WORKING OUT OF THE
WORKFORCE IS CERTAINLY THERE
THAT WE COULD. CALL UPON
COMMENTED. OF THE- TERRIBLE
CRISIS THAT WE'VE HAD TO- IN-
OF PP AND- AND OTHER EQUIPMENT-
IT'S QUITE CLEAR THAT WE HAVE
ISSUES THAT WE HAVE TO DEAL
WITH IN THE FUTURE AROUND
PROCUREMENT AND TO. PROVIDING A
SECURE SUPPLY CHAIN OF AND I
THINK- BECAUSE OF. IN IN THE
FUTURE WE SHOULD BE TALKING
BOUT OF A DISCRETE FUNDING
SOURCE SO THAT WE KNOW OF THAT
THE FUNDING IS THERE WHO OP
MINUTE LEE- CREATE A SYSTEM
WHERE WE DON'T HAVE THIS KIND
OF- IN THE FUTURE TO IT'S QUITE
DISTURBING I THINK FOR EVERYONE.
JUST YOUR OFF ON THE TREE AND
THIS IS THE WORLD. THAT THE-
OUR THINGS THAT ARE VERY TO
RISK TO THIS DOWN WERE SIMPLY
NOT OF IN THE NECESSARY
QUANTITIES AND SO THAT'S
SOMETHING THAT WE DEFINITELY
NEED TO WORK ON. THE ADDRESS
CREATED A BUSINESS TASK OF HOW
WHICH I'D YEAH GENERALLY THINK
IS A THING OF BUT IVORY SOME A
NO OF CONCERN AND MY COMMUNITY
THEY MIGHT BE REFLECTED
ELSEWHERE IN THE STATE AS WELL
THAT SMALL BUSINESS NOT REALLY
WERE LIKE THAT IN THAT. IN A. I
TWO FIVE GREAT CAUSE TO EVERY
IN THE STATE THAT SMALL THE-
ROLE IN THE STATE OF. INSTEAD
OF COLLAPSED AND THE NEW TO BE
PART OF THE- ABOUT HOW BRING
THE A CON BACK. ON BECAUSE
ECONOMY COMES BY. CALIFORNIA
AND ON. YEAH MISTER WILL I CAN
CERTAINLY SAY FOR THE ADMIN I
KNOW IT'S EASIEST IN THE
HEARINGS SAY THE EVERYTHING A
TALK BUT FROM DIRECT CON THAT
WE'VE ALL WITH THE GOVERNOR THE
SENIOR TEAM OUT SMALL BUSINESS
BOTH IN TERMS FIXING THE P. FOR
AND THAT THE FEDERAL BUT ALSO
HELPING THE SMALL BUSINESSES IN
THE STATE REALLY IS A TOP
NUMBER FOR THE MANY BUT IT WILL.
ASK FORCE I HAVE THAT THE LIST
AT. NUMBER IN FRONT OF ME SO
WE'D LIKE TO DEFINITELY AT
BRING AT FEEDBACK THAT YOU HAVE
SEX IN TERMS OF YOU KNOW WHO
THEY NEED MAKE SURE THAT THEY
REACH OUT. TO MAKE SURE THAT
ALL CRISP ARE. RIGHT BUT MAKING
SURE THAT SMALL. GET THE HELP
THEY NEED OUT WILL BE A CRIME
AVERAGE ON THAT TIME FORCE
WHICH THE OF FINE. AND THE
GOVERNOR OFFICE OF BUSINESS
ECONOMICS WILL BE THERE CLOSELY
WEST I BELIEVE THAT THERE. PLAN
IS PUT OUT ABOUT. TERM I
RECOMMEND. OVER THE NEXT A AS
WELL. TIONS AND THAT. BROUGHT.
THE STORE- LEVELS OF
UNEMPLOYMENT TO THAT WE'RE
EXPERIENCING IN THE STATE RIGHT
NOW- AND THAT'S MADE IT
IMPOSSIBLE FOR MANY PEOPLE. TO
MAKE THE RENT PAYMENT AND THAT
TURNED AYE IS AFFECTING- MANY
LANDLORDS AROUND THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. ARE THERE ANY PLANS
IN THE WORKS FOR- A STATEWIDE
RENTAL ASSISTANCE THAT WOULD
HELP TO ALLEVIATE THAT PROBLEM.
SO ON THIS YEAR THAT THE RENT
THAT RENDON RIGHT TO SYSTEMS
DEFINITELY THE ADMINISTRATION
IS VERY CONCERNED ABOUT THE
PRESSURES ON BOTH ON RENTERS AS
WELL AS THE BROADER PRESSURES
IN THE HOUSING MARKET AND THAT
WAS A KEY DRIVER BEHIND THE
DECISION WITH. RENTAL PAINTINGS
I GOT THEIR- EXECUTIVE ORDER A
COUPLE WEEKS AGO. I PERSONALLY
CAN LOOK AT THESE AND
NEIGHBORHOOD. ON TO PICK OF THE
CONSTRAINTS THAT WE FACED WITH
OUR BUDGET AND OUR BALANCED
BUDGET REQUIREMENTS WE REALLY
ARE LEANING ON THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT AS MUCH AS WE CAN.
TO PROVIDE ADDITIONAL
ASSISTANCE THERE WAS SOME
HOUSING ASSISTANCE IN THE ACT
WE NEED DEVELOPMENT BLOCK GRANT
AND THEN ALSO I KNOW NOT
DIRECTLY ON YOUR QUESTION. WHEN
pASSISTANCE THROUGH THE
EMERGENCY SOLUTIONS PROGRAMS
BUT THE GOVERNOR. SAID ASK FROM
THE SENATE BUT AS WELL UNLESS
STEP POPPING RENTAL ASSISTANCE
WILL BE HOPING AND NOT JUST
SOMETHING THAT CAN FOR. THE
FEDERAL. WE WILL ALL. PEOPLE AT
WHAT WE DO YOU WITH REGARD TO
THE BUDGET OVER THE NEXT
SEVERAL ALSO TURNING OVER TO MY
COLLEAGUE CHRIS AND WHO NAY
ABLE TO WRITE ADDITIONAL. A
THIS IS BECAUSE- I'M IN TURN OF
THANK. COMPONENTS OF STATE. IN
ADDITION TO THOSE THAT MY
COLLEAGUE MENTIONED. THERE IS
EIGHT TENANTS BASED RESIDENT AT
RENTAL ASSISTANCE PROGRAM AND
FOR PUBLIC HOUSING AUTHORITIES
WHICH SHOULD. BE ABOUT A
HUNDRED AND SIXTY MILLION
DOLLARS IN CALIFORNIA AND THEN
ANOTHER. AND RELATED TO PUBLIC
HOUSING AUTHORITIES JUST TO
HELP THEM MAINTAIN OPERATIONS
DURING THE PANDEMIC I KNOW IT
IT IS NOT WIDESPREAD- BUT IT
THERE IS SOME RELIEF AND
CERTAIN AREAS. THANK YOU. THAT
CONCLUDES MY QUESTIONS AND
REMARKS THANK YOU MISTER THANK
MATHEMATICS DOCTOR WOULD HAVE
ONE FOLLOW UP QUESTION ON
TESTING YES THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR AND ACTUALLY WANT TO
THANK MISTER BLOOM FOR RIVER
JOGGING MY MEMORY ON THIS MY
CONCERN- AROUND TESTING- IS
THAT I HAVE- ONE COUNTY THAT
HAS NOT HAD A CASE I HAVE ONE
COUNTY THAT HAS NO ACTIVE CASES
BUT HAS HAD CASES- ANOTHER
COUNTIES HAD TWO CASES AND THEN
A COUPLE COUNTY SAID. QUITE A
BIT MORE- THE END AND THOSE
COUNTY THAT HAVEN'T HAD CASES
OR OR HAVE HAD MINIMAL CASES IT
ACTIVE CASES ARE VERY CAN ABOUT
THE TESTING PART OF THIS AND
THAT THE RESOURCE WILL GO HOT
SYNOPSIS WAY TO IN THE REASON
DIFFERENT. THE ARE SMALL TOWN
IS. ZERO UNDER OR STEP YES. SIR
THE POTENTIAL IS IF HAVE
TESTING AND CONTEST COPE IN
TEST A PERSON WHO'S A WOULD.
SHOWING SYMPTOMS AND THE AND
THE A PA RESULT THEY THE
ABILITY TO TRACE BECAUSE THERE
AREN'T AS MANY CASES IN THE
COUNTY- THE COUNTIES ARE MUCH
SMALLER. AND THERE THERE IS A
CHANCE THAT YOU COULD STOP AN
OUTBREAK- BUT IF THEY HAVE THE
TESTING. A CODE. TO DO THAT-
THE IMPLICATIONS OF THAT IN A
SMALLER COUNTY THAT HAVE LESS
FOR PURPOSES. BE SIGNIFICANT
AND SO THAT BENEFIT. PART THAT
I AM. I DIDN'T WHAT CAN I TELL
MY SMALLER COUNTIES IS SAY THAT
THEY WOULD LIKE TO HAVE SOME
TESTING OF CAPACITY TO PREVENT
AN OUTBREAK- NOT NECESSARILY-
THEN THE WAY THEY'RE GETTING IT
NOW. DOCTOR WITH THIS IS MARK
ON EACH WITH THE HEALTH AND
HUMAN SERVICES AGENCIES SO
RIGHT NOW WE'VE HAD TO.
PRIORITIZE WHERE WE ARE.
TESTING AND WHO WE ARE TESTING-
HOWEVER THE TESTING TASK FORCE
HAS A VERY CLEAR- DIRECTOR FOR
BOTH THE GOVERNOR AND THE
SECRETARY THE HEALTHY. THIS IS
AGING. AND THAT IS TO BE PASSED.
THE STATE SO THAT WORKING TO
WE'RE DOING ACTIVE UNITY.
WORKING BROAD BASED CAN. THING
AND. ANDRES IN TERMS OF RURAL
VERSUS URBAN WE HAVE TO FIGURE
OUT HOW WE GET TESTING
CAPACITIES ACROSS THE STATE.
INCLUDES RURAL AREAS OF THE
STATE ESPECIALLY WITH REGARDS
TO CONTACT TRACING YOU
RECOGNIZE THAT WE CAN'T DO
CONTRACT RACING WITH THE WORK
FORCE THAT WE CURRENTLY HAVE IN
THE PUBLIC HEALTH
INFRASTRUCTURE. AND SO WE ARE
HAVING CONGRESS CHANGED.
FORWARD PARTNER WITH YOU AND
ARE. AROUND FIGURE OUT WHAT
EVENTUALLY LEFT WHICH I IN
ORDER TO HAVE THAT CAPACITY. I
GUESS MY POINT IS IN SOME KEY
THE PROBABLY COULD HAVE TO COME
TO DO THAT CA TRACING IF THEY
HAVE ABILITY TASK AND SO
WITHOUT IT- YOU CAN'T AND SO-
THAT'S THAT'S MY CONCERN. BUT
THERE ABOUT THAT THE FORCE'S
WORK ON IT AND- I HOPE THAT IF
WE DO GET THAT HAPPENED THAT.
AND I HAVE I WAS ON A CALL WAS
SIX PUBLIC HEALTH OFFICERS LAST
WEEK AND THE NUMBER ONE AND
REMEMBER THESE ARE ALL
DIFFERENT SIZE COUNTIES. THE
NUMBER ONE THING THEY WERE
TALKING ABOUT WAS A NUMBER ONE
WAS TESS. NUMBER TWO. SO THANK
YOU. THANK DOCTOR WHAT I WAS
FOR AN GET TO MY QUESTIONS AND
SO ON. IN A SO THIS MISTER
BLOOM WASN'T THE ONLY ONE
BETWEEN EVERYBODY LINE SO I
DON'T HAVE SO JUST GO BACK TO
TESTING FOR A- SECOND I I'M
JUST GOAL IS ABOUT TWENTY FIVE
TASADAY BY MAY FIRST DO WE- ARE
WE ON OUR MARKET TO ME THAT
GOAL IN THE- IN ORDER. HAVE THE
MORE THEY TESTING HOW MANY
TESTS WOULD NEED TO DO IN A DAY
ROUGH TWO BE ABLE TO DO THE
MORE. BROAD BASED TACTIC.
MISTER CHAIRMAN WE ARE ON TRACK
TO MEET THOUSAND. A DAY TO BE.
YES DAY WE AND WE ARE WE ARE
LOW TO THE BY THE OF THE MY- I
WE'RE ACT LOOKING AT ALL OF OUR
AND TEST HI. FOR A LACK OF A
BETTER TERM. AT THESE ARE BOTH
ACADEMIC AND- AS WELL AS A
COMMERCIAL LAB CENTER UP AND-
WORKING WITH OTHER PARTS. OR
LACK TORIES CLEAR ABER TORY. AB
PERHAPS DO THIS TYPE OF TESTING
BEFORE BUT ARE LOOKING TO
TRANSITION TO DO THIS TYPE OF
TESTING I SO THAT WE HAVE HAD
THE ABILITY TO BE. CAPACITY
PROCESS WE'VE GOT AT A NUMBER
OF HIGH. THAT ARE ALREADY
TESTING HAVE THAT. CITY WE ARE
ACTIVELY ARE COUNTY. WHO ARE.
SELECT TIED. IN A DAY WHERE
ACTIVELY NUMBER OF DIFFERENT
SALUTE WERE NOT TO POINT TO
JUST WANT TO FROM THE MORE DOWN
IN ORDER FOR US TO A BY WE ARE
A TRACK TO TWENTY FIVE TO TEST
BY THE END OF THE MONTH NO NO
YOU FOR THE BUT HOW MANY WE
NEED TO UP TO DO THE BROAD TEST
YOUR TO BRING TO. WHAT THIS
CITY ACROSS THE STATE AND WHAT
THE LIMITING OUR SO IT JUST BE
TO TASK SOME IN WE HAVE THE
ABILITY TASK WHAT THE LIMITING
FACTOR A IS THE BILL TO COLLECT
THE SPACE SO ONE OF THE THINGS
THAT I LIEU TO OUR TODAY WAS
THE NO THAT WE ISSUE THE CHAIN
RICK SWAPS OR MEDIA OKAY. WE DO
A LOT TESTING. BUT WE'RE HAPPY
I'M JUST WITH REGARDS TO
GETTING WE CAN ACTUALLY COLLECT
THIS. WE'RE LOOKING NOW IS BOTH
OF THOSE COME. TO SEE HOW HOW
DO YOU PLAY IN THE THERE IF
THERE IN THE THAT GOVERNOR HAS
MAPPED OUT WITH RICK TO THE
MODEST. OF THE- CLICK ON THIS
GOING TO ASK THE QUESTION FOR
THE THIRD TIME SO YOU HAVE A
FULL OF TWENTY FIVE THOUSAND ON
MAY FIRST. WHAT IS THE NUMBER
WE NEED TO REACH. I WAS LOOKING
FOR I DON'T I DON'T I DON'T
HAVE A EXACT OF THOSE ANY RIGHT
A HUNDRED JUST I DON'T AN EGG
NUMBER PART OF THE CHANNEL IS
GOING BE THIS CHAIN. I YOU HAVE
A MANY TESTS AS POSSIBLE WE
CAN'T AND I YOU CAN HAVE A TEST
EVERYTHING CAL. BUT IF YOU HAVE
ISSUE WITH THREE TO HOW YOU
COLLECT SOME AND THEIR PROBLEM
THREE TO THE- PASSED IN SO WE
ARE NOT TO RE TWO ISSUES ONE.
NO AGAINST SEMANTIC OF THE THIS
BECAUSE STAYING YES LET'S JUST
THE WHOLE TESTING PROCESS SO
LET'S NOT GET STUCK WITH. IN
YOU'RE GOING THE FIVE THOUSAND
TODAY MY- WHAT NUMBER NEED TO.
ORDER MORE NORMAL IS AT A
HUNDRED IS A FIFTY IS IT LIKE A
MAN BUT WHAT WHAT IS IT. WHERE
ASSESSING THAT RIGHT NOW I
DON'T HAVE THE NUMBER FOR. WHEN
DO YOU THINK WOULD HAVE A
NUMBER. I WAS. TO MY- I CAN'T
DO I COMMIT TO MY BUT ASSUMING.
IN THE NEXT COUPLE OF DAYS WE
WILL HAVE A NUMBER FOR ITS
GREAT OKAY PERFECT- JUST TAKING
LONG TESTING SO I KNOW LA
COUNTY- IS NOW OFFERING FREE
TESTING FOR EVERYONE- ONE
MEDICAL WHICH IS I GUESS A
PRIVATE HEALTH CARE- THERE'S
OFFER. FREE TESTING FOR
EVERYONE DO YOU GIVE CENTS ON
THEY'RE ABLE TO DO IT SAID
THESE TWO IN THAT THE PROBABLY
MORE I JUST IT I KNOW WHAT AT.
THE BILL WHAT OTHER. CANNOT
HAVE THEY BEEN ABLE TO AT THE
SWAMP AND THAT AND THE REASON
THAT YOU REFERRED TO IN OTHER
AREAS HAVE. HI SO AT YOUR IS.
RIGHT THERE A PAST CITY WITH
REGARD TO THE NET OF FRIENDS
THAT MIGHT BE AVAIL IN OUR LA
MY BE THERE THAN IN MY BE
ANOTHER. WE DON'T WE DON'T SEE
TO THAT WE AT LEAST NOT RIGHT
I'M NOT GOING BUT AN ISSUE
REGARDS TO THE RE. THE THING
THAT I WAS TO IS THE BY MEET
WHICH THAT PIECE OF LUCK WITH
THAT SPECIMENS PUT INTO AND WE
ARE ACTIVELY WORKING ON
ACTUALLY PRODUCING THAT ARE.
THEN THIS. THAT CAN. HI JIM
THIS YEAR THE DEEP SENSE OF WHY
ORGAN CAN TO FOR EVERYBODY SAVE
MY SAN FRANCISCO CAN'T. I THINK
THAT'S A TO THE LOCAL. THAT
WEREN'T DICTATE AT THIS LEVEL
DOES WHAT AND WE ARE LOOKING TO
WITH THOSE JR. BUT REMEMBER THE
IT'S NOT JUST IN PUBLIC SECTOR
WERE DOING TESTING WELL DOING A
LOT OF PRIVATE SECTOR TEST AND
HOW THE PRIVATE SECTOR ENTITIES
DECIDE TO TEST AND WHERE TO
TEST THAT IS UP M. BASED ON
DEMAND. WHOLE LOT OKAY SO
COLLABORATION PRIVATE ENTITY
PUBLIC AND- THAT IS GOING TO BE
THE DECISION OF THE LEVEL ASKED
TO THEY PRY. THAT IS A LOW GEN
I CAN THAT EIGHT BY I. FIVE TEN
DAY ARE YOU TALKING ABOUT JUST
STAY TEST THAT'S CAL TESTS ALL
FOR ACCOUNT I'M SORRY. TO FOR.
IN PUBLIC SECTOR HOW. HOW MUCH
INFORMATION ARE YOU GETTING
REAL TIME SO THAT YOU CAN GET A
SENSE OF- JUST BECAUSE BASED
ON. THIS DIALOGUE DOESN'T SEEM
LIKE YOU HAVE A REALLY GOOD
UNDERSTANDING WHAT'S HAPPENING
LA WHICH IS THE- JUST COUNTY IN
THE STATE VERSUS SAY. THE OTHER
COUNTIES AND IN ON THIS
PARTICULAR ISSUE. SO WHAT WE
KNOW IS- WE HAVE VERY GOOD DATA
COMING IN FROM ALL PROPER TERRY
SPEAKING AT NO THEIR MANDATE.
TO REPORT WITH REGARDS TO ALL
TASKS THAT ARE POSITIVE- WE
HAVE NOW REQUIRED THAT ALL
LABORATORIES COMMERCIAL AND-
PUBLIC REPORT NEGATIVES AS WELL
THE PACE AT WHICH WE ARE
GETTING THE NAME OF REPORTS. I
NEED TO COUNTY AND WE- GEN BUT
WE ARE COLLECTING AT AS
MANDATED AT THAT LOCAL
LABORATORIES BOTH PUBLIC AND
PRIVATE REPORT BOTH POSITIVE
AND NEGATIVE TESTS THAT THEY DO
IN EACH FLAPPER. DO YOU DO IS.
TIME YOU GET A REAL TIME DATA
IN TERMS OF WHO'S ADMINISTERING
TASS SO BASED ON THAT YOU HAVE
A SENSE OF THE NUMBER OF TEST
THEY'RE BEING. DONE YEAH I
ASSUME. GETTING DOUBT THOSE
FIGURES AT THE COUNTY LEVEL OR
YOU GET GREATER GRANULARITY
THAN THAT. I IT IS AT THE
COUNTY LEVEL- IF YOU ACTUALLY
VISIT OUR WEBSITE AT C. H. E.
JEFF AT CA DOC UP EVERY DAY WE
POST A NUMBER OF PROTESTS THAT
ARE. ACROSS THE STATE GOT IT.
WHAT WERE YOU DO REAL. YOU'RE
NOT NECESSARILY. YOU DON'T HAVE
A SENSE PACIFIC LEE WHAT THE
OVERALL CAPACITY AS- WE GET
WHAT WHAT WE HAVE A SENSE OF
THIS HOW MANY TESTS WERE
ACTUALLY DONE WHAT WE'RE
WORKING ON RIGHT NOW. THE
REASON WHY I CANNOT. ANSWER
YOUR QUESTION IS WE'RE REACHING
OUT TO EACH ONE OF THESE
INSTITUTIONS TO SAY IN ADDITION
TO WHAT YOU SAID RIGHT NOW HOW
MUCH ARE CAN YOU. AND WHAT ARE
THE LESS LIMITING FACTORS AS TO
YOU NOT TEST IT'S A- CITY THAT
WE'RE TRYING TO UNDERSTAND.
MOMENT AND THE TWENTY FIVE TO
TWENTY FIVE THOUSAND THE TESTS.
THAT INCLUDES TESTS AWAITING A
RESULT OR THAT'S JUST THE ONES
THAT HAVE RESULT. WE'RE LOOKING
TO DELIVER TWENTY TO HAVE THE
ABILITY TO TEST TWENTY FIVE
THOUSAND SPECIMENS PER DAY
THAT'S THE THAT'S THE GOAL THAT
THAT AT THE TASK FORCE HAS PUT
FORWARD. GONNA SO THAT MEANS
THAT THE TWENTY DOLLAR BILLS
ARE RESULTS SO THAT'S A
POSITIVE OR NEGATIVE. I'M SORRY
CORRECT. JUST GOING BACK ARE
JUST WANTED TO ASK QUESTIONS
AROUND THE JOINT LEGISLATIVE
BUDGET COMMITTEE LETTER WHICH
WAS- LAST I THINK IT WAS LAST
WEEK OR THE WEEK BEFORE THESE
THESE WEEKS TOUGH START TO
BLEND TOGETHER SO I APOLOGIZE
FOR THE- FROM FORGET. AS PART
OF THE LETTER WE HAD PASSED TO
TRACK SUPPLY AND DEMAND A P. P.
ACROSS THE STATE WE HAD ASKED
FOR WHICH MAJOR TYPE OF
EQUIPMENT AND DESTINATION EACH
OUTGOING SHIP INTENT FOR THOSE
TO BE TAKEN UP IN CAP SPACE
COUNTY OR ZIP USER. INCLUDE
OFFICER ISN'T UP. TO WORK TIME
PARAPHRASING THE LETTER ALSO
THE OF ORDER FILL BY COUNTY OR
HEALTH CARE. THE POWER ORDER
FOR DISTURBING WITHIN THESE
JURISDICTION AND FOR ALL OF
THAT TO BE. UP PUBLISHED ON OUR
WEBSITE NOW- SHE THE- THAT THE
COUNTY SPREAD SHEET THAT WE GOT
SHOWING IN INETY FIVE
RESPIRATORS AND SURGICAL MASKS-
DID GIVE A SENSE ALL WHEN THAT
INFORMATION CAN BE. PUBLISHED
ONLINE I THINK A LOT OF.
REQUEST A WEEK AT OUR FROM
LOCAL OFFICIALS LOOKING AGAIN
FOR INFORMATION I THINK MY
COLLEAGUES HAVE ALL ECHO THAT
IT WOULD BE GREAT IF SOME OF
THIS INFORMATION COULD BE COULD
BE BLIND REAL TIME LOOKS LIKE
SOME OF THE DATA YOU FOR YOU.
MENTION ALREADY TALKED ABOUT.
YEAH THANKS FOR THE QUESTION.
MISTER CHAIR WE ARE WORKING ON
NOT- EXPANDING OUR- OUR
DASHBOARD- AND THE INFORMATION
THAT WE- WILL BE ABLE TO PUT UP
ONLINE AND SO WE'RE HOPING TO.
GET THAT COMPLETED OUR PRIORITY
QUITE FRANKLY HAS BEEN ON
GETTING THE PP WERE ACTUALLY
RESPONDING TO THE EVENT AND SO
MOST OF THE- EFFORTS OF THE
CRUISER AND WORKING. I'M HAVE
BEEN- TO BE ABLE TO AT LEAST OF
FOCUS ON- ADJUDICATING WHY
RESOURCES WE HAVE AND- TRY TO
PUSH THOSE OUT AS AS FAST AS
POSSIBLE. BUT WE HAVE BEEN
WORKING ON THE DASHBOARD AND WE
HOPE TO HAVE A COMPLETE HERE%
ALL WITHIN A WEEK. OKAY BYE
WEEK IT WILL BE ABLE TO GET
SOMETHING ON A LINE. THAT'S
GREAT AND DO YOU THINK YOU'LL
BE ABLE TO PROVIDE INFORMATION
THAT. EIGHTY RIVER QUESTION.
ALL TO GO BACK AND LOOK AT THE
LETTER AGAIN AND THERE ARE.
MANY THINGSTHAT ARE ON THERE
WE SHOULD BE ABLE TO- PROVIDE
DAD AND I TRY TO MAKE SURE THAT
THERE ARE NOT. SENSITIVE OR- A
CRITICAL ISSUES ON THERE THAT
WE CAN'T PROVIDE FOR
OPERATIONAL REASONS NOT THAT'S
FINE AND I THINK. YEAH I THINK
FOR IN THIS THIS IS JUST TO
SORT OF ECHO WHAT THE SENATE
COMMITTEE SAID I THINK FOR
ISSUES THAT ARE SENSITIVE WE
ALL UNDERSTAND. THERE ARE SOME
ISSUES THAT ARE SENSITIVE- MY
SUGGESTION IT WOULD BE. GOOD TO
HAVE A SEPARATE LEGISLATIVE
BRIEFING ON ISSUES THAT ARE.
PARTICULAR SENSE HERE THAT HAVE
PARTICULAR SENSITIVITY. I THINK
IT IS IMPORTANT FOR US TO AT
LEAST GET BRIEFED ON THOSE
ISSUES EVEN IF YOU CAN'T.
COMPLETELY SURE THOSE WITH THE
PUBLIC- SO WE WOULD BE GREAT TO
ACTUALLY SET UP SOME SORT OF
PROCESS TO THAT THAT- THAT THAT
CAN OCCUR. I KNOW THAT THERE'S
THESE DAILY ALL WE ASK CALLS
THERE BUT THEY'RE ONLY ONE
HOUR. AND OFTEN TIMES- YOU KNOW
QUESTION I'M MORE SENSITIVE. I
CAN'T BE HONEST AND SOMETIMES
YOU KNOW QUESTION IS JUST WE
GET TO THE QUESTIONS BECAUSE
SOME PEOPLE ON THE CALL. BUT
HOPE THERE'S A- YOU AGAIN. IN
GETTING THE REST. THIS IS SORT
OF THAT'S- AND- MAYBE I'M JUST
OVERLY SENSITIVE BUT AGAIN IT
JUST SEEMS THAT- IT WOULD BE
IMPORTANT FOR US TO. BE ABLE TO
HAVE A FULL BRIEFING ON. ALL
THOSE ISSUES ARE SENSITIVE AND
CAN'T BE RELEASED TO THE PUBLIC.
THANK YOU ALL I WILL TAKE THAT
BACK AND SEE IF WE CAN. WE CAN
NOW WILL GET BACK ON THAT. ON
IT AND JUST JUST GOING BACK TO-
THE MODEL FOR A SECOND I KNOW
THAT WE TOUCHED ON A LITTLE BIT
BUT- BUT AGAIN. THE MODEL I
GUESS. WE TALKED ABOUT EARLIER
THAN THE MODEL SHOWS A MID MAY
PEAK I KNOW THAT SAY I THINK
IT'S THE UNIVERSITY OF
WASHINGTON MODEL BECAUSE THAT'S
ONE OF THE MODELS THAT ONLINE.
SHOWS A MID APRIL P. D. DO YOU
KNOW WHO ANY. UNDERSTANDING THE
DIFFERENCE. SURE THAT THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIRMAN FOR THAT
QUESTION AND THE JOHN TOP GUN
MODEL IS ALSO AVAILABLE ONLINE
AND OPEN TO THE PUBLIC AT THE
DIFFERENCE AND IN US COMING
CONVERSATIONS WITH OUR
COUNTERPARTS ANOTHER STATE. IS
THAT THE- THAT THE ASSUMPTIONS
ARE BEING USED IN THE
UNIVERSITY OF WASHINGTON MODEL
ARE CHANGING ARE ON THE BACK
AND QUITE FREQUENTLY. I AND-
THEY ARE RATHER CONSERVATIVE
COMPARED TO SOME OF THE OTHER
MODELS- AND SO- WHAT WE ARE
LOOKING AT IS NOT JUST ONE
MODEL OF A MULTIPLE MODELS SO
WE START THERE KEEPING A CLOSE
EYE AYE OUT ON THEIR- AYE HME
MODEL THAT IS BEING PRODUCED BY
THE UNIVERSE. WASHINGTON THE
UNIVERSITY OF PENNSYLVANIA
MODEL. OUT NOW TO MY- JOHN CAN
THE MODEL WE ARE ALSO WERE.
UNIVERSITY IT TO OUR PRODUCING
A MODEL. THE IDEA HERE IS
DIRECTIONALITY- ARE AWARE HOW
ARE WE SEEING THE
DIRECTIONALITY OF THE VIRUS
WITHIN IN ANY PARTICULAR STATE
AND- WHAT WE LIKED ABOUT THE
JOHNS HOPKINS MODEL IS THE
ABILITY TO PROVIDE COUNTY LEVEL
DATA THAT THE OTHER MODELS WERE
NOT ABLE TO DO. SOME OF THEM
ARE BEGINNING TO DO THAT BUT
THAT WHAT REALLY REALLY LIKED
ABOUT THE JOHNS HOPKINS MODEL
YEAH THAT'S GREAT IF YOU COULD
SHARE THE LINK FOR THE HOPKINS
MODEL THAT THE- GRAY AYE.
ALWAYS FIND IT THE THROUGH
THEIR WEBSITE. I'M NOT HERE I
JUST DON'T COME BACK QUESTION
AROUND CONSTRUED MUSIC
CONSERVATIVE WHAT DO YOU MEAN
YOU MEAN THAT. IT'S BECAUSE-
INSTEAD. PREDICT LESS INTER. SO
BIG OF THAT THE CANCER. RIGHT
OKAY GREAT- AND THEN JUST GOING
BACK TO FINANCE ARE REGARDING
SOME OF THE EXPENDITURES- WE
KNOW THAT- MISS CALVERT
PROVIDED THE EXPENDITURES FOR
APPROXIMATELY THE- I GUESS
PARKS MY FOR. TWO BILLION
DOLLARS HERE THERE'S ANOTHER
FIVE BILLION THAT WE'VE TALKED
ABOUT. SPENDING CAN YOU GIVE US
A SENSE OF WHAT. WHAT THAT IS
WITH WITH THE MAJOR MARKETS ARE
AND WE CAN GET A BREAK OUT.
LATER TO BUT JUST TO GET A
ROUGH SENSE. WILL I TURN IT
OVER IT'S ACTUALLY SIX HOUR TO
DISCUSS THAT I SHOULD SAY THAT
SHE WILL SHE CAN DEFINITELY
TALK ABOUT MAJOR BUCKETS AND
HOW WORKING CATEGORIES WHEN IT
COMES TO ACTUAL ALLOCATIONS-
THESE ARE VERY ANSWER YOU CAN
DISCUSS HOW WE ARE. GREAT.
THREE SIX OVER IT AGAIN- SO TO
VERY HIGH LEVEL OF ANY OF THE
USED TO SECURE PERSONAL
PROTECTIVE EQUIPMENT AND
CRITICAL THAT. I AM ALL THEIR
BE VARIOUS HOSPITAL MEDICAL
SEARCH. AND ACTIVITIES SO I'M
STAFF BEING TOTALLY SAYS- AS AN
EXAMPLE AND THE HOTELS FOR
HEALTH CARE WORKERS AND- WHAT
STEP THAT CANNOT GO HOME ITSELF
ISOLATOR INCLUDED AND THERE'S A
RANGE OF SUPPORT SERVICES
NUMBER OF WHICH WE TALKED.
ABOUT AS FAR AS BEING. ROLES
ARE SIX BASIC ALEX SO THOSE ARE
THAT THE HIGH LEVEL CATEGORIES.
THAT ARE. INCOME IN THE LARGER
AND SEVEN BILLION DOLLARS. EACH
ESTIMATES. SO YOU HAD P. P.
HOSPITAL AND MEDICAL SEARCH.
HOTELS IN SUPPORT SERVICES WITH
THE WHAT DO I'M SORRY APPLY
MISTER CATEGORY OR TO. NO I
THINK THAT CAPTURED THOSE-
CORRECTLY SO SUPPORT SERVICES
IS. INCLUDES THAT- HOMELESS
SERVICES ALLOCATIONS A FEW BEEN
SUPPORTS- THAT CHILD CARE
SERVICES OF COURSE WE TALKED
ABOUT EARLIER- AS WELL AS SOME
OF THE- SECTION THIRTY SIX
PUBLICATIONS. SO SINCE THERE'S
ABOUT ROUGHLY FIVE BILLION MORE
THAT HASN'T BEEN- BROKEN OUT
ROUGHLY WHAT ARE YOU
ANTICIPATING SPENDING ON PPV
VERSUS. HOTELS SUPPORT SERVICES
HOMELESS AND CHILD CARE
SERVICES. RIGHT AT THIS TIME WE
DON'T HAVE A BREAK OUT TO
PROVIDE YOU- AT THIS NUMBER
AGAIN. TALKING ABOUT THE BROAD
CATEGORIES BUT WE DON'T HAVE A
BREAKOUT AVAILABLE TO SHARE.
THAT'S BECAUSE YOU HAVEN'T THAT
JUST- ESTIMATE OF WHAT YOU
ANTICIPATE OR- YOU YOU HAVEN'T
NAILED DOWN THOSE EXPENDITURES
AT. RIGHT SO I THINK IT AND IT
IS AGAIN YEAH OUR PRELIMINARY
CASH FLOW ESTIMATE- AND THINGS
ARE- CHANGE AND THINGS HAVE
BEEN CHANGING SO WE ARE.
TRACKING THESE CATEGORIES AND
AGAIN DON'T HAVE A BREAK OUT AT
THE TIME AT THIS TIME. YEAH I
THINK JUST TO ECHO WHAT MICHAEL
MARK I'M ALMOST ALL MY
COLLEAGUES HAVE. SAID IN IN
TOWN. I THINK WHERE YOU KNOW
WHERE WE'RE OBVIOUSLY
EXTRAORDINARILY SUPPORTIVE OF
THE GOVERNOR AND THE
ADMINISTRATION EVERYTHING
THAT'S BEEN DONE TO. REALLY
MANAGE THIS DEMOCRATS BASS AS
POSSIBLE HERE IN CALIFORNIA-
HAVING SAID THAT THE YOU KNOW
THE EMERGENCY POWERS- THAT WERE
GRANTED. YOU KNOW WITH AN
UNDERSTANDING THAT THIS WOULD
BE FOR A CERTAIN AMOUNT OF-
DISCRETE TIME- DEFINITELY
WASN'T THE SENSE THAT THERE WAS
A BLANK CHECK OR THAT WE WOULD
JUST BE- JUST- NOTIFIED AFTER
EXPENDITURES WERE ALREADY
COMMITTED TO SO I THINK THE
HOPE IS. NOT WE HAVE GONE
THROUGH A ROUGH INITIAL FIVE
WEEKS AND OBVIOUSLY THERE'S
STILL MORE TO BE. DONE BUT THAT
WILL BE SIGNIFICANTLY MORE
DISCUSSION BACK AND FORTH
ESPECIALLY WHEN IT COMES TO
THE- EXPENDITURE OF RESOURCES
ESPECIALLY AS IT HAS AN IMPACT-
GOING INTO NEXT YEAR'S BUDGET
AS WELL AS- AN ONGOING BUDGETS.
THIS IS NOT THIS IS A RESERVE
ANY. OF POLY WE'VE ALL. VERY
VERY TO BUILD YOU KNOW WE I WAS
THERE ON THE GROUND FLOOR AS WE
STARTED BUILDING THIS SERVICE
AND I THINK WE- WANT TO HAVE A
SAY IN TO HOW. THIS RESERVE
MONEY IS BEINGSPENT- WE
OBVIOUSLY KNOW THAT RIGHT NOW
WE HAVE A CRISIS- WE HAVE FULL
FAITH AND- DUTY OF THE GOVERNOR
TO REALLY GET US THROUGH THIS
CRIME BUT HOW DOES THAT I THINK
WE ALSO. FEEL LIKE WE HAVE A
VERY IMPORTANT ROLE TO PLAY
ESPECIALLY AS IT COMES TO THE
APPROPRIATION AND THE
EXPENDITURE OF THESE RESOURCES
SO THEN. JUST GOING BACK TO THE
OTHER FIVE BILLION WIND WIND WE
ANTICIPATE GETTING MORE
INFORMATION ON THIS. SO I THINK
I CAN SAY ARE. YOU EAT EVEN IN
THE NEXT COUPLE WEEKS I DON'T
THINK THAT THERE WILL BE A FULL
PLAN FOR COMMUNICATIONS OF THE
EXACT FIVE BILLION IN PART
BECAUSE THAT FIVE BILLION.
TAKER MAY CHANGE BUT CERTAINLY
THAT YOU CAN EXPECT THAT AS
PART OF THE NAME PROVISIONS.
BUDGET PROCESS YOU KNOW WE'RE
PRESENTING OUR FISCAL PLAN
ABOUT PROPOSAL FOR THE UPCOMING
YEAR FOR YOU OUR CONSIDERATION-
THERE SHOULD BE ADDITIONAL
DETAIL THERE. THEY WERE YOUNG I
THINK THE HOPE. MOVE AWAY FROM
JOINT. BUDGET NOW. ARE WE
UNDERSTAND THAT YOU MAY NOT
KNOW EVERYTHING IN THE FUTURE I
THINK THE YOU KNOW EVERY YEAR
WE DO A BUDGET AND THE ONLY
THING. WE CAN SAY FOR CERTAINTY
IS THE BY JUST NOT GONNA BE ONE
UNDER PERCENT AFTER WE ALL WE
ALL KNOW THAT- BUT- WE AGREE ON
A DOCUMENT THAT IS A SET OF
SYMBOLS ON THE SIDE OF
EXPENDITURES OVER. I THINK IT
WOULD BE NICE TO GO BACK THAT
ESPECIALLY IN REGARDS TO STICK
SPEND THE CHORE OF BILLIONS AND
ENDS UP WITH YOU KNOW. TWENTY
DOLLARS. SO AGAIN I THINK THAT
THAT'S JUST MY A LIFE MY FINAL
POINT JUST MAKING SURE THAT
AGAIN WE- YOU KNOW WE HAVE A
BUDGET PROCESS WE HAVE A BUDGET
PROCESS AND HOW WE SPEND MONEY-
OBVIOUSLY WE KNOW WERE IN AN
EMERGENCY WHERE WE NEED TO
EXPAND MONEY QUICKLY BUT ALSO
ON HOW THE PROCESS WHERE WE ARE
TRYING TO MANAGE OUR EXPENSE.
WE ALREADY HOW FINE. WE GET OUR
EXPECT WORSE BUDGET NEW HAS YOU
KNOW MOVING FORWARD- HIGH I
WOULD DEFINITELY CONCUR WITH
THAT TO THINK IT'S EVEN MORE
REASON FOR US TO BE WORKING
TOGETHER- TO MAKE SURE THAT YOU
KNOW AS WE MAKE THESE DECISIONS
THAT THEIR JOINT DECISIONS NOT
JUST ABOUT DECISIONS FROM ONE
PARTICULAR PART- SO. LOOKING
AROUND TO SEE IF THERE ARE ANY
ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS ARE PEOPLE
DYING OF HUNGER- YOUKNOW WE
ARE WE ARE GOING TO GO TO
PUBLIC COMMENT WE HAVE A NUMBER
OF PEOPLE ON THE PHONE WE HAVE
A FEW BRAVE SOULS HERE IN THE
COMMITTEE ROOM- SO WE WILL GO
TO PUBLIC COMMENT WE ARE
ASKING. A MINUTE EACH I AND I
SEE MR LEVEL IN THE AUDIENCE
WHO IS YOUR BRAVE. FOR HALF
HOURS THIS HEARINGS ON THIS
LEVEL. HELLO HIGH SCHOOL
FOOTBALL COACH YOU ONCE TOLD ME
THE THING HE LIKED ABOUT ME WAS
I WAS TOO STUPID TO BE AFRAID.
GOOD FOR YOU I BE REMISS I
DIDN'T COMMENT ON THIS
COMMITTEE HEARING I'VE BEEN
HERE THIRTY FIVE YEARS AND THIS
COMMITTEE HEARING WITH
EVERYBODY'S QUESTIONS-
EXEMPLIFIED THE VERY HIGHEST
STANDARDS OF PUBLIC SERVICE
EXCELLENCE- WHEN I TALK ABOUT
VERY QUICKLY HE IS AN UNMET
NEED THAT WE HAVE AND THAT'S
THE NEED FOR INTER OPERABILITY
SERVICES CONNECTING ALL OF THE
HEALTHCARE PROVIDERS THE
HOSPITALS. THE HEALTH OFFICERS
IN EVERY COUNTY TOGETHER UNDER
THE BEST INTEROPERABLE ANY
SERVICE IN THE COUNTRY IS IN
NEW JERSEY- WHERE THEY HAVE
CONNECTED EVERYONE TOGETHER
THEY MUNICH. FOR EXAMPLE YOU
HAD A HOSPITAL LAID OFF PEAK.
DATA MEDIA REPORT SOMEPLACE
WHERE THERE WAS NEED- IF YOU
NEEDED TO MEET MOVE PATIENTS
IT'S A VERY EFFECTIVE- WE DON'T
HAVE THAT HERE AND WE NEED TO-
IT IS EASY TO INSTALL THE
SOFTWARE SETTING UP. THE NEW
JERSEY PROGRAM CAN BE SET UP IN
EVERY HOSPITAL IN THE STATE IN
LESS THAN FIVE DAYS. AND THE
COST- IS PERHAPS ABOUT FOUR
HUNDRED THOUSAND DOLLARS TOTAL
WHICH IS PROBABLY REIMBURSABLE
ON THE FEDERAL SIDE ANYWAY- I
WOULD COMMANDED THIS COMMITTEE.
THAT YOU ASKED POINTED
QUESTIONS ABOUT. CAN WE GET
THIS DONE HERE IN CALIFORNIA
YOU MAY EVEN WANT TO PUT THAT
AS PART OF YOUR AGENDA IN
FUTURE HEARINGS. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH EXCELLENT HEARING THANK
YOU VERY MUCH I KNOW WE HAVE
ABOUT THIRTY PEOPLE ON THE
PHONE AND WE'RE GONNA START
TAKING COLORS. AND LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN FOR PUBLIC COMMENTS
YOU MAY PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO
THANK YOU CAN WITHDRAW YOUR
QUESTION OR PARDON ME YOUR
COMMENTED ANYTIME. BY REPEATING
THE ONE ZERO COMMAND IF YOU
HAVE ALREADY PRESS THE ONE
ZERO. THE QUESTION QUEUE YOU DO
NOT BE DEPRESSED FOR THE SECOND
TIME. AND IF YOU ARE USING A
SPEAKER PHONE PLEASE PICK UP
THE HANDSET BEFORE PRESSING THE
NUMBERS ONCE AGAIN FOR PUBLIC
COMMENT. PRESS ONE THEN
THERE'LL WILL GO TO HELL MOD
ALONG AND A LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. YEAH OTHER THANK YOU
SO MUCH THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
AND MEMBERS OF THE
SUBCOMMITTEE. I MEAN COME ON ON
AND STOP ATTORNEY AT THE ASIAN
LAW CAUCUS I'M HERE TO
REPRESENT THE NO PP IN
CALIFORNIA COALITION- WE WISH
TO THANK ALL THE BOOKS WERE
WORKING IN OUR STATE CAPITOL
AND THROUGHOUT THE STATE. UNDER
THIS CRISIS. I WANT TO
RECOGNIZE THE CRITICAL ROLE
THAT STATED BEAT LIKE. CAL YES
ARE PLAYING OR SPEECH RESPONSE
TO CALL AT NINETEEN. HOWEVER IN
THIS MOMENT INCREASE COMMUNITY
CONCERNS AROUND GOVERNMENT OVER
REACH. INCREASED SURVEILLANCE
DATA COLLECTION AFRICAN
INCREASE BUT NECESSARY FEDERAL
RELIEF. WE ARE DEEPLY CONCERNED
ABOUT A- YET. ONGOING
COLLABORATIVE EFFORT. WITH THE
FEDERAL DEPARTMENT OF HOMELAND
SECURITY IN DEVELOPING ONLY AT
THE SO CALLED. HOMELAND
SECURITY OPERATIONS. AT PARTY
CELEBRATION CAL THE WE HAVE
DEVELOPED PROGRAM LIKE
PREVENTING BUT BETWEEN ISM OR
PVC. EQUITY PAPER CAN REACH
GRANT. BOTH OF WHICH ARE
MODELED ON THE AT THE I. T. ON
WITH THE PRO WHICH I. EXTREMELY
HARD FOR I'M TO. A CROWDSOURCED.
THESE PROGRAMS WILL TELL YET
THIS A LOT. RG AT BP THE
PROGRAMS ARE EXTREMELY ARE
POINT BUDGETS FOR THE FOR THE
NOISE THERE WE JUST WANTED TO
MAKE A QUICK RECORD JUST IN
YOUR TIME TO GET THE TIMES UP
IF YOU COULD JUST WRAP UP THAT
THE GREAT. YES YES THANK YOU SO
MUCH FOR YOUR TIME I. JUST WANT
TO MAKE THE REQUEST WE WANT TO
AFTER THE COMPANY PREVENT ANY
STATE FUNDING GOING TO CAL- YES
THIS. YEAR CRITICS HAVE ACCUSED
AROUND. REQUIRED HELLO WE ARE
NOT USING A FUNDING PREVIOUSLY
PROVIDED BY THE STATE THE
FUNDING OPERATE THESE PROGRAMS
THE TO REALLOCATE BUT FUND. FOR
OTHER EMERGENCY RELIEF. AT THE
CALL IN THE GOVERNOR TO AND IT
IS THAT THESE PROGRAMS THANK
YOU SO MUCH. WE HAVE PUBLIC
COMMENT FROM FATIMA LADDER
FIFTEEN MEDDLING IN THE OPEN.
HI EVERYONE THANK YOU SO MUCH
MY NAME IS BOB THE MINUTE I AM
ALSO AT THE ASIAN LAW CAUCUS I
WANT TO THANK YOU ALL SO MUCH
FOR HOLDING THIS HEARING- AND
ALSO THINK THE MEMBERS AND
STAFF OF THE STATE GOVERNMENT
FOR THEIR TIRELESS WORK IN
RESPONSE THAT CURRENT TOP AND
THAT MAKE SURE JUST WANTED TO
MAKE A QUICK NOTE THAT
ALCOHOLIC WHEN YOUR RESPONSE.
EASY WE MUST NOT FORGET THAT
EVEN AND WE NEED FEDERAL
INVOLVEMENT AT THIS TIME THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT CAN AND HAS
IN THE PAST USE CRISES. TO
EXPAND POLICE POWERS TO TARGET
AND FURTHER COLONEL. MARCH
NINTH WHICH IS COMMUNITY. HELLO
ATTORNEY GENERAL WELL ARE DOING
IS PREVIOUS TENER. TENURE AND
THEN. YOU THE HIV AIDS CRISIS
AND THE MINUTE THEY- OF HAITIAN
TO DETAIN. THREE HUNDRED AND
TEN HE'S MEN WOMEN AND CHILDREN
SEEKING REFUGE. AND THE U. S.
AT THE NAVAL BASE IN GUANTANAMO
BAY- OR HOW THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT AND THE FBI
CONTINUED TO USE. THAT OF
TERROR. ALLEN ETHNIC AT
RELIGIOUS. SUCH AS THE LOCAL
EIGHT SO WE URGE THE- WE ARE IS
THAT AT THIS TIME CALIFORNIA
ACT WITH OR SITE AND PUT
MEASURES IN PLACE. THAT ENSURE
THAT CALIFORNIA'S MANY AGENCIES.
MAN WILL NOT BE COMPLICIT IN
SUCH FEDERAL OVERREACH AND FUND
MANAGERS THAT PROTECT OUR CIVIL
LIBERTIES PERSON. THANK YOU SO
MUCH. AND WE HAVE PUBLIC
COMMENT FROM JONATHAN NELSON
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK YOU
CHAIR KING JONATHAN OPEN WITH
COMMUNITY WATER CENTER'S BEGIN
TO A LETTER SUBMITTED TO THE
COMMITTEE BY OVER FIFTY
ORGANIZATIONS ON ACT THAT THE
TAKE WATER. AND COMMUNITY FARM
WORKER COMMUNITY NEED URGENT
ACTION TO SECURE ACT THAT THE
WATER IN THEIR HOMES NOW AND IN
THE COMING MONTHS. WE DO A POT
BUT THAT THE GOVERNOR HAS
ALREADY TAKEN AND IT'S A BOOK
THAT AN EXECUTIVE ORDER THAT
REQUIRES WATER RECONNECTION.
ANYONE QUIT BLOCKED WATER
BEGINNING ON OR AFTER MARCH
FOURTH AND ALL THE PROTECT
AGAINST FUTURE WATER SHOP. WELL
THAT IS THE TRONG FOUNDATION
THOUGH THERE ARE STILL A COUPLE
OF URGENT ACTION THAN PRODUCTS.
INCLUDING MAKING THAT ANYONE
WHO THEIR WATER SHUT OFF. FOR
TO MARCH FOR. CAN CONTINUE TO
HAVE. ACT THAT THE WHY AND THAT
THEIR WATER ACTIONS IT IN IT'S
POSSIBLE GIVEN WE ARE ASKING
THE SHELTER IN PLACE. AND ALL
THAT REPAIRS PROVIDE FINANCE
FOR A LEAK IN THE COMING MONTHS
BOTH THE SMALL WATER TO. KEEP
THE LIGHTS ON AND A LOW INCOME
HOUSEHOLDS WHO MAY BE UNABLE TO
PETER UTILITY BILL FOR A LONG
TIME. AFTER LIKE ACT THAT DICK.
LAND BUT YOU'RE LATE THE THANK
YOU CAN LOOK FOR TO WORK WITH
YOU THINK YOU. AND WE HAVE
PUBLIC COMMENT FROM OF THE MAN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI AND BEING
IN THE LEADERSHIP COUNCIL FOR
JUSTICE AND ACCOUNTABILITY
IMMEDIATELY WORK WITHIN THE SAN
JOAQUIN AND COACHELLA VALLEY IS
THERE ANYTHING STAGGERING
IMPACT OF CO THE NINETEEN.
FIRSTLY THE END UP. ON THE TOP.
IN A CENTRAL FOR THAT BUT ONE
OF A- BECAUSE I CAN LOT YOU TO
COOK THE NINETEEN. WILL AND
JACK BAR. RESIDENTS FROM A SEAT
IN THE ASSISTANCE MOREOVER IT
WATER AND SEWER SERVICE WITH
ALL CALIFORNIANS MUST BE
IMMEDIATELY RECONNECTED
REGARDLESS OF THE DATE LOCKED
THEIR VETS. AND COMMUNITIES
INCLUDING- NEED ACCESS TO
PRODUCE AND WHICH NOT BE LEFT
TO ROT IN THE FIELD. WE DO
STILL NEED A REAL STATEWIDE
AFFECTION AND FOR CLOSURE MARK
FOR AS WELL AS THAT FORGIVENESS
HELLO INCOME CALIFORNIANS.
AFTER CHILDREN LISTED-
ADDITIONALLY WE DO NEED MOBILE
HOT SPOTS THE POINT AND- THE
STRUCTURE. UNDER YEAH. BLACK
AND ASIAN AND PARTICIPATION
APPLE PUBLIC MEETING BOTH LOCAL
AND STATE. SHORT WE URGE YOU TO
PRIORITIZE A AND BASICALLY
COURSE GOT AND ONE HEALTH THAT
ARE ONLY BEING TO BE NOW BACK
OVER NINETEEN. THANK YOU THANK
YOU. HAVE A COMMENT FROM WESLEY
MARTINEZ PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI
THIS IS LESLIE MARTINEZ ALSO
WITH LEADERSHIP COUNCIL FOR
JUSTICE AND COUNTER THE BILL
WOULD BE I WORK DIRECTLY WITH
THE COMMUNITY RESIDENTS IN
FRESNO COUNTY AND I'M HERE TO
SPEAK ON BEHALF OF THE
COMMUNITY THE UNINCORPORATED
COMMUNITY OF COUNTRY WHAT CREEK
AND THE UNINCORPORATED
COMMUNITY OF WHEN THEY'RE- BOTH
OF- BOTH COMMUNITY LEADERS HAVE
ASKED. FOR IT THE- PLEASE
CONSIDER THE FACT THAT THERE IS
NO- ACTIVE YOU INTERNET IN BOTH
OF THESE COMMUNITIES AND
THEREFORE THEY CANNOT
PARTICIPATE IN FRESNO COUNTY
BOARD OF SUPERVISORS MEETING
BECAUSE THEY'RE ONLY TAKING
COMING. THROUGH IN. ADDITION
LIAM. THEY ARE NOT ABLE TO ACT
WITH THE IMPORTANT INFORMATION
THAT IS BEING GIVEN BY THE
PUBLIC. PUBLIC HEALTH. AND
FINALLY I REALLY WANT TO THANK
ALL OF THE RULE- MEMBERS TODAY
THAT ARE PRESENT IN ADVOCATING
FOR RURAL AREAS- JUST. A DOCTOR
AND BILL WAS TALKING ABOUT HOW
THE FOOD BANKS AND I WANT TO
REALLY ADVOCATE FOR OUR
FRONTLINE VOLUNTEERED FOR
INLAND- DISTRIBUTING FOOD THEY
TYPICALLY GIVE A HUNDRED. OF
HE'LL AND THEY THEY ARE GIVING
OVER THREE HUNDRED MEALS PARTY
DISTRIBUTION THE RESERVE HAS
RUN OUT THERE IS NO PP WE ARE
REQUESTING THAT UP FRONT LINE
VOLUNTEERS ARE ALSO PUT-
GETTING MORE ARE GETTING MORE
SHOOTING OFF MORE PP THANK YOU
SO MUCH. THANK YOU. AND WE HAVE
A COMMENT FROM TAMMY MARGIN
TAMMY PLEASE GO AHEAD. YES
CAPTION UNIT CHIANG MAI NUMBER
CAN MARTIN ON BEHALF EQUALITY
CALIFORNIA AND THANKS SO MUCH
FOR TODAY'S REVIEW OF THE
INITIAL EMERGENCY FUNDING WE
APPRECIATE THE POINT MEMBERS
MADE WITH REGARD TO NEED THE
CRITICAL COMMUNITY
ORGANIZATION. AND WE JUST URGE
THAT  NEED TO MOVE INTO THE
NEXT PHASE OF THE VERY AFTER
THAT THERE BE A CONSIDERATION
OF ADDITIONAL RESOURCES TO
REACH OUR MOST VULNERABLE
COMMUNITIES INCLUDING. TARGETED
SUPPORT FOR THE OUT. COMMUNITY
WHICH IS DISPROPORTIONATELY AT
RISK OF THE MEDICAL FINANCIAL
AND SOCIAL IMPACT OF PRO THE
NINETEEN AND YOU KNOW AS I'M
SURE YOU'VE SEEN AND WHY. ALL
DOLLARS HAVE FLOWED INTO. AT
THE STATE. COLLEGE FUNDING I WE
WOULD URGE IMMEDIATE TARGETED
FUNDING FOR LGBTQ PLUS PEOPLE
AND NONPROFIT THAT WE LOOK
FORWARD TO THE DISCUSSION
DURING NEXT WEEK- NEXT WEEK
HEARING AS WELL AND AGAIN.
THANK YOU THANK YOU AND HAVE A
COP FROM BEVERLY YOU. WE HAD.
YOU WANT. T. A JOINT
PARTNERSHIP WITH THE W. AND AT
THE YOU THANK YOU FOR HEARING
TODAY. WE'RE GRATEFUL FOR THE
MINISTRY. MILLION BACK
MANAGEMENT FAMILY HEALTHCARE
FOR CAN AFFECT SUPPLIES PP. I
THE TRICK IT QUICK A POSSIBLE
FOR ALL. WE SHOULD A TO FIFTEEN
AND TRACK YOUR CA
PROFESSIONAL WORKERS WHICH I
SUPPORT WOMEN CAUCUS YOUR
QUESTION COULD FUNDING TO
ENSURE CARE TO CENTRAL WORKERS.
HE ALSO URGED THE STATE THE
MARKET THE PEOPLE BGO. TO
CREATE A FUND FOR PROVIDE
RETAINS RECRUIT. WE THANK THE
COMING MIKE FELLOW BE IN A
TRUCK EIGHT WHITE RIDICULOUSLY
FOR FAMILIES HOW BY THAT THEY
COULD IMAGE OF THE CARE BY
DON'T ON BEHALF OF W. B. R. OF
THE MEASURE SHOULDN'T. BE LIKE
HOW CARE PROVIDER. HOWEVER THE
NEED TO REMAIN ME THINK ONLY
NUMBER. FOR HIS COMMENTS WE
URGE MORE TO HE PROMPT PROVIDER.
WE ALSO ARE MADE TO ENSURE THE
MAY WAGE GEN ONE AT ALL ARE
SHOULD WAIT A. AND LOCAL. THE
FEDERAL INCREASE THE FACT THE
THING AND ON WORKER ATTENTION
WILL FORWARD TO WORKING YOU ON
ISSUE THANK YOU THANK YOU. WE
HAVE COMMENT FOR MICHELE BIRTH
PLEASE GO AHEAD. MICHELLE I TO
FOR THE BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
DIRECTOR ASSOCIATE WANT TO
THANK THE AND MY PRETTY HEARING
AND IT'S- ASSEMBLY MEMBER THAT
ON THE LAN COOPER AS WELL IT
WOULD SURVEYS CONCERNS ABOUT
THE MENTAL HEALTH AND CLICK. IS
DISORDER NEEDS OF ALL
CALIFORNIANS COATED NINETEEN
WILL ABSOLUTELY AND HAS ALREADY
INCREASED DEMAND FOR PUBLIC
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH SERVICES
WHICH IS UP 22% NATIONWIDE AS-
MICHAEL. ASK ABOUT 7% FROM THE
PRIOR MONTH IF DURING PUBLIC
HEALTH CRISIS PLAYING OUT IN
PARALLEL WITH THE BROADER
PUBLIC HEALTH PANDEMIC AND THE
LONGER. INCLUDE THE MORE WE
INCREASES IN ANXIETY DEPRESSION
COGNITIVE DEFERRED SUICIDALITY
THE COUNTY WE HAVE A WHOLE.
ACTORS ALONG. CANCEL IT MANY
BARACK. AN ALLIANCE SEARCH AND
CAN SERVICES HAVE REQUESTED THE
ADMIN ESTABLISHED MILLION
DOLLAR. FUND TO STABILIZE OUR
BEHAVIOR HEALTH NET AND
PRESERVE COURT INFRASTRUCTURE
OUR FOLKS ARE ABSOLUTELY
FRONTLINE WORKERS WHO ARE NOT
CURRENTLY PRIORITIZE FOR P. P.
AND OTHER SORTS OF THE COURT
AND YET WE ARE INTEGRAL TO
ADRESS THE NEEDS OF HOMELESS
INDIVIDUALS. INMATES COMING OUT
OF PRISON COUNTY JAIL SURE YOU
KIDS WHO ARE HOME THANK YOU SO
MUCH TAKE CARE. THANK YOU END
UP ACTUALLY GO TO COREY SO
LEGAL COREY LINE IS OPEN. THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN VERSE
CHORUS ALSO ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA STATE SHERIFFS
ASSOCIATION I IN TERMS OF
COVERT NINETEEN RELATED FUNDING
ISSUES- CSS INSURERS ARE
WORKING WITH THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF CORRECTIONS AND
REHABILITATION DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE RELATED TO THE POT AND
CITY SEARS INTO. INMATES FROM
COUNTY JAILS AND THE FUNDING
DIRECT SHERIFF FOR THE COSTS
ASSOCIATED WITH HOLDINGS
INMATES IN JAILS WE APPRECIATE.
IT MINISTER CMMITMENT TO
PROVIDE THE FUNDS. WE
APPRECIATE THE DISCUSSION OF
PROTECTING LOCAL GOVERNMENTS-
AND FUNDING FOR PUBLIC SAFETY
AND LOOK FORWARD TO OUR
CONTINUED WORK TOGETHER TO
MITIGATE LIKELY DROP IN TAX
RECEIPTS THANK YOU. THANK YOU
THANK WE'LL GO NEXT TO
ELISABETH ESTEBAN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. MAMA WILL TRY THAT AGAIN
YOU ARE RIGHT GO AHEAD THANK
YOU. I THANK YOU CHAIRMAN AND
MEMBERS FOR HADN'T HAVING HERE
ON THIS IMPORTANT HEARING I'M A
STUDENT AT THE GARAGE HIGH
SCHOOL THERMAL CALIFORNIA. AND
I'VE BEEN NOTICING THAT MANY
STUDENTS AND THAT YOU COULD
TELL ABANDONED AS WELL AS OTHER
PLACES TO HOLD LOW INCOME AND
IMMIGRANT FAMILIES. DON'T HAVE
ACCESS TO THE INTERNET AND MOST
OF THE WORK IS ONLINE. IF YOU'D
LIKE WE'RE DISCONNECTED TOWARD.
AND WE ARE SURE YOUR- MAJORITY
OF THE FAMILIES IN OUR
COMMUNITY AND OUR DOCUMENTED SO
THESE KIDS DON'T HAVE SO MUCH
TO TEACH THEM. IT'S DIFFICULT.
WHEN THE- BODY THEIR
COMMUNITIES WHO ARE NOT HAVING
ACCESSIBLE TO CLEAN WATER AND A
TO FIFTEEN MANY LOW INCOME
FAMILIES. ARE REQUIRED. FOR
HELP TO HAPPEN BECAUSE WE'VE
BEEN WAITING FOR SO LONG
ELECTION HAPPY HAPPENING. IN
OUR LIVES I URGE TO. I DON'T.
THE GROUP OF MOST ONE PEOPLE
DID YOU COLD IN NINETEEN. THANK
YOU FOR YOUR TIME. THANK YOU
YOU HAD A COMMENT FROM A ANA
JOHN PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE MY NAME IS ANNA
JOHNSON WITH JOHN BURTON
ADVOCATES FOR YOU AND WE ARE
PART OF A LARGER COALITION OF
CHILD WHAT CARE USED DOCTOR.
AND RECEIVED ORGANIZATION- WE
HAVE SUBMITTED OUR- REQUEST IN
WRITING THEY COMMITTEE- ARE
ESSENTIALLY JUST RE EMPHASIZING
A HUGE THANK YOU FOR YOUR
LEADERSHIP AND PROTECT. FOR OF
OUR MOST MEMORABLE AND STATE
ARE USED TO OUR- YOUTH OF
COLOR- AND LGBT Q. IDENTIFYING
WHO ARE AT A HIGHER RISK OF
EXPERIENCING HOMELESSNESS. ARE
AT HIGHER RISK OF- COATED
NINETEEN EXPOSURE THROUGH
LIVING IN CONGREGATE CARE
FACILITIES SUCH AS GROUP HOMES
ARE STR TNCS- SHELTERS OR ADULT
SHELTER. AND THAT CHILDREN JUNE
ON. SO THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
THE LEADERSHIP TO DATE AND LOOK
FORWARD CONTINUING OUR
CONVERSATION WITH YOU-
ESPECIALLY IN LIGHT OF THE- OUR
NUMBERS OF ARE USED TO HAVE-
IDENTIFIED UNDERLYING HEALTH
CONDITIONS AND NEED SO THANK
YOU AGAIN THANK YOU. AND A
COMMENT FROM CATCH THE BIRD
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI THIS IS
KATHY BURKE WITH THE HEALTH
OFFICER THE POSITION OF
CALIFORNIA I WANT TO THANK YOU
FOR YOUR QUESTION TODAY ABOUT
CONTACT TRACING AND LOCAL
HEALTH DEPARTMENT RESOURCES- WE
LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING WITH
YOU AND WITH THE ADMINISTRATION
MAKE SURE LOCAL HELP. IN THE
BACK INTO CAN. CONNECT THAT
MAKE INTO ON GOING FUNDING THAT
WE CAN CONTAINS PRE OUTBREAKS
WELL WHEN THEY ARRIVE. WHETHER
IT BE ANOTHER NOVEL CORONAVIRUS
OVER THE PHONE OR AT THE DATA
BACK THERE WITH THAT- IN PUBLIC
HEALTH WE TALK A LOT ABOUT
DISEASE CONTROL AND PREVENTION.
AND YOU WANT TO THANK YOU FOR
YOUR DEDICATION. CONTROL RIGHT
NOW. AND. THE FUTURE. THANK YOU
THANK YOU ARE WILL GO TO
THERAPY PLEASE CALL. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR FOR HOSTING THIS
IMPORTANT HEARING THERE BRIDGE
ON BEHALF OF THE ASSOCIATION OF
HEALTH CARE. OKAY DIFFERENT
PROVIDE ME THE CRITICAL
SERVICES AFFECT YOUR TODAY
INCLUDING A CUTE AMERICANS EAT
CLINICAL DENTAL AND FILL
NURSING CARE. AND PROVIDE THE
FINANCIAL STRESS THAT OUR
HOSPITALS AND CLINICS HAVE ND
CONTINUE TO UNDERGO AS THEY
WORK TO ENSURE MAXIMUM SAFETY
DURING THE CRISIS. WELL WE CAN
MANY ADMINISTRATION'S EFFORT TO
SECURE ADDITIONAL FEDERAL
FUNDING FOR HEALTH SYSTEM WE
ENCOURAGE LUCKY. SURE ARE. FOR
AND COURTED DURING TIME. I
QUESTIONS REGARDING THE PRESS
THAT AN ECHO THAT TO MEET THESE
WERE UNDER NORMAL CIRCUMSTANCES
FOR SOME OF OUR SMALLER
HOSPITAL. OR TO WORKING WITH
THE LEGISLATURE AND
ADMINISTRATION TIME AND ARE
HAPPY TO SERVE AS A RESOURCE
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. AND THANK
YOU COME IN WILL BE DORNE
WILLIE THE LINE IS OPEN. REALLY
PERHAPS YOU MIGHT HAVE THE
PHONE NEEDED WE DO HAVE YOUR
LINE OPEN. IT AGAIN JUST
MOMENTS. OKAY SHEMAY HAVE A
TAKE IT OR SO BUT OF Q. WILL GO
TO MEGAN SUPERS MAKER IN THE
LINE OF OPEN. THANK YOU THANK
YOU FOR CHAIR AND MEMBERS MAKE
AND SUPER COMBI HALF OF
CALIFORNIA'S HEALTH PLUS
ADVOCATE FOR PREVENTING. ONE
THIRTEEN HUNDRED COMMUNITY
HEALTH CENTERS THAT ARE SEVEN
POINT TWO MILLION PEOPLE. I
THINK YOU AND IN THE FOR HAVING
THIS HEARING IT'S IMPORTANT TO
KNOW THE PP NEEDS THAT HEALTH
CENTER THERE ARE. TO THOSE IN
HOSPITALS URGENT NEED FOR AN
EIGHTY FIVE MASS GALLONS AND
FACE SHIELD. HELP YOU SHORT
LIMITING THEIR ABILITY. DEADLY
AND- CAST. TRIAGE. GEN NEARLY.
PP WE TALKED ABOUT TO COMING TO
BEAR WE ARE HOPE THAT THE
SITUATION WILL BEGIN TO RAPIDLY
IMPROVED- ADDITIONALLY ON
EXPERT HELP AN INTERESTING A
DROP IN PRIMARY CARE BUT IT'S
ABOUT 50% AND A 90% REDUCTION
AND FEDERAL INCOME WHICH WILL
RESULT FINANCIAL GAP ABOUT A
MILLION DOLLARS. A WEEK. WHERE
RIGHT THERE CHAMBER CLOSE IN
OVER HEALTH CENTER
ORGANIZATIONS THAT ARE
REPORTING FOR LOW'S OR LAY OFF
TO DOCTOR WOULD COMMENT EARLIER
THESE HEALTH CENTERS ARE TRYING
TO CONNECT WITH THESE PROVIDERS
WHAT THE HELL TO HELP POOR
OPPORTUNITIES- THAT ARE
AVAILABLE AS MUCH AS POSSIBLE
THE ABILITY TO. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. CURTIS LANE CURTIS
LINE IS OPEN. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR MEMBERS ON CHRIS LANG ON
BEHALF OF CALIFORNIA NURSES
ASSOCIATION REPRESENTING OVER A
HUNDRED THOUSAND REGISTERED
NURSES. BY INDIRECT CARE. TO
PATIENTS IN CALIFORNIA HELP
THIRTY WE APPRECIATE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO COMMENT THEIR
CONCERNS ABOUT PP SUPPLIES AND
PEE PEE. TERMINATION WE
UNDERSTAND THAT FORTY ONE POINT
FIVE MILLION IN NINETY FIVE
RESPIRATORS HAVE BEEN
DISTRIBUTED IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA WE ARE. I DID FOCUS.
HAVE ENOUGH SPEED TO BETTER
PROTECT OUR AND OTHER FUN HELP
FROM MY HEALTHCARE WORKERS MUST
REPORT TO YOU ARE NURSES HAVE
NOT SEEN THE IMPACT OF THIS
DISTRIBUTION AND THEIR UNIONS
IN MANY CASES EMPLOYERS ARE
HAVE LOCKED UP OR RASZYN IN
NINETY FIVE RESPIRATORS. THIS
IS ON. SOME BUSINESSES HAVE
BEEN DO FOR THE ORDER MAKING
THAT APPROPRIATE BE PROVIDING
WHEN TREATING KOBE NINETEEN OF
THE PATIENTS. WHO NEED
PROTECTION SHOULD HAVE ACCESS
TO THE FRONT RESTORATION-
RESPIRATORS WE ARE SUPPORTED BY
THE G. J. J. ALBEIT HE REQUEST
MINISTRATION IMPOSING GLOBALLY
UP A WEB PAGE THAT TELLS THE
STATE'S STOCKPILE SO MUCH. IN
THE- THANK YOU. ALRIGHT WE'LL
GO TO IT ROOM I OF OPEN. MY AND
GRAHAM ACLU OF CALIFORNIA WHILE
WE APPRECIATE TODAY'S
DISCUSSION ON PROJECT ROOM HE
AND THE GOVERNOR'S ANNOUNCEMENT
WEEKEND LOCALITIES ACTED
QUICKLY ENOUGH TO MOVE PEOPLE
INTO HOTELS AND MOTELS. WHERE
THEY ACTIVATE MOVED ONLY A
MINUTE THE PERCENTAGE OF THEIR
AND COMMUNITY AND PRIVATE RIGHT.
VISUAL FOR ME SHOP DEVASTATING
OUTBREAK ARE OCCURRING
INCLUDING IN SAN FRANCISCO
WHERE ONE SHELTERS FOLLOW OVER
A HUNDRED PEOPLE TEST ODDNESS.
ALLOCATING FUNNY ALONE IS
INSUFFICIENT WHEN
IMPLEMENTATION AND DIRT BIKE
COMMUNITY DYNAMICS THE LACK OF
BACKING. WE ASK OUR RIGOROUS
LEGISLATIVE OVERSIGHT TO FOCUS
ON A HOUSING FIRST AND NON
CONGREGATE HOUSING POLLUTION
MODEL. PROVIDED WRITTEN COMEDY
TELLING THAT OVERSIGHT AND
SHARE A STORY OF AN ORANGE
COUNTY RESIDENT WHO'S IN A
GROUP SHELTER CHOOSING IN COMP
I AND CURRENT LIVE IN A CROWDED
IT ALMOST ALTER OVER TO AN- ALL.
THAT RIGHT THE LACK. HI MAN
RESULT OF. THANK SEVEN THE
PROMISED FOR OVER A WEEK BUT
THE FACT THAT THEY WON'T EVEN
FOR OUR FOR AN WEEK NO ONE HAD
BEEN OFFERED ROOM THANK YOU.
THANK YOU AND WE'LL GO NEXT TO.
THANK YOU WITH THE TERM MEMBER
A LOOK AT THE HIGH ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA SPECIAL
DISTRICTS DESTINATION
INDEPENDENT BACK OF THE TRUCK
ON THE FRONT LINES OF COVER
NINETEEN RESPOND TO CONTINUE TO
ENSURE THAT THE LESS CRITICAL
LOCAL SERVICES SUCH AS WATER
WASTEWATER AND POLICE
PROTECTION HELPED. RE
INTRODUCE. AMONG OTHERS.
COOPERATE NOT. COUNTED DISTRICT
ARE NOW FACING THE RESULT
COMPANY RESPOND ARE. NINETEEN
MOTOR PARTY ANTICIPATING. A
MAJOR FINANCIAL IMPACT MANY
INDICATING THEY ONLY TO DRIVE
OWN HERTZBERG REDUCE DOCKING
AND KEPT. ME WITHIN THE NEXT
SIX MONTHS. ANY OF THE- AND BY
COVER NINETEEN OF THE PROVIDER
THE VITAL SERVER THE THINKER
INTEREST IN AREAS NO IMPACT BY
THE STATE CAPPED OFF WHILE BY
AND RECENT DR AND THEN. IN
ORDER TO CONTINUE THE REBELLION
THE NEXT LEVEL AFTER. SPECIAL
DISTRICTS WILL NEED ACCESS TO
TRICKLE RELIEF MEASURES. WE
APPRECIATED THE DISCUSSION
CONCERNING ACCESS TO FUNDING
FOR LOCAL GOVERNMENT AFTER
LOCAL GOVERNMENT OF ALL SIZES
INCLUDING SPECIAL PROJECT
FEEDBACK WILL SHARE THE
FINANCIAL RELIEF FROM THE
FEDERAL STIMULUS. I'VE BEEN
ALLOCATE THIS STATE. IS NOT
FUNNY BECOME AVAILABLE A
DIFFICULT BECAUSE OF BEING IN
THE- YOU CAN REMEMBER LOOK FOR
YOU CAN YOU WORK ON
ADMINISTRATION THE COLLISION
BUT THEY PART. THANK YOU. SO TO
JAIL. FOR THIRD DEGREE THE LINE
IS OPEN. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS JACQUI
PROSTITUTE WITH THE CALIFORNIA
SCHOOL EMPLOYEES ASSOCIATION
REPRESENTING ABOUT TWENTY FIFTY
THOUSAND CLASS I'M SORRY IN A
PUBLIC SCHOOL. THIS FOOD
SERVICE WORKERS CURRENTLY ON
THE FRONT LINES DISTRIBUTING
DAILY BREAKFAST AND LUNCH IS TO
OUR STUDENTS AND THEIR
FAMILIES. MANY BUS DRIVERS
DOLLAR TO HELP DELIVER MEALS
INTO NEIGHBORHOODS AND AUGUSTO
DIAS ARE LOOKING ALL. HOUSE
SITE. CLEAN AND ONE NOTE WE
HAVE KEY COMES ABOUT C. KEEP A
MEMBER. AS YOU KNOW SB ONE ONE
SEVEN ALLOCATE A HUNDRED
MILLION TO BE SPENT A
PROTECTIVE EQUIPMENT. I THINK
THE PIE AND BECAUSE DON'T YOUR
SERVICES AT THE END OF BILLS
SAY THE TEETH I THINK. THIS
LEARNING. THEIR THAT THE GUY UP
WHAT. A THESE FUNDS TO COVER
THE FUNDING. COULD LEAD TO THE
DEPLETION OF CRITICAL DOLLARS.
I WILL BE THAT THE LEGISLATURE
CAN ENSURE THE NECESSARY.
RESOURCES ARE PROVIDED AND THAT
DOLLARS. EIGHTY TWO HEALTH AND
SAFETY IN SCHOOLS I SPENT
COOKERS. TO WORKING WITH YOU TO
THE LIBERATION THE BILL IN ITS
BUDGET THAT MAKES MY SCHOOL
FUNDING TO PREVENT THEY ARE.
SURE THAT OUT WELL YOU'D HAVE
TO PUT THE KIDS NEED THANK YOU
THANK YOU. AND WE HAVE A
COMMENT FROM ENTRY AT RIVER
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
KEREN MEMBERS IN TRAILER THERE
ARE REPRESENTING THE CALIFORNIA
IMMIGRANT POLICY CENTER I'D
LIKE TO START BY THANKING YOU
FOR YOUR LEADERSHIP ON CLOTHES
NINETEEN RESPONSES ON BEHALF OF.
THE STATE IT IS CRITICAL THAT
WE CONTINUE TO BUILD ON THIS
MOMENTUM AND ENSURE THE PUBLIC
SAFETY OF ALL CALIFORNIANS.
COPE WITH NINETEEN AS A
PANDEMIC THAT REQUIRE
EXTRAORDINARY RESPONSES IN
ORDER TO COMMUNICATE THE
PROPORTIONATE IMPACTS ON
COMMUNITIES OF COLOR AND IN
PARTICULAR WHEN IT COMES TO
REDUCING OUR JAIL POPULATION
AND DETENTION FACILITY
AFFILIATION. ACCORDING TO ICE
THERE IS A TOTAL OF ONE HUNDRED
AND TEN CONFIRMED CASES IN
DETENTION FACILITIES
NATIONALLY- BOTH WITH DETAINEES
AT EMPLOYEES. THE AGENCY HAS
RESPONDED BY OPTING TO LOCK ALL
DETAINEES THEMSELVES FOR UP TO
TWENTY HOURS A DAY IN AN EFFORT
TO REDUCE THE AMOUNT OF TIME
SPENT IN. AND WE ALL KNOW THIS
IS NOT ABOUT HOW IS YOU CAME
AND THE SHOULD THE REST OF THE
NATION AND THE EFFORT SPEND ANY
OPERATIONS THAT COULD LEAD TO
THE CONFINEMENT OF INDIVIDUALS
AND HEALTH AND SAFETY AND-
THANK YOU. AND A COMMENT FROM
MICHELE GIBBONS PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD AFTERNOON MICHELLE GELLER
THAT THE COUNTY HEALTH
EXECUTIVE THE SENSATION OF
CALIFORNIA AND WE APPRECIATE
THE DEPTH OF THE ISSUES RELATED
TO THE RESPONSE THAT HAVE BEEN
RAISED HERE TODAY I WANT TO
REMIND EVERYONE THAT OUR LOCAL
PUBLIC HEALTH TO. THE I AM BY
ALL INSURANCE COMMUNITY THAT.
PART OF WHAT MADE THE RESPONSE
EFFORTS ARE CHALLENGING IS THE
LACK OF SUFFICIENT RESOURCES
INVESTED INTO PUBLIC HEALTH.
CUTTING MANY OTHER FACTORS CAN
BE ADVERSELY IMPACTED. I WANT
TO THANK ASSEMBLY MEMBER BLANCA
MATCHING THE WALLET CONTACT ME
THING AN ECHO THE COMMENTS MADE
FROM CATBIRD BECAUSE- OPENING
OUR COMMUNITIES PEOPLE. WITH
OUR ABILITY TO CON CANNOT
CONTACT CAKING IN ISOLATION AND
CARRY OUT OTHER CORE PUBLIC
HELPFUL. EVEN WITH TECHNOLOGY A
VOLUNTEER SUPPLEMENTING THAT
AFTER AND NO THE SHORT TERM.
THE CAPACITY AT LOCAL HEALTH
DEPARTMENT NEED TO BE BUILT AND
TO SUSTAIN OVER THE LONG TERM
FOR THAT WERE ADEQUATELY
RESOURCE DEFEND AGAINST. THE
NINETEEN AND- OTHER PUBLIC
THREAT. THIRTY NINE OKAY. THAT
ARE STATED FACING A REALLY
BELIEVE THAT THE- OF OUR
ECONOMY AND THE COMMUNITY THE
THIRD DEPEND ON THE WORK OF OUR
LOCAL HEALTH DEPARTMENT. AND WE
REALLY NEED RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST THAT THE ADMINISTRATION
AND THE LEGISLATURE- DEDICATED
SIGNIFICANT AT I'M NOT
RESOURCES TO BOLSTER. AND THE
HEALTH COMMUNITY THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. AND THAT COMMENT
FROM BARBARA GLAZER PLEASE GO
AHEAD. THANK YOU BARBARA GLAZER
WITH THE CALIFORNIA HOSPITAL
ASSOCIATION HOSPITAL'S VERY
MUCH APPRECIATE THE STATE'S
RAPID RESPONSE TO ADDRESS THE
CODE THE NINETEEN PANDEMIC.
THERE IS NO GREATER PRIORITY
FOR HOSPITALS AND PROTECTING
THE SAFETY OF THEIR PATIENTS
AND STAFF. THE INVESTMENT THE
STATE MADE IN PERSONAL
PROTECTIVE EQUIPMENT
UNDOUBTEDLY HAS STABILIZED.
HOSPITAL AT THE FOREFRONT OF
CALIFORNIA'S RESPONSE TO THE
PUBLIC HEALTH EMERGENCY HAVE
BEEN CRIPPLED FINANCIALLY
BEGINNING IN FEBRUARY TO
PREPARE TO CARE FOR TENS OF
THOUSANDS OF POTENTIAL CO GOOD
NINETEEN POSITIVE PATIENT UP
IT'LL BEGAN TO PURCHASE MASSIVE
AMOUNTS OF SUPPLIES. SO SPEND
THE NON EMERGENCY SURGERIES AND
OTHER PROCEDURES AND BEGAN TO
TRANSFER SUBACUTE PATIENTS TO
OTHER APPROPRIATE CARE SETTING.
THESE ACTIONS HAVE RESULTED IN
A SHARP UNEXPECTED REDUCTION IN
REVENUE AS MUCH AS 50% MANY
CASESTHAT IT'S MAKING IT HARD
FOR SOME HOSPITAL TO MAKE
WEEKLY PAYROLL AND PRETENDING A
GREAT THREAT TO MANY HOSPITALS
BY ABILITY. THIS EXTREME
FINANCIAL DISTRESS IS AN
EXISTENTIAL THREAT CALIFORNIANS
HEALTHCARE. IT'LL TAKE GRATEFUL
FOR THE ABILITY TO BE ART OF
THE CONVERSATION AS WE WORK TO
REBUILD THE DEVASTATED SYSTEM
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. CAN
COMMENT- FROM AARON APATHY
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO ERIN OUT
THE ON BEHALF OF PUBLIC
ADVOCATE THE NUMBER OF THE LTFS
EQUITY COALITION THANK YOU
CHAIR TEAM COMMITTEE IN FACT WE
WANT TO RECOGNIZE THE
LEADERSHIP OF THE
ADMINISTRATION AND THE
DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION AND
WORKING WITH SCHOOL DISTRICT
DURING THE PANDEMIC. THE CRISIS
IS FREE AND ALL THE COMMUNITY
CENTER RIGHT A RANGE OF SOCIAL
EMOTIONAL PHYSICAL WANNA
SUPPORT. THE PHARMACY
VULNERABLE STUDENT THE FAMILY
CORD TO. IMPACTED LOCAL.
CALIFORNIA K. TWELVE EDUCATION
FUNDING LEVEL WITH INADEQUATE
HEADING INTO THIS CRISIS. AND A
LEARNING LOS THIS SPRING WILL
ONLY EXACERBATE EXISTING
ACHIEVEMENT GAP. THE RESULT
EVEN GREATER FINANCIAL NEED.
MANY STUDENTS AND FAMILIES AND
COMMUNITIES DO NOT HAVE ACCESS
TO TECHNOLOGY NECESSARY FOR
DISTANCE LEARNING AND FOR OTHER
ESSENTIAL SERVICES HELLO
HEALTHCARE. THEY'LL BE RECALL
LONG AFTER. THREE OF THEM.
EDUCATION BUT PROVIDED NOT BE
ONE SEVEN. AND THAT'S THE
ALLEGED PROVIDED FUNDING FOR
SCHOOLS IN THE BUDGET YEAH ON
THE PROPOSITION NINETY EIGHT
MINIMUM GUARANTEE THE
LEGISLATURE COVER NINETEEN
RESPONSIBLE CAPACITY FOR
DISTRICT PEOPLE. THE BUDGET AND
THE FAMILIES OF THE GREATEST
NEEDS PARTICULARLY IF DECISIONS
ARE MADE TO ADDRESS LOCAL
CONCERNS. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
AND A COMMENT FROM- DESIREE
JONES PLEASE GO AHEAD. DESIREE
JONES HERE ON BEHALF OF LOS
ANGELES METRO THE STATE'S
LARGEST PUBLIC TRANSPORTATION
AGENCY THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
HOLDING THIS IMPORTANT HEARING
TODAY WE WANTED TO NOTE FOR
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE THAT
WE CONTINUE TO OPERATE LIFELINE
BUT IN RAIL SERVICE. CONTAINING
THE HEALTH AND SAFETY OF OUR
PATRONS AND EMPLOYEES IS OUR
AGENCIES IN NUMBER ONE
PRIORITY. WILL CONTINUE TO
CARRY A SERVICE WORKERS AND
LINE BULLIES AS WELL AS THOSE
THAT RELY ON PUBLIC TRANSIT IN
THEIR DAILY LIVES BUT OUR
RIDERSHIP IS DOWN OVER SEVENTY
PERCENT. OUR STAFF OPERATORS
MAKE. AN ATTENDANT ARE WORKING
AROUND THE CLOCK TO PROVIDE.
OUT WE HAVE WRITTEN. AND IF
THEY CAN'T LOS IN REVENUES THE
FEDERAL THAT'S HAVE HELPED WITH
RESPECT OUR OPERATIONS BUT THEY
WILL NOT BE ENOUGH WE'RE ASKING
THE STATE TO WORK WITH US TO
PROVIDE DIRECT ASSISTANCE SO
THAT WE CAN TO PROVIDE VITAL
SERVICES TO THE OVER TEN
MILLION. THAT WE- HERE IN LOS
ANGELES COUNTY AS THE ECONOMY
CONTINUES TO SLOW LOCAL SALES
TAX REVENUES THANK YOU. AND
COMMENTED FROM TIM MADDEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK YOU
ASSEMBLYMEMBER TAKE A MEMBERS
HAD MAD REPRESENT THE
CALIFORNIA CHAPTER OF THE
AMERICAN COLLEGE OF EMERGENCY
PHYSICIANS EMERGENCY PHYSICIAN
TOLD UNIQUE IN CRITICAL ROLE IN
OUR HEALTHCARE SYSTEM WHEN IT
COMES TO THIS PANDEMIC. WE ALL
WANT TO NEED EMERGENCY
PHYSICIAN TO BE AVAILABLE
WENTY FOUR SEVEN BASIS
ESPECIALLY IN THESE TIMES OF
CRISIS A BIRD SUFFICIENT PRIDE
BEING ON THE FRONT LINES
HELPING ANYONE WHO COMES IN TWO
OUR EMERGENCY DEPARTMENT. EVEN
IF AS IS THE CASE WITH THE CALL
THE PANDEMIC IT PUTS OUR OWN
LIVES AT RISK AS WELL AS OUR
LOVED ONES KING WHAT ARE
MEMBERS WE HAVE HEARD THE
VOLUME. COMING INTO THE PERSON
I MEANT FOR THE PAST FOUR WEEKS
DECLINE BY 40% THE NUMBER LOOK
EVERY BIT MORE. THE CLIMB. FOR
MURDER POSITION TO OUR IN. BY
HANS. THIS IS THE RESULT IN
THEM HAVING THEIR INC REDUCE AS
RE OF THE IN RED FROM. VISITS
WE ARE WORRIED AT THE AFFECTED
THIS REDUCTION AND PATIENT
VISITS AT THE TIME TO GET IT
INSPECTED TO CONTINUE
POTENTIALLY INTO TWO THOUSAND
TWENTY ONE. THE CHALLENGE FOR
MERCY FISHING GROUPS AND TO
MAINTAIN LEVEL STAFF TO GET
OUR- DEPARTMENT. THAT IS NEEDED
TO CONTINUE TO MEET THE ONGOING
SEARCHES THAT ARE JUST PAINTED
THINKING WE HAVE SUBMITTED A
REQUEST FOR SOME FINANCIAL
ASSISTANCE IN THE- FUTURE.
THANK YOU. AND A COMMENT FROM
CONNIE DELGADO COUNTY PLEASE GO
AHEAD. WITH YOUR CHAIR NUMBER
TWENTY DELGADO ON BEHALF BUT
AFTER TALK IT'LL LEADERSHIP
FORM REPRESENTING CALIFORNIA
THIRTY FIVE DISTRICT MUNICIPAL
HOSPITAL WE'RE THANKFUL FOR
TODAY'S DISCUSSION INCLUDING
THE COMMENT MADE BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER WOULD WE ARE PLEASED TO
PARTNER WITH STAKEHOLDERS
DURING THE UNPRECEDENTED PINE
YOU KNOW. THERE WILL BE
NUMEROUS IMPACTS ON OUR COUNTRY
AND IN CALIFORNIA AND EACH
CALIFORNIAN RESULTING FROM AN
ACTIVE BEACH RELATED TO OF IT
NINETEEN SHOULD CRUCIAL THAT
CALIFORNIA DISTURBING AT THE
HOSPITAL BE GIVEN. THE SUPPORT
TO SURVIVE IN PROVIDE NEEDED
CARE TO THOSE IN THEIR
COMMUNITIES AND CALIFORNIA A
WHOLE AND WE LOOK FORWARD TO
CONTINUE A CONVERSATION THANK
YOU THANK. YOU AND WE ARE GO
TO. CENTER PLEASE GO. GOOD
AFTERNOON DANIEL SANCHEZ ON
BEHALF OF THE CHIEF PROBATION
OFFICERS I THINK THE ONSET OF
THE PANDEMIC COUNTY PROBATION
DEPARTMENT HAVE BEEN QUICKLY
ADOPTED BEST PRACTICES TO
PROTECT THE HEALTH AND SAFETY
OF OUR CLIENTS OUR STAFF AND
THE COMMUNITY. WE SUBMITTED A
LETTER THAT GOES INTO MUCH MORE
DETAIL BUT- WE HAVE TAKEN
SIGNIFICANT STEPS TO FURTHER
LIMIT YOU CAN OUR JUVENILE
FACILITY MAKING THE WHOLE WHO
STATE OF OUR FOOTBALL FOR
SOUTH. MAIN CHANGING IN
PROCEDURES IN THE COMMUNITY
WERE USING TECHNOLOGY PART TO
CHECK IN WITH. SUPERVISION OUR
FAVORITE IN HIGH NEED END OF.
WORK IN PERSON TO PROVIDE. ON
IN ACCORDANCE  SOCIAL BUT
SIMPLY PRACTICES. I'M ONE OF
THE AREAS I WANT TO TOUCH ON IT
AND THAT WILL BE CHIU UNDER P.
R. C. S. EARLY RELEASES IN THE
CHANGES WE'VE- MADE TO HELP
OTHER PARTS OF THE SYSTEM
MANAGE THIS CRISIS- WITH THESE-
THESE PEOPLE COMING BACK. TO US.
THE INDEX. THERE CERTAINLY
SIGNIFICANT. WE HAVE A
COMPREHENSIVE INFORMATION AS
AND MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES ARE.
SIGNIFICANT NEED THOSE
POPULATION. WE APPRECIATE THE
EMERGENCY MITIGATION FUNDING
FOR THAT- WERE ALSO USING
PREACH TITLE- OPTIONS TO HELP
SUPERVISORS. WHILE IN. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU WILL GO AND NEXT
TO MEGALI CAN K. THE LINER OPEN.
HI GOOD AFTERNOON MY VALLEY
KINCAID FROM PUBLIC ADVOCATE
REGARDING THE HIGHER EDUCATION
BUDGET WE RECOMMEND THAT THE
LEGISLATURE REQUEST THE PUBLIC
IN MISSIONS OF HIGHER EDUCATION
TO PRIORITIZE TRANSPARENCY AND
PROVIDE A REPORT REGARDING HOW
THEY WILL BE SPENDING THE
FEDERAL DOLLARS. HOLLY WILL
COLLECTED INCLUDE IN INPUT ON
STUDENT NEED AND THE CRITERIA
THEY PLAN TO USE TO DISTRIBUTE.
WRECKED EMERGENCY AID TO. THE
REQUESTED INCLUSIONS ALSO
PRIORITIZE UNDOCUMENTED
STUDENTS WITH THE SUPPORT AND
RESOURCES THEY NEED A THE AT.
AND THEY ARE NOT INCLUDED THE
FACT IN THE STATE PROVIDE%
SUPPORT TO CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY
COLLEGES THAT THEY SERVE MANY
STUDENTS. PART TIME STUDENT
INCLUDING UNDOCUMENTED STUDENTS
AND WITH HIGH. THEY ARE NOT
INCLUDED IN THAT. I THANK YOU
TO THE COMMITTEE THE GOVERNOR
AND ALL THAT AND THE POOR TO
WORKING TO ADDRESS THESE ISSUES.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. THANK YOU
I WILL GO TO I'LL YET- GRIPPING
THE LINE IS OPEN. HI KAREN
MEMBERS ONLY AGREEING WITH THE
AMERICAN FEDERATION OF STATE
COUNTY AND MUNICIPAL EMPLOYEES
MANY OF OUR CONCERNS AND REYES
THROUGHOUT THE REALLY
THOUGHTFUL DISCUSSION TODAY.
THE RIVER THAT MEMBERS IN A LOT
OF DIFFERENT SETTING AND WILL
BE SUBMITTING WRITTEN COMMENTS
TO DIVE DEEPER INTO SPECIFIC
AREAS. JUST WANTED TO TAKE A
MOMENT TO ELEVATE SOME OF THE
ISSUES- MUCH HAS BEEN SAID
ABOUT SECURING PP FOR OUR
HEALTHCARE WORKERS WHICH- RIGHT
NOW AT. I LEARN SOMETHING OF A-
BECAUSE- ABOUT WHO ABOUT
EMPLOYEE IS. I WOULD ADD THAT
ASK ME ALSO REPRESENT NON
MEDICAL CENTRAL EMPLOYEES. WHO
CONTINUE TO WORK WITH
VULNERABLE POPULATION AND ALSO
HAVE SAFETY CONCERNS THAT MUST
NOT BE LOST IN THE
CONVERSATION- FOR EXAMPLE WE
HAVE. COUNTY THE WORKER TO
CONTINUE THEIR WORK WITH HOME
OF THE HOMELESS POPULATION. AND
AGILITY WORKERS FOR INTERACTING
WITH THE PUBLIC DALY. IF WE
CAN'T GET BY THESE EMPLOYEES PP
MANY TO MAKE SURE THAT WE ARE
OFFERING. A DEEPER CAUTION-
LIKE. ONE OF THE TEAM. WRITING
HEALTHCARE FOR FEDERAL EMPLOYEE
THE FOR MILLION IS TO COME FOR
AT BUT WE ARE YOU CAN
ADDITIONAL FUNDS FOR CHILD ECHO
THE EARLIER COMMENTS THE W. IN
REGARD TO RURAL HOSPITALS WE
SHARE SOMETHING MEMBER PHAM
CONCERNED ABOUT THE FINANCIAL
CRISIS OUR ROLE HOSPITALS ARE
SEEN. ROLL HOSPITAL SYSTEM THAT
HAVE BEEN UNIQUELY IMPACTED BY
COVERED NINETEEN PATIENTS. ARE
THE MAJOR CRIMES IN REVENUE
FROM POSTPONING ELECTIVE
SURGERIES AND- A GROWING
EMPLOYEES AT THE TIME THANK YOU
OKAY THANK YOU I WILL GO NEXT
TO THE LINE OF WINDOWS TENERIFE
ISLAND IN THE LINE OF OPEN.
I'LL BE TRIED AGAIN I JUST
MOMENT- LINDA ME OF DROPPED
WILL GO TO MAUREEN WASHBURN THE
LINE IS OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON
WEARING WASHBURN WITH THE
CENTER ON JUVENILE AND CRIMINAL
JUSTICE. I WANT TO EXPRESSED
GREAT CONCERN OVER THE SAFETY
OF NEW IN THE STATE'S DIVISIONS
JUVENILE JUSTICE. DJJ EKG YOU'D
HAVE BEEN LAUGHED OUT OF THE
EARLY RELEASE HAPPENING
THROUGHOUT THE REST FIFTEENTH
WE ARE AND WE ARE. NOT TIME
BEFORE THE VIRUS SPREADS
QUICKLY READ. OF NINETEEN
COMMITTEE AND OTHER STATE
LEADERS TO TAKE IMMEDIATE
ACTION TO SAFEGUARD VULNERABLE
YOUNG PEOPLE THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. OUR GLOBAL OCCUR MARINO
WASHBURN PLEASE GO AHEAD. NEXT
LOCAL CZYTANY IN COEBURN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. THANK. THE SPINNING
COOPER REPRESENTING THE
CALIFORNIA ALTERNATIVE PAYMENT
PROGRAM ASSOCIATION PRIOR TO
THE EMERGENCY EIGHTY COMMUNITY
PARTNERS HAD ALREADY EXTENDED
THEIR TWENTY NINETEEN TWENTY
CONTRACT AND VOUCHERS FOR
SERVING SIXTY THOUSAND FAMILIES
AND CHILDREN. DURING THE CRISIS
WITH THE ELIMINATION OF
COLLECTION OF FAMILY FEES THIS
MUCH NEEDED RESPITE FOR
FAMILIES CREATED THE SCENARIO
WHERE MANY CONTRACTORS ARE NOW
OVER IT RULED IN THEIR
CONTRACT. IN REGARDS TO THE
SIXTY THOUSAND OUT THEY'VE BEEN
MAXED OUT LET ME PUT THAT
NUMBER IN CONTEXT AND JUST STEP
OF THE TWENTY SIX CATEGORIES OF
ESSENTIAL WORKERS ARE THE
ESSENTIAL HEALTHCARE WORKERS
TOTALING FOUR HUNDRED AND SIXTY
TWO THOUSAND. WITH CHILDREN
UNDER THE AGE OF FOURTEEN OF
THAT NUMBER ROUGHLY A HUNDRED
AND THIRTEEN THOUSAND OUR
FAMILY THAT EIGHTY FIFTH AT
LINE LEVEL. SO I ASSEMBLYMEMBER
MCCARTY PRIOR TO CRY THERE IT
ALLOW ABOUT. CHILD CARE AT THE
RIGHT IS THE MATH THE PART THAT
ISSUE. THE REGARD TO
HIGHLIGHTING THE NEED OF A SUCH
A WORKERS ARE ACTIVE. WORKERS
IN FAMILY SOMETHING GREATLY. I
AM HEARING YOUR- THANK YOU.
MAXWELL GOAL TO THAT WOULD J.
LEAVE HAD. HELLO COULD NOT WAS
A AS YOU HERE RIGHT THAT
HUNDRED THE CITY HOW. THIS SORT
OF WANT TO QUICKLY HIGHLIGHTS
AND POP THAT WE UP THAT ARE THE
PRESS INCLUDING JUST NEED FOR
THE DESPERATE NEED FOR PEOPLE
ON THE GROUND IN SUPPORT
GOVERNOR ANNOUNCED BUT WOULD
LOVE TO SEE SOME ADDITIONAL
TEN. AND THAT IS WHY ECHOED BY
YOUR CALL TODAY A DISH. SHAPE
THE- WORK TO SERVE GOD DOCKING
COMMUNITIES THAT WE NEED TO DO
MORE AND WOULD LIKE TO ECHO THE
ALEJO'S REPORT AROUND. YEAH
THANK. MAX LOCAL TO RONALD
COLMAN. GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER
CHAIR AND MEMBERS THANK YOU
RONALD CALLING ON BEHALF OF
HEALTH ACT OF CALIFORNIA WE
SUPPORT THE CALL BY THE
LEGISLATURE AND THE NIXON
ADMINISTRATION ON THE NEED FOR
MORE FEDERAL TO OUR STATE AND
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS HEALTH AT.
LETTER WE WITH OVER. FIVE OR-
OUT FOR A AT THE FEDERAL LEVEL
ON HEALTH INSURANCE
AFFORDABILITY ASSISTANT
IMMIGRANT INCLUSIVITY AND
FEDERAL POLICIES. ENSURING THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT COVERS ALL
STATE HELPING HER TO COST
SHARING FROM PATIENTS FOR
TREATMENT. AND TO WORK TOWARDS
STRONG PROTECTION FOR HEALTH
CARE CONSUMERS ALL OF THIS WILL
BE NEEDED TO EFFECTIVELY
RECOVER FROM THE CRISIS. WE
UNDERSTAND THE TOUGH DECISIONS
NEED TO BE MADE GIVEN THE
FISCAL OUTLOOK AND NEVER
RETURNING TO WORK LOAD BUT WE
DO UNDERSTAND. THAT HEALTHCARE
INVESTMENT. ALLOCATED TO GET US
OUT OF THIS PANDEMIC AND MAKE
SURE THAT WE CAN BETTER FOR.
ONE AND SO. THAT'S FOR VISUAL
WE NEED TO KEEP CAL. FOR AND
MAY SURE WE CAN CONTINUE.
PROPOSAL BY OUT TO BE A DOCTOR.
ACTUALLY TAKES GOOD. HERE'S.
THANK YOU THANK YOU. THANK YOU
WILL GO TO DARBY KERN WILL IS
OPEN. HI THANK YOU KING MEMBER
AND DARBY KERR AND WITH CAL
STATE AT THE THAT RECORD ALL
FIFTY EIGHT COUNTY THERE'S BEEN
A GREAT HEARING TODAY I THANK
YOU FOR IT. AND YOU KNOW THE
CASE THESE ARE ON THE FRONT
LINES OF THIS CRISIS AND PAN
MEG AND COUNTY ARE WORKING HARD
AND SORRY FRIEND FROM PUBLIC
HEALTH OFFICERS AMERICAN P.
OPERATE CENTER HUMAN SERVICES
FAILED MEANT. BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
NINE ONE ONE SERVICE IN CORNERS
COUNT I MEAN THIS TO KEEP THE
STATE FORWARD AND AS WE'RE
DOING THIS CASE LOAD THEIR
WRITING CASH FLOW IS GETTING
TIGHT AND MANY COUNTY. AND
OTHERS ARE BURNING THEIR RICH
RAPIDLY. AND. BUT WE ARE
RESPONDING IN WITH THE STATE
YEAH THAT AS THE STATE BUDGET
IN ME THAT WE HAVE REDUCED. WE
WERE TOGETHER PARTNERS TO MAKE
CAN. AS A FRONTLINE PROVIDERS
THE REVENUE TO KEEP OUR
SERVICES IN PLACE THANK YOU
MORE CONCERNED WITH THAT
DECLINE IN THE STATE REVENUE
BECAUSE OF THE DIRECTLY TIED IN
NINETEEN NINETY ONE AND TWO
THOUSAND WRITTEN. A LETTER
REALIGNMENT. THANK YOU AND-
NEXT- WE GO TO THE LINE OF KIM
LEWIS THE LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD KIM. YEAH THANK YOU
CAN LOW IT'S REPRESENTING THE
CALIFORNIA COALITION FOR YEARS
THAT THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY STAY. WITH THE
MEDICAL MEDICAMENTOS ADDITIONAL
DETAILS I JUST WANTED TO
ELEVATE THE NEED THAT ARE YOU
EXPERIENCING HOMELESSNESS- I'M
ESPECIALLY WILL BE AT THE END
FIND THEIR- DIRECTED TOWARDS
THE NEW. HOMELESS MAN WE KNOW
THAT ARE YOU SOMETIME OFTEN GET
TRIGGER AND THAT THE FUNDING
DIDN'T HAVE THE SAME FOR THE
RED REQUREMENTS AT THE
LEGISLATURE PUT IN WHICH YOU
CAN HAPPEN HOPE THAT- THE
LEGISLATURE WILL CONTINUE TO
FOCUS ON ARE YOU GOING FORWARD.
THANK YOU AGAIN. OKAY THANK YOU
AND THAT WE'RE GOING NEXT TO
THE LINE OF KRISTEN NAM CHECK A
CRYSTALLINE THE LINE IS OPEN.
THE AFTERNOON THE NUMBER BEHALF%
OF THE CALIFORNIA PARTNERSHIPS
AND COULD NOT BE FOUND WANT TO
THANK YOU FOR YOUR LEADERSHIP
AND RESPONSE TO THE COMPLEX
ISSUES- ALSO WANT TO MAKE SURE
WE LIFT UP OF THE NEEDS OF
DOMESTIC FOUND THE FIVE VERY.
FOR WHOM THE SHELTER HOME IS
NOT A SAFE PLACE. WE'RE ALREADY
HERE SERVICE PROVIDERS ABOUT
INCREASE CALLED OUR HOTLINE.
MAN OUR SERVICE. AND WE ALSO Q.
AWARE HOW MANY DRIVERS WE CAN
BE OUT RIGHT NOW BECAUSE OF
THEIR ON LIVING- OKAY FLATTEN
THE KOBE KIRBY BEGIN OPEN BACK
UP AT ME AND- A REALLY. URGING
SERVICE REQUEST REALLY. I WON.
SURVIVORS OF A NEED. OR IF YOU
CRISIS AND BE. THE REAL FORWARD
TO PARTNERING YOU IF COMPLETING
MAKES OUR THAT THAT THEY AND-
IN THAT MEET THEIR- ARE. FUNDED
TO BE ABLE TO. PROVIDE THE
SERVICE THAT THEY NEED A
ADDRESS THEIR HOUSE AND PUBLIC
SAFETY. THANK YOU THE YOU. AND
COMMENT FROM JEAN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. THANK YOU MISTER MEMBERS
GENE HURT YOUR BE OF THE OR
COUNTIES CAL. SHE HAD THE
SUPPORT AND- FROM THE STATE AND
FEDERAL. AS WE WORK AS A STATE
RUN LIKE FRONTLINE RESPONDERS
TO THE COCA NINETEEN PANDEMIC.
ANYTHING PARTICULAR AT GROUND
ZERO OF THIS AND- PUBLIC HEALTH
AND ECONOMIC CRISIS WITH THE
VAST MAJORITY OF COOK A
POSITIVE PIECES AND
HOSPITALIZATION. OUR COLLECTIVE
RESPONSE THAT IS GREAT THAT
HAVE BEEN QUESTIONED AGGRESSIVE
WITH A SINGULAR FOCUS ON
PROTECTING THE PUBLIC HEALTH
AND SAFETY AND SAVING LIVES.
WHAT RECOUNTED GREATLY
APPRECIATE THE SUPPORT AND
ASSISTANCE FROM THE STATE AND
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT THIS
CONSIDERABLE EFFORT OF COURSE
COMES AT GREAT EXPENSE. FURTHER
WE ANTICIPATE THAT OUR WORK
WILL CONTINUE TO BE REQUIRED AT
A ROBUST LEVEL FOR MANY MONTHS
FOLLOWING THE LIFTING OF SHORT
TERM PLACE ORDERS. ARE THINKING
THAT SERVICES WILL BE CRITICAL
TO CALIFORNIANS WHO ARE
RECOVERING FROM ILLNESS WHO
HAVE BEEN LAID OFF FROM THEIR
JOBS. AND YOU CONTINUE TO
REQUIRE IN HOME CARE JUST TO
NAME A FEW. AT THE SAME TIME.
FOR THE PROGRAM TO INCREASE. IS
FOR THE PROGRAM. THIS TAX. CAN
YOU WON'T MAKE BACK TO THE MAIN
CENTER OF SPEAKER AND OTHER WE
TO CAN TO WORK IN PART WITH
THAT MUCH TO IN THIS. THROUGH
THE PUBLIC HEALTH AND ECONOMIC
CRISIS TO ENSURE THAT WE HAVE
THE NECESSARY RESOURCES TO KEEP
CALIFORNIANS SAFE AND HEALTHY
WE LOOK FORWARD ONGOING
DISCUSSION THIS WEEK PROGRESS
FROM CRISIS TO RECOVERY THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. AND THAT
COMMENT FROM ERIS ELLIOTT
NAVARRO GO AHEAD. I WANT TO
THANK YOU FOR HOLDING THIS
IMPORTANT BUDGET HEARING DURING
THE UNPRECEDENTED TIME WE AGREE
WITH ASSEMBLY MEMBER AND I'M
GLAD THAT CAL HELP HELP YOU
SURE CHILDREN AND FAMILIES CAN%
ACT THE QUALITY CARE IN THEIR
HOME AND IN THEIR COMMUNITIES
AND WE LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING
WITH YOU TO MAKE THAT POSSIBLE.
EVEN WITH ALL THE ESSENTIAL
ACTION CALIFORNIA LEADERSHIP
HAS ALREADY TAKE MORE IS NEEDED
TO SUPPORT CALIFORNIANS
CHILDREN AND FAMILIES THE
CHILDREN ARE NOT THE MOST
VULNERABLETO THE VIRUS THEY
ARE SOME OF THE MOST VULNERABLE
TO THE CONSEQUENCES IT HAPPENED
CALIFORNIANS CHILDREN HAVING AT
LEAST ONE IMMIGRANT PARENTS WE
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST ADDITIONAL
WORK FOR IMMIGRANT FAMILIES
PLACES WHERE CHILDREN ARE. YEAH
YOUR INSURE. THE MEASURE ACT
THE AND TO OF HEALTH. AND THE
INCLUSION IMMIGRANT THE REALLY
MOVING. WE RECOGNIZE THAT ONE
THREE IS WORK AND HOW IMMIGRANT
WE ASK THAT THE CAN TO THE NEW
TO TRY SO AND THE ESSENTIAL WHO
TO SEND THEIR- TO BE CENTERS
THE TIME THIS THEY CAN TO
PROVIDE RESOURCES THANK SO MUCH.
AND WE HAVE COMMENT FOR WILLIE
DORN PLEASE GOING. THANK YOU I
CAN MEMBER OF THE CA THANK YOU
FOR THIS OPPORTUNITY AND- GREAT
HEARING MY NAME IS LILY
DORNEMANN THE COMMUNITY CLINIC
ASSOCIATION OF LA COUNTY
REPRESENT OVER SIXTY FOUR
MEMBER COMMUNITY CLINICS THAT
OPERATE MORE THAN TO RETURN
FIFTY SITES IN LA COUNTY AND
THIRD MORE THAN ONE POINT SEVEN
MILLION. I THINK YOU WOULD HAVE
STILL IN THE COVERED NINETEEN
WHY MONTH. BUT CENTERS ARE
SEEING A- IN. SERVICES OF THE
FIFTY TO PER. ACCORDING TO A
RECENT. LINK MALICE SAYS LA
HEALTH AND- TO WE HAD NINETY.
MILLION OVER A THREE MONTH
PERIOD ADDITIONALLY MOST OF OUR
MEMBERS WILL HOLD COULD NOT
URGENT DENTAL SERVICES ONLY
PROVIDING EMERGENCY PROCEDURES
WHICH HAS LED TO ROUGHLY
NINETY. AND I'M OPEN COUNTER.
CLINICAL VERY SHORT ON PP AND
CONTINUE FACE THE INTERACTIVE
IMPACTING WORKING CLOSELY THE
AIR LIKE AND BY ECHO THAT MADE
BY MY COLLEAGUE TO REALLY
ENSURE THAT HELPS IN THE
RECEIVE ADDITIONAL FEDERAL
STIMULUS AND I WANT TO THANK
THE LEGISLATURE BUT THE STEPS
TAKEN TO ALLOW YOU TO IMPLEMENT
TELEHEALTH DURING THAT'S GREAT
IT'S THE ABILITY TO BE
REIMBURSED FOR VIRTUAL THAT
THAT WILL BE CRITICAL TO THEIR
ABILITY TO SAFELY PROVIDE CARE.
THANK YOU YOU LENGTHY RECORD.
AS WE AGE AFTER YOU NORMAL
THANK YOU VERY. AND .COM FROM
MIKE A- PLEASED AHEAD. THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS
THIS IS MIKE AT DOCTOR OFF ON
BEHALF OF THE ACLU OF
CALIFORNIA WE REMAIN DEEPLY
CONCERNED ABOUT CONDITIONS AND
CRESCENT JAILS AND DETENTION
CENTERS ACROSS THE STATE AND
THE DISPROPORTIONATE IMPACT
CURRENT CONDITIONS ARE HAVING
ON BLACK AND BROWN
CALIFORNIANS. AS THE HEALTH OF
INCARCERATED INDIVIDUALS
CONTINUES TO DECLINE AND THE
NUMBER OF INFECTED INDIVIDUALS
LIVING AND WORKING WITH
ANYTHING TO CASH AND PRIZES WE
WOULD URGE THE STATE FURTHER
EXPAND THE FREELY MACINNES. AND
INCREASED SAFETY MEASURES WITH
THE THESE. THANK YOU SO MUCH
FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK
AND WE LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING
WITH YOU ON THESE ISSUES MOVING
FORWARD THANK YOU. AND A
COMMENT FROM A LINDA TENERIFE A
LINDA THE LINE IS OPEN. THANK
YOU MEMBERS THIS IS LINDA FROM
THE CALIFORNIA PAN ETHNIC
HEALTH NETWORK WE SUPPORT MEDI
CAL ELIGIBILITY FOR ALL SENIORS
REGARDLESS AND IMMIGRATION
STATUS WE HAVE OF THE NEED TO
LINK THE EDP WITH MEDIC HOW AT
THE POINT OF ENTRY FOR
INTERCEPT ON. WE THINK THAT
EATING OFFERED YOU MORE
MANDATED LANGUAGE ACCESS
REQUIREMENTS BECAUSE NOT ALL
THERE. ARE TRANSLATED. YES YOU
ALSO SUPPORTED CAPACITY THAT
THE VIOS NEED THE HELP AND GOAL
CLIENTS WHO ARE IN NEED OF
HEALTH CARE. YES THAT'S TRUE
PROVIDE MORE BRINGING UP TO IN
GO OVER THE THEY CAN HELP AND
WHILE THEY'RE IN WITH- MOST UP
TO THE INFANT. ALL ALL OF THEIR
INCOME ONLY ON. IT'S TRYING IN
OLD HELP SPECIAL BRING BUDGET.
INTERPRET SHOULD ALL BE YOUR
BILL AT ALL TESTING TREATMENT
FIND. SO THAT MET FOR MY ARE
ONE. AT ASKING I THINK. WE
DON'T UNDER. ON KEEPING ALL BE
WERE. ON DINNER. IN RELATED TO
COVERAGE. AND DEATHS SO THAT WE
CAN UNDERSTAND GREATER
DISPARITY. WE ALSO NEED TO HOLD
THE PH MARK HORRIBLE FOR HOW.
INFORMATION IS BEING USED TO
ALLOCATE RESOURCES. ON HIM EACH
NATION CURTAINS YOU'RE-
THINKING GREAT THANK. AN
ALTERNATE BACK TO OUR SPEAKERS.
GREAT THANK YOU WILL REALLY
APPRECIATE THE PUBLIC FOR
STICKING IN WITH US WE KNOW IS
A VERY LONG HEARING ALSO JUST
WANT TO THANK ALL THE COMMITTEE
MEMBERS WHO CAME TODAY AND
PARTICIPATED IN AND PUT
TOGETHER I THINK A VERY VERY
GOOD HEARING AND AGAIN I START
OFF BY JUST THE STAFF BUT THE-
ENORMOUS WORK WENT TO PUTTING
UP. SPEAKER STAFF LDC OUR
ASSEMBLY RULE STAFF ARE BUDGET
COMMITTEE STAFF MINE MY STAFF
THE ASSEMBLY SERGEANTS- WE KNOW
THAT THIS IS A- DIFFERENT WAY A
NEW WAY OF DOING BUSINESS THAT
WE ARE NOT ALWAYS A CUSTOM TO
BUT WE KNOW THAT. IF WE WANT TO
CONTINUE TO BE A DEMOCRAT GETS
TO INVOLVE THE PUBLIC. SO BE
RESPECTFUL OF PUBLIC OF
GUIDELINES WE KNOW THAT WE HAVE
TO CONTINUE TO DO THINGS THIS
WAY SO WE REALLY APPRECIATE ALL
THE HARD WORK THAT WENT INTO
THIS. THAT WE WILL ADJOURN
THANK YOU.